TWENTY NINTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
MEETING OF THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
COMMITTEE. FOR TO START I WANT
TO THANK ALL THE STAFF
INCLUDING OUR SERGEANTS AND
OTHERS WHO HAVE MADE A RETURN
TO THE CAPITOL TO HEAR BILLS
POSSIBLE. I'M GOING TO READ
SOME INSTRUCTIONS ON. HOW WE
CONDUCT OUR HEARING DURING
COVER NINETEEN TIMES DUE TO
CURRENT ONGOING SAFETY CONCERNS
WE ARE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCING HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. AND THROUGHOUT
THE CAPITAL SO WE CAN ONLY HAVE
A LIMITED NUMBER OF FOLKS WATCH
AND PARTICIPATE. IN THE HEARING
IN PERSON. WE ALSO REQUIRE THAT
MUST BE WORN IN PHYSICAL
DISTANCING BE MAINTAINED BY ALL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC CORE
TESTIFYING. WEATHER HERE IN THE
ROOM OR AT A VIDEO CONFERENCING
SITE. IF YOU DO NOT HAVE A MASK
WE CAN PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU. IT
IS THE CUSTOM AND PRACTICE OF
THE HOUSE THAT MEMBERS BE
PROPERLY ATTIRED. FOR OUR
HEARING. WEARING A MASK IS ALSO
A REQUIREMENT OF BEING PROPERLY
ATTIRED. WE HAD TWENTY SIX
BILLS ARE GENDER I'LL NOTE
THERE FOR BILLS ON CONSENT AND
I'LL MENTION WHICH BILLS THERE
ARE- BECAUSE IT IS LATE ON A
THURSDAY AND MANY MEMBERS NEED
TO CATCH FLIGHTS TO GET BACK TO
THEIR DISTRICTS WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO MOVE VERY EFFICIENTLY
THROUGH OUR GENDER AND I WOULD
ENCOURAGE OUR MEMBERS. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE MOTIONS
EARLY AND OFTEN THEY WOULD BE
VERY WELCOME- WE ALSO HAVE A
NUMBER OF COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WILL BE TESTIFIED WILL BE
PRESENTING BILLS ON BEHALF OF.
OTHER MEMBERS WHO HAD TO CATCH
FLIGHTS WE'RE ASKING AUTHORS TO
GIVE SISON PRESENTATIONS
PARTICULARLY IF A BILL IS NOT
CONTROVERSIAL AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION. EACH BILL CAN HAVE
TWO MAIN WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION EACH MAIN
WITNESS WILL GET UP TO TWO
MINUTES EACH. PLEASE BE ADVISED
THAT FOR OTHER WITNESSES
CALLING IN TO REGISTER
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION. WE ARE
ASKING THAT YOU ONLY STATE YOUR
NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL. SO FOR
EXAMPLE DAVID CHIU. SAN
FRANCISCO SUPPORT. IF YOU SEE
MORE THAN THAT THE OPERATOR
WILL BE INSTRUCTED TO CUT YOU
OFF. IF YOU'RE UNABLE TO GET
THROUGH ON THE PHONE PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO SUBMIT WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE PORTAL.
ON THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE.
THIS WILL BECOME PART OF THE
OFFICIAL RECORD OF THIS BILL-
BECAUSE AT THIS VERY MOMENT WE
HAVE QUORUM I'M GONNA ASK MADAM
SECRETARY IF YOU COULD PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. YOUR. THERE. WE
HAVE A QUORUM GREAT. WE HAVE
SEVERAL OPTIONS TODAY. SO
DEVELOPMENT BANK GO THROUGH. SO
YOU WILL GET THE- APPARENTLY WE
HAD SOME MICROPHONE ISSUES
DURING THE ROLL CALL SO LET'S
JUST GO THROUGH ROLL CALL ONE
MORE TIME MADAM SECRETARY. HERE
HERE. YEAH ALL RIGHT HERE HI
THERE. LEARN HERE HERE. WAIT
OKAY WE STILL HAVE A QUORUM SO
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE OPTIONS
FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY FOR
THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WE CAN
ONLY ACCOMMODATE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
A MINIMUM CONTENTION OF STAFF
SO THAT WE CAN MAINTAIN SIX
FEET OF SPACING THERE'S ALSO
STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOL FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL IF
A MEMBER THE PUBLIC WISHES TO
TESTIFY ON A BILL PLEASE RAISE
YOUR HAND AT THE PROPER TIME OR
STEP UP TO THE MICROPHONE AND I
WILL ALLOW YOU TO TESTIFY. WE
ASK THAT YOU PLEASE NOT TOUCH
THE MICROPHONE AND WHEN YOU
FINISH TESTIFYING PLEASE EXIT
THE HEARING ROOM. OR RETURNS
RECEIPT AND OBSERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING ON LEAVING THE
CAPITAL INCLUDING ELIMINATING.
ELEVATOR USED TO ONE PERSON AT
A TIME. IN ADDITION TO BEING
ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM THE
HEARING ROOM WE HAVE SOME BILL
WITNESSES MAKING USE OF OUR
WITNESS CONFERENCING ROOM- IN
STATE CAPITOL ROOM ONE TWENTY
SEVEN THOSE WITNESSES WILL
APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS
CAN WATCH LIVE TESTIMONY FROM
OUTSIDE HER ROOM. AND ASK
QUESTIONS OF THOSE WITNESSES.
IN ADDITION TO TESTIFYING FROM
INSIDE THE HEARING ROOM
WITNESSES IN THE PUBLIC CAN
MAKE USE OF ONE OF A REMOTE.
TESTIMONY STATIONS LOCATED ON
THE NORTH SIDE OF THE CAPITOL
GROUNDS- SO LITERALLY OUTSIDE
THOSE WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON
THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH
THEIR TESTIMONY LIVE FROM
OUTSIDE THE HEARING ROOM. AND
ALSO HAS SOME QUESTIONS. FOR
DIALING WITNESSES WILL BE USING
A MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALL IN
NUMBER IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR TWO OH TWO YOU
CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN.
IF YOU'RE CALLING IN POLICE
PLAN TO DO SO IS THE AUTHOR OF
THE BILL YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON
IS BEGINNING THEIR
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPOSE
THE BILL. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS. INCLUDES MUTING
YOUR LIVESTREAM BROADCAST AND
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE SOUND
DISTORTION. PLEASE BE ADVISED
IF YOU'RE A MAIN WITNESS
PROVIDING TESTIMONY. YOUR MAIN
ON A LIFELINE AND WILL HAVE TO
MEET YOURSELF UNTIL YOU'RE
CALLED TO SPEAK. IF YOU HAVE
ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE. YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX THREE
ONE NINE. TWO EIGHT FIVE AND MY
COMMITTEE STAFF WILL BE THERE
TO TRY TO HELP. I ALSO WANT TO
GET NOW WE WILL ACCEPT WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE POSITION
LITTLE PORTAL. ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. WE MAY
NEED TO LIMIT HOW LONG THE
PHONE LINES ARE OPEN ON EACH
BILL IS WE'RE GONNA TAKE
HEARING SCHEDULE. AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE AND
UNDERSTANDING SO WITH THAT.
LET'S GO FIRST TO THE CONSENT.
CALENDAR THERE ARE FOUR ITEMS
ON CONSENT. ITEM FOURTEEN A. B.
NINE SIX FIVE LEVINE. ITEM
FIFTEEN AB TEN NINETY FIVE
COOLEY. ITEM TWENTY THREE A. B.
FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE DALY. AND
THE COMMITTEE HOUSING UNLESS
BELT EIGHTY FIFTEEN EIGHTY.
FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOUR CORRECT
MOTION TO APPROVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. AS OUR SECOND.
THERE'S A SECOND MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HI HI YEAH. KILEY HI MORE.
FORTY WORK. THE CONSENT OUT WE
HOLD WILL ALLOW OTHER MEMBERS
TO ADD ON- WANTED JUST MENTION
TWO MORE THINGS- WE HAVE TODAY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD
SUBSTITUTING FOR SIMPLY MEMBER
BRIAN MAIENSCHEIN ON THIS
COMMITTEE. AND WITH THAT I
THINK WE ARE READY TO PROCEED-
SINCE THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
MEMBERS THAT ARE TRYING TO
CATCH FLIGHTS AND OUR FIRST
AUTHOR HAS TO CHAIR A MEETING
THAT'S HAPPENING EXACTLY AT
THIS MOMENT IN THE BANKING
COMMITTEE. I WOULD LIKE FOR US
TO JUMP TO FILE ITEM THIRTEEN
A. B. ELEVEN THIRTY THREE
ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE GRAYSON
WHICH IS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HOUSING ALLOCATION
ACT. MR GRAYSON. ALL. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT TO YOU
ASSEMBLY BILL. ELEVEN THIRTY
FIVE. THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE ARE ALL TOO FAMILIAR
WITH THE CHRONIC LACK OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE
STATE. RECENT ESTIMATES SHOW
THAT THE NEED TO PRODUCE ABOUT
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND NEW AFFORDABLE UNITS
ANNUALLY THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY
NINE IN ORDER TO MEET THE
NEEDS. OF OUR CONSTITUENTS.
BETWEEN TWENTY FIFTEEN AND
TWENTY NINETEEN WE PRODUCED AN
AVERAGE OF JUST NINETEEN
THOUSAND UNITS. WE ARE AN ORDER
OF MAGNITUDE AWAY FROM THE
LEVELS OF PRODUCTION THAT WE
NEED AND THE TRAGIC RESULTS CAN
BE SEEN ON THE STREETS OF
EVERYONE OF OUR DISTRICTS. THE
EXTENT OF THIS PROBLEM DEMANDS
MORE THAN JUST A PIECEMEAL
SOLUTION. WE NEED TO EXAMINE
THE STRUCTURES THAT UNDERPIN
OUR ENTIRE AFFORDABLE HOUSING-FINANCE SYSTEM. AND EXPLORE
TRULY TRANSFORMATIONAL CHANGES
TO THE WAY WE ALLOCATE OUR
FINANCIAL RESOURCES.
UNDERSCORING THIS POINT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR
RECENTLY RELEASED A REPORT
DETAILING SIGNIFICANT
SHORTFALLS IN THE STATE'S
APPROACH TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FINANCE. THE AUDITOR FOUND THAT
THE LACK OF A COORDINATED AND
CENTRALIZED STRUCTURE FOR THE
ALLOCATION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING RESOURCES. HAS REDUCE
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
STATE'S RESPONSE TO OUR HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS.
DEVELOPERS INTERVIEWED FOR THE
AUDIT EXPRESSED THE NEED FOR A
SYSTEM THAT CONSOLIDATES AND
COORDINATES MULTIPLE HOUSING
RESOURCES INTO ONE CENTRALIZED
PROCESS. THE REPORT CONCLUDED
THAT A STANDARD SET OF
REQUIREMENTS CONSISTENT
DEADLINES ANY SINGLE
APPLICATION PROCESS FOR MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING PROGRAMS. WOULD
NOT ONLY REDUCE THE LIKELIHOOD
OF DELAYS FOR APPLICANTS. BUT
COULD ALSO INCREASE THE STATE'S
SUPPLY OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AB ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE ONE ACT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HOUSING
ALLOCATION ACT. WHICH WILL
REQUIRE PCS SIX EIGHT. CAL HFA
ANTIQUE ACT TO ESTABLISH AND
OPERATE A SINGLE CENTRALIZED A
CENTRALIZED HOUSING FUNDING
ALLOCATION COMMITTEE UNDER B.
C. A. S. H. THE COMMITTEE WILL
BE RESPONSIBLE FOR ALLOCATING
STATE CONTROLLED FINANCING. TO
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS AND WILL
SERVE AS THE POINT OF CONTACT
FOR DEVELOPERS SEEKING TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA. IT WILL ALSO
REQUIRE THE COMMITTEE TO CREATE
A UNIFIED APPLICATION AND AWARD
PROCESS FOR THE ALLOCATION OF
STATE CONTROLLED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FUNDS FINALLY THE BILL
REQUIRES THE SECRETARY A BCS
ESTATES TO DEVELOP AN
ORGANIZATIONAL PLAN. FOR THE
HOUSING DEPARTMENT'S IN THE
AGENCY TO STREAMLINE PROCESSES
AND ELIMINATE REDUNDANT TASKS.
AND TO SUBMIT A REPORT ON THAT
PLAN TO THE LEGISLATURE NO
LATER THAN DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO. WITH
ME TODAY TO DISCUSS THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS BILL I HAVE
TWO WITNESSES THE AUDIBLE BETTY
CONTROL OF CALIFORNIA STATE
CONTROLLER AND DINNER- JENNIFER
SEVAK WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS. THANK
YOU THIS TIME WE WILL GO TO OUR
WITNESSES- ONE WE GO FIRST TO
OUR STATE CONTROLLER.
CONTROLLER YEE TO THE OPERATOR
IF YOU COULD PLEASE OPEN A PER
LINE. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY. AT THE CONTROLLER I
SERVED AS A BOARD MEMBER OF P.
CAT CONCERT LACK AND HAVE SEEN
FIRST HAND. HOW WE THE STATE
ARE IN OUR OWN WAY WHEN IT
COMES TO FUNDING AND BUILDING
DESPERATELY NEEDED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. WE CURRENTLY REQUIRE
THOSE SEEKING STATE SUPPORT TO
FINANCE CONSTRUCTION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS TO
WORK THEIR WAY THROUGH A
GAUNTLET OF PROPHECIES AND
REQUIREMENTS FROM NO LESS THAN
FOR STATE DEPARTMENTS.
THEREFORE I'M PLEASED TO
SPONSOR AT ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE
WHICH WILL STREAMLINE THIS
PROCESS AND ENSURE WE DEPLOY
OUR PUBLIC RESOURCE SUPPORT FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING MORE
EFFECTIVELY. AB ELEVEN THIRTY
FIVE CREATES A ONE STOP SHOP
FOR PORTABLE MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING DEVELOPERS TO OBTAIN
TAX EXEMPT BONDS STATE AND
FEDERAL TAX CREDITS AND STATE
SUBSIDIES LOANS. ALIGNING THE
ALLOCATION OF THESE FUNDS UNDER
A SINGLE ENTITY HAD PROCESS
WILL HAVE THREE MAJOR BENEFITS.
FIRST REDUCE THE TIME AND COST
THE STAKEHOLDERS APPLYING FOR
AFFORDABLE HEALTH NEEDS FUNDING
FROM THE STATE. CURRENTLY
PROJECTS MUST GO THROUGH A
MULTI YEAR PROCESS TO RECEIVE
AWARDS FROM EACH CITY SAID
BLACK AND TAKACS. IF THE
PROJECT IS UNSUCCESSFUL IN ANY
ONE COMPETITION DEVELOPERS MUST
REAPPLY OFTEN MULTIPLE TIMES
SLOWING THE TIMELINE AND
INCREASING DEVELOPMENT COSTS.
JUST LOOKS WEAK THE UC BERKELEY
TURNER CENTER ISSUED A REPORT.
ON THE COMPLEXITY OF THE TAX
CREDIT PROGRAM. IT THE
RECOMMENDED TO CREATE A ONE
STOP SHOP APPROACH. ON ONE SO
SHOPPING. APPLIES FOR ALL STATE
FUNDING SOURCES AT ONCE
SHORTENING THE STATE'S FINANCES
TIMELINE TO LESS THAN A YEAR.
IN EACH APPLICATION CYCLE FOR
PROJECT IS AWARDED IT WILL
SHOULD RECEIVE ENOUGH FUNDS TO
COMPLETE THE PROJECT WITHOUT
HAVING TO APPLY FOR OTHER STATE
FUNDING PROGRAMS. SECONDLY IT
REDUCING THE DUPLICATE OF WORKS
THAT IS CURRENTLY BEING
COMPLETED BY MULTIPLE STATE
DEPARTMENTS OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON SPOKE ABOUT AND THAT'S
ARTICULATED IN THE STATE
AUDITOR'S REPORT. AND THIRD
ALLOW FOR MORE EFFICIENT AND
TIMELY DISTRIBUTION OF STATE
CONTROLLED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FUNDS. IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
SO BLOCKS PRIVATE ACTIVITY BOND
A WORK PROCESS BECAME
OVERSUBSCRIBED. WE NOW HAVE TO
BETTER COORDINATE OUR PROGRAMS
TO MAKE THE MOST OF OUR LIMITED
HOUSING RESOURCES. MANY
PROJECTS THAT HAVE RECEIVED
FUNDING FROM H. CD IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS HAVE NOT BEEN BUILT
BECAUSE THEY ARE STILL WAITING
ON COMPETITIVE AWARDS FROM
SUBCOMMITTEE CAC. TO FINALIZE
THE FINANCING STRUCTURE. FOR
EXAMPLE THE LEGISLATURE OUT
FROM THE VOTERS APPROVED THREE
BILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL
OBLIGATION BONDS IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. BUT THESE
BONDS ARE TAKING LONGER THAN
ANTICIPATED TO BE UTILIZED. DUE
TO THESE PROCESS INEFFICIENCIES.
THIS BILL THE FIRST. BUT THE IS
MORE WORK TO DO TO STAY. THE
FOR LONG TERM COMPLIANCE OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THE
GOVERNOR LET. OF THE CREDIT.
INVESTMENT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS WITHOUT
A MORE EFFICIENT ALLOCATION
SYSTEM. MUCH OF THE STATE
FUNDING OF SLAVES TO THROUGH
DELAYS AND UNNECESSARY
BUREAUCRACY. AND THERE'S REALLY
NO REASON TO WAIT UPON THAT
THIS COMMONSENSE PROPOSAL THAT
WILL INCREASE THE SPEED AND
AMOUNT OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH LET'S GO TO THE
SECOND WITNESS. ON THIS AND
THAT WOULD BE JENNIFER SPEC
FROM THE ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS. BUT YOU SURE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE JENNIFER STACK
WITH CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS PARENTS HUNG SUPPORT.
AB ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE SEEKS TO
CONSOLIDATE THE STATE'S HOUSING
FINANCE FUNCTIONS INTO A SINGLE
LOCATION WITH A SINGLE PLANNING
APPLICATION. HOUSING IS IN HIGH
DEMAND BUT IN SHORT SUPPLY IN
CALIFORNIA IS WE'VE BEEN IN THE
PROCESS OF HOUSING SHORTAGE
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY. TWO
COOPERATIVE STATE AUDITOR'S
REPORT CALIFORNIA DOES NOT
CURRENTLY HAVE A SOUND WELL
COORDINATED STRATEGY OR PLAN
FOR HOW TO MOST EFFECTIVELY USE
ITS FINANCIAL RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SHORTAGE LACK OF COORDINATED
HOUSING PLAN IS EVIDENT IN ITS
FOR AGENCIES. MISALIGNED
INCONSISTENT REQUIREMENTS. FOR
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROGRAMS
THEY ADMINISTER. FURTHERMORE
THE NEED FOR OUR STABLE AND HOW
BEEN ONE OF THE- PRIORITY FOR.
FAMILIES BIG FURNITURE HOUSING
ONE OF THE SIGNIFICANT
FINANCIAL COMMITMENT
CALIFORNIANS UNDERTAKEN THEIR
DAY TO DAY LIVES. FURTHERMORE
HOUSING AND HOUSING RELATED
ACTIVITIES ARE OF PRIMARY
IMPORTANCE TO THE PEOPLE OF THE
STATE AND WARRANTS LIKE CLEAR
IN UNIFIED FOCUS OF STATE
GOVERNMENT RESOURCES.
ADDITIONALLY BECAUSE OF THE
REPUBLIC TO PERMANENT SOURCE
FOR AFFORDABLE WORKFORCE
HOUSING AND APPROVED OTHER
FINANCIAL RESOURCES DEDICATED
HOUSING OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS. THESE CONVERSATIONS ARE
ONLY EXPECTED TO GET MORE
COMPLICATED AS WE CONTINUE TO
TRY TO ADDRESS THIS CRISIS. AND
ESTABLISH MORE RESOURCES. FOR
THOSE FOLLOWING THE STATE
POLICY DEVELOPMENT PROCESS AND
THERE'S CLEARLY BEEN A LACK OF
INTER AGENCY COORDINATION.
COMMUNICATION BREAKDOWN OFTEN
LEADS TO COMPETING PROGRAMS ARE
DEPICTED AFFECTS. THE LACK OF
COORDINATED AND CENTRALIZE
STRUCTURES TO MANAGEMENT AND
ALLOCATION OF HOUSING
RESOURCES. HAS REDUCED THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF OUR STATE'S
RESPONSE TO OUR HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS. CREATING
A ONE STOP SHOP FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FINANCE WILL REDUCE
REDUNDANT PROCESSES. CREATE
OPERATIONAL EFFICIENCIES AND
MAKE BETTER USE OF THE STATE'S
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DOLLARS.
MAYBE ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE WILL
HELP FOCUS THE STATE'S EFFORTS
TO SOLVE THE STATE'S HOUSING
SUPPLY CRISIS AND FOR THESE
REASONS WE- RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST TRY THOUGH. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THEIR TESTIMONY
AT THIS TIME WE WILL HEAR
TESTIMONY FROM THE OPPOSITION-
LIKE TO INVITE UP- THE
TREASURER OF OUR STATE
TREASURER MARK. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CHAIR CHU AND YOUR
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
IN THIS HOUSING CRISIS. WHEN I
WAS ELECTED STATE TREASURER IN
TWENTY NINETEEN I HOSTED A
FIFTEEN CITY LISTENING TOUR. AS
CHAIR UP TO CATCH AND SEDLAK I
PERSONALLY CHAIRED AND ATTENDED
EVERY MEETING IN TWENTY TWENTY
AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THAT'S
TWENTY ONE SAID LIKE MEETINGS
AND FOURTEEN T. CAC MEETINGS
LAST YEAR. LAST YEAR WE WERE
COLLABORATIVE LEE WAS CITIES
COUNTIES LOCAL AUTHORITIES
DEVELOPERS AND ATTORNEYS TO
COMPLETE A MAJOR OVERHAUL. OF
THE SAID LACK ANTI CAP
REGULATIONS WHICH HAS NOT BEEN
DONE IN FIFTEEN YEARS. WE ALSO
APPROVED A RECORD NUMBER OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS IN
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY AND ARE ON
TRACK THIS YEAR TO EXCEED LAST
YEAR'S NUMBERS. WE ALSO
EXPEDITED OUR REGULATORY REFORM
PROCESS TO QUICKLY IMPLEMENT AB
ONE OH ONE. WE FIX LEGACY
ISSUES LIKE THE CARRY FORWARD
ISSUE THAT WAS MENTIONED IN THE
AUDITOR'S REPORT WHICH WAS
WHICH HAPPENED UNDER TO. UP
TREASURES AGO. WE OVERSAW A NEW
NINETY EIGHT MILLION FEDERAL
DISASTER TAX CREDIT PROGRAM
CALLAGY IF THEY WON A NATIONAL
AWARD FOR OUR JOINT APPLICATION
PROCESS WE ROLLED OUT A NEW T.
CATCH AND SAID LIKE JOINT
APPLICATION THIS YEAR. EIGHTY
FOUR THIRTY FOUR WHICH WAS
PASSED BY THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR REQUIRES H. C. D.
TO BETTER ALIGN THEIR SIX MAJOR
FUNDING SOURCES AND THEY WILL
ALSO BETTER ALIGN WITH PARTY
CAC AND SEDLAK PROCESSES. TO
PUT IT IN THE SIMPLEST FORMS
SIMPLEST TERMS THE SYSTEM IS
WORKING. I CAN SAY THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS THE MOST
EFFICIENT OPEN AND TRANSPARENT
PROCESS FOR ALLOCATING AND
AWARDING TAX CREDITS AND BONDS
COMPARED TO ANY OTHER STATE IN
THE UNITED STATES. WE HAVE A
SYSTEM THAT IS ACCOUNTABLE TO
ELECTED OFFICIALS AND
RESPONSIVE TO THE NEEDS. ME
EMPHASIZES AGAIN. IN THIS TIME
OF CRISIS OUR SYSTEM IS WORKING.
CERTAINTY OF EXECUTION IS KEY
TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS PROPOSING A WHOLE
NEW OVERHAUL AT THIS TIME IS
RISKY AND CREATES UNCERTAINTY
IN THE MARKET PLACE. THIS BILL
IS TRYING TO SOLVE A PROBLEM
THAT DOESN'T EXIST. INSTEAD OF
EXPEDITING HOUSING THIS
LEGISLATION COULD
UNINTENTIONALLY HAMPERING. IT
COULD BURY THE FOR HOUSING
AGENCIES UNDER ANOTHER LEVEL OF
BUREAUCRACY. IT WILL FORCE A
DISRUPTIVE TRANSITION AT A TIME
WHEN WHAT IS NEEDED IS
STEADFASTNESS STEADY
STEADINESS. AND I BELIEVE IT
WILL STIFLE AND SLOW DOWN OUR
CURRENT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PRODUCTION WHICH IS PERFORMING
AT ITS HIGHEST LEVEL THAN EVER.
I ALSO BELIEVE THERE NEEDS TO
BE A SEPARATION OF DUTIES
BETWEEN HOUSING POLICY AND
HOUSING FINANCING. IN THE PAST
THERE HAVE BEEN GOVERNOR'S THAT
DID NOT SUPPORT FOR WORK IN
DIFFERENT TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. SO HAVING ALL THE
HOUSING DECISIONS AND FINANCING
UNDER ONE ROOF WOULD REMOVE
COMPETITION AND CREATE A
POLITICAL SYSTEM WHERE STAFF
PICKS AND CHOOSES THEIR
FAVORITE PROJECTS. I REAFFIRM
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
SHOULD BE THE POLICY ARM AND
THE CHARGERS OFFICE SHOULD BE
THE FINANCING ARM. WE ARE
WORKING COLLABORATIVE LEE WITH
OUR SISTER AGENCIES AND ARE
SURPASSING EXPECTATIONS AS WE
STRIVE TO HIT THE GOVERNOR'S
GOAL A THREE POINT FIVE MILLION
NEW HOMES BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
I AM ALL IN FAVOR OF REFORM
WHEN NEEDED. I WAS ELECTED TO
THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN. AND WHEN I
CHAIRED THE BOARD IN MY SECOND
YEAR. I REQUESTED THREE OUTSIDE
AUDITS THAT RESULTED IN THE
LARGEST REFORM. THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION HISTORY AND MOVE
THE ADMINISTRATION AN APPEALS
PROCESS UNDER THE GOVERNOR
WHICH WAS MUCH NEEDED. HOWEVER
THE STATE'S HOUSING AGENCIES IS
A DIFFERENT SCENARIO. THE MAIN
PROBLEM WE HAVE MEMBERS IS THE
LACK OF BOND ALLOCATION WHICH
IS LIMITED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND IS OUTSIDE OF
THE STATE'S CONTROL. WE NEED
COMPREHENSIVE HOUSING SOLUTIONS
NOT A PIECEMEAL APPROACH AS A
FORMER LEGISLATURE LEGISLATOR
MAJORITY WHIP AND SPEAKER PRO
TEM OF THE ASSEMBLY AND ACTIVE
AND ACCESSIBLE STATE OFFICER. I
FULLY COMMIT TO WORKING WITH
YOU TO GET US THERE. HOWEVER
THIS BILL AS PROPOSED IS NOT
WHAT IS NEEDED AND MAY
EXACERBATE THE PROBLEM. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO VOTE NO
ON THIS BILL BECAUSE IT IS NOT
GOING TO CREATE OR EXPEDITE NEW
HOUSING PRODUCTION IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LET'S GO TO THE
SECOND OPPOSITION WITNESS
MISTER BEN BARKER FROM THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL FINANCE A
THIRTY. FIRST I'D LIKE TO THINK
CHAIR CHIU IN YOUR COMMITTEE
FOR THE LEADERSHIP FOR THE
LEADERSHIP WORKING TO HELP FIX
THE HOUSING CRISIS I'D ALSO
LIKE TO THANK THE HONORABLE
TREASURE MOFFETT LEADERSHIP AND
GUIDANCE. THROUGH THE MAJOR
OVERHAUL OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
REGULATIONS THAT HAPPENED
THROUGHOUT THE LAST TWO YEARS.
I AM BEN BARKER FINANCIAL
ADVISER TO THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL FINANCE AUTHORITY
ALSO KNOWN AS THE SEEM OF FAYE
WHICH IS THE MOST ACTIVE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CONDUIT BOND
ISSUER IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE ISSUED
BONDS FOR HUNDREDS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. ONE POINT
OF REFERENCE THE CM A FACE
EMITTED MORE THAN SIXTY FIVE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING
APPLICATIONS. TO SAID LIKE
ANTIQUE ACT IN THE FIRST ROUND
OF THIS YEAR. THIS IS MORE THAN
ALL OTHER ISSUERS COMBINED IN
THE STATE. AS THE LARGEST
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ISSUE WHERE
WE'RE SURPRISED THAT NOBODY HAS
REACHED OUT FOR OUR INPUT ON
THIS BILL. AB ELEVEN THIRTY
FIVE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
HOUSING ALLOCATION ACT
ADDRESSES THE WRONG ISSUES.
OVERWHELMING ISSUE WITH HOUSING
ALLOCATION IS THAT CALIFORNIA
NEEDS MORE. THE FEDERAL THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. I'M SORRY
THE STATE RECEIVES AROUND FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS OF ALLOCATION
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
AND WE COULD USE MORE THAN
DOUBLE THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA CANNOT CHANGE THAT
ONLY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
CAMP. YESTERDAY SAID LIKE
ALLOCATED MORE THAN ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN BONDS WELL IT HAD
REQUEST FOR OVER THREE BILLION
DOLLARS IN BONDS. IT IN OTHER
WORDS WE'RE THREE TIMES
OVERSUBSCRIBED. AND THIS IS
MORE THAN ANY OTHER ROUND IN
THE HISTORY OF SELECT WHICH
SHOWS THAT THE CURRENT SYSTEM
IS CURRENTLY WORKING.
CALIFORNIA AFFORDABLE MULTI
FAMILY RENTAL HOUSING PROJECTS
ARE LARGELY FINANCED BY. TAXES
ON BONDS AND TAX CREDITS ONE OF
THE CRITICAL TENETS TO FINANCE
HIS CERTAINTY OF EXECUTION.
CALIFORNIA HAS AN OPEN
UNDERSTANDABLE TRANSPARENT AND
ACCOUNTABLE PROCESS FOR
AWARDING ALLOCATION OF STATE
CEILING. ON QUALIFIED PRIVATE
ACTIVITY BONDS. THIS PROCESS
HAS BEEN REFINED OVER MANY
YEARS AND MOVING AND MOVING THE
PROCESS RIGHT NOW WOULD PROVIDE
UNCERTAIN INTEREST. NEITHER
WHICH WILL HELP DURING A
HOUSING CRISIS MY PARTNERS AND
I IN A DIFFERENT CAPACITY HAVE
FACILITATED TAX EXEMPT BOND
TRANSACTIONS IN OVER THIRTY
FIVE STATES. THE ALLOCATION OF
VOLUME CAP IN OTHER STATES IS
LESS. EFFICIENT TRANSPARENT AND
EFFECTIVE IN CALIFORNIA THE
LARGEST U. AS THE LARGEST USER
USER OF THIS PROGRAM WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PRODUCTION COULD BE
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED. BY MOVING
THE ALLOCATION PROCESS FROM THE
TREASURE'S OFFICE WITH DECADES
OF EXPERIENCE TO SOMEWHERE ELSE
WE BELIEVE THE CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT AND WE WORKED
DILIGENTLY WITH THE STATE
TREASURER'S OFFICE AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS UP. STATEMENT FOR
THE SAID LIKE REGULATIONS TO
MAKE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ALLOCATION PROCESS MORE
EFFICIENT. EVERYTHING CONTAINED
WITHIN THIS BILL CAN BE DONE
PROCEDURALLY. THERE IS NO FIX
IS THE NEED TO BE DONE ON A
LEGISLATIVE LEVEL. CURRENTLY
THIS IS ALL IN PROCESS BETWEEN
KICKED HE TEXTED LACK H. IN
COLLEGE AFFECT FOR A ONE FOR
ONE APPLICATION ONE STOP
PROCESS. AGAIN THIS IS NOT NEED
TO BE DONE UNDER LEGISLATIVE
MANNER. THE LAST THING THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING COMMUNITY
NEEDS IS REVAMPING THE PROCESS
RIGHT AFTER THE STAKEHOLDERS
WORKED FOR YEARS TO REPENT
DIDN'T GO TO THE LARGEST REVAMP
TO HAPPEN LAST YEAR. AGAIN THIS
CREATES UNCERTAINTY AND THE
LACK OF EXECUTION. THIS BILL
WILL NOT PRODUCE A SINGLE UNIT.
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU FOR A NO
VOTE ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE WILL NOW GO TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT WISH
TO. EDUCATOR SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL IF THERE ANY MEMBERS IN
THE HEARING ROOM. IF THERE ANY
NUMBERS ON THE ROUTE LINE. IF
THERE ARE ANY MEMBERS ON THE
OPERATOR LINE OPERATOR IF YOU
COULD PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
SUPPORT A. B. ELEVEN THIRTY
FIVE. AND IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF AB ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE THESE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT OF
AB. ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE. AND AT
THIS TIME WE DO HAVE ABOUT
EIGHT IN THE QUEUE. WE'LL START
WITH NUMBER TWO THIRTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ACCURACY ON
THE APPLE HEALTHCARE CALIFORNIA
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN
THIRTY FIVE. NEXT TO BE NUMBER
TWO SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
RANDY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION AND
IT'S HEALTHY HOUSING FOUNDATION
I IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR THIS
TRANSFORMATIONAL BILL THANK YOU.
ABOUT ALIGN ONE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS DERREN
BROWN'S KEY WITH USA PROPERTIES
I ACTUALLY PRESSED INTO EARLY
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL. NEXT TO BE
NUMBER ONE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON. JERRY TO
MAKE IT ARGUE BELT OKAY
CALIFORNIA PARTNERS FOR FIVE OF
THEM. EVAN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS. THEY- YEAH. AND ASK AT
THE PORT. NEXT TO BE NUMBER
THREE OH THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THREE THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS IS BILL MURPHY WITH ALL
THIS KIND OF ACTION SO CAL AND
MARK L. CHAPTERS. IN STRONG
SUPPORT. NEXT IN LINE THREE OH
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS
IS SANDRA AND I WILL AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF IT. NOW GO TO LINE
ONE SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BRIAN DO LITTLE OF WEST
HOLLYWOOD I AM IN SUPPORT.
TEXAS NUMBER TWO SIXTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS DIDN'T
GET OR PADDING I WOULD
RESIDENTS UNITED NETWORK AND
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORT HIGH.
HOW YOU. NOW BEEN ALIGNED TO
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS KATHERINE HEDGES AND I
HAD TO PURCHASE A. B. ELEVEN
THIRTY FIVE. NEXT TO ME NUMBER
TWO NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I CAN FRANKEN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AT THE CENTER FOR
SUSTAINABLE NEIGHBORHOODS THAT
AREN'T SUPPORT THANK. YOU WILL
NOW GO TO LINE TWO SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. EARLIER THIS
SUPPORT FOR THE STARTED BATES
MURPHY A MEMBER OF RESIDENTS
UNITED NETWORK AN ECHO THANK
YOU. AT THIS TIME WE CURRENTLY
HAVE NO OTHERS IN THE QUEUE FOR
SUPPORT PLEASE CONTINUE THANK
YOU LET'S NOT GO TO MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC THE WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC HERE IN THE
CHAMBER. OF THE REMOTE STATIONS
SEE NOW LET'S GO TO THE
OPERATOR LINE OPERATOR PLEASE
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
OPPOSITION TO AB ELEVEN. THIRTY
FIVE. AND NOW HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB ELEVEN THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION
TO AB. ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE. BUT
THIS TIME WE DO OF ABOUT NINE
IN THE QUEUE. THAT WILL START
WITH LINE ONE EIGHTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS JIM
ANDERSON WITH CHELSEA
INVESTMENT CORPORATION AND WE
ARE IN OPPOSITION THE BILL.
ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE. NEXT TO BE
NUMBER ONE OH TWO IS GOOD. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS JAMES SUFFER
WHAT PRESIDENT THAT AFFIRMED
HOUSING WE ARE IN OPPOSITION.
TO ONE ONE THREE FIVE. NOW GO
TO LINE TWO FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M CONSTRUCTING A GROUP
OF. NOW GO TO LINE TWO EIGHTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. JERRY
MEMBERS CAITLIN JOHNSON WITH
POLITICAL SOLUTIONS ON BEHALF
OF PATRICK STABLE HOUSE AND THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
OPPOSITION. NEXT TO BE ALIGNED
TO THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS DUSTIN
AWKWARDNESS AND REGROUP I
OPPOSE. SO THE LINE ONE SIXTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. JONATHAN
CALLERI CALIFORNIA'S STATEWIDE
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT ACCORDING
WERE IN OPPOSITION TO AB.
ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE. SO LITTLE
LINE TO TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TWENTY SEVEN LINES OPEN.
PHOTO LINE ONE OH SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS LORRAINE CAN
READ ON BEHALF OF NATIONAL
COMMUNITY RENAISSANCE THE FIFTH
LARGEST NONPROFIT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPER OWNER IN THE
NATION STRONGLY OPPOSES A. B.
ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE THANK YOU.
TO BE ALIGNED TO SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MELISSA BLOCK
I AM THE FORMER CHAIRED AROUND
COMMUNITY LAND TRUSTS FORMER
IRVINE CITY COUNCIL MEMBER I'M
ATTACK ATTORNEY A WORKING IN
THE AREA OF A PORTABLE HOUSING
FOR TAX CREDITS AND BOND AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING A NO
VOTE ON THE BILL. NEXT IS GOING
TO BE ALIGNED TO- ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ANDREW HANNAH WITH-
GLOBAL PREMIER DEVELOPMENT I
STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B. ELEVEN
THIRTY FIVE AND I'M ASKING- FOR
NOVA. THANK YOU. WE HAVE NUMBER
ONE NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI LAUREN DELGADO
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD
OF THE CALIFORNIA PORTABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT ASSOCIATION
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
NUMBER THREE OH NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MARKER BEING URBAN
HOUSING COMMUNITIES HAMMERING
OPPOSE THE BILL. AND NEXT OVER
THE LINE TO TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH HELLO. MY SEE
YOU VILE DATES HOW TO DATE AND
I'M OPPOSED TO IT PLEASE VOTE
NO THANK YOU. WE'RE. THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO FURTHER IN THE
QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION PLEASE
CONTINUE MISTER CHAIR. THANK
ARE MUCH ON A BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE- I WANT TO STATE
A FEW WORDS- JUST TO LET MY
PERSPECTIVE I KNOW A NUMBER OF
YOU HAVE COME UP TO ME THE LAST
FEW HOURS ASKING ABOUT THIS.
LET ME START BY SAYING THAT I
HAVE- SURE THE GREATEST RESPECT
FOR TREASURE. I KNOW SHE IS
DOING THE BEST SHE CAN DURING
THIS TIME PERIOD FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT NOTE THIS AND LET THE
RECORD REFLECT MY PERSPECTIVE.
THIS BILL DOES NOT REFLECT
ANYTHING ON HER LEADERSHIP OR
HER WORK- AND I ALSO WANT TO
MENTION THAT- THE TREASURE AND
I HAD A CHANCE TO SPEAK ABOUT
THIS FOR THE FIRST TIME A FEW
DAYS AGO. WHEN I LEARNED ABOUT
THE OPPOSITION- AFTER RATES UP
THE BILL AND INDICATED MY
SUPPORT FOR THIS CONVERSATION-
LET ME SAY THIS I THINK IT'S
FAIR TO SAY THAT THE
COMPLEXITY. OF STATE FINANCING
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING HAS LONG
BEEN AN ISSUE. THIS IS PREDATED
THIS GOVERNOR PREDATED THIS
TREASURE THIS CONTROLLER AS WE
HAVE. BEEN TRYING TO GRAPPLE
WITH OUR HOUSING CRISIS I THINK
IT'S ALSO FAIR TO SAY THAT IN
RECENT YEARS WE HAVE INFUSED
MORE MORE MONEY INTO THE
SYSTEM. OUR PRIVATE ACTIVITY
BOND HAS BECOME MUCH MORE
COMPETITIVE THAT COMPLEXITY HAS
INTENSIFIED AND THE REALITY IS
WE'VE HAD FOUR DIFFERENT
ENTITIES HCD. TELL EACH OF A.
T. CAC SET LACK. THAT ARE ALL
PART OF THIS PUZZLE- AND I
THINK IT'S ALSO FAIR TO SAY
THEY'RE DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES
ON WHETHER. HE'S HOUSING
SYSTEMS ARE WORKING AND WHETHER
THIS IS THE MOST EFFICIENT WAY
THAT WE CAN DO IT- AND I HAVE
THOUGHT IT IS IMPORTANT TO HAVE
A CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW WE
BETTER ALIGN OUR HOUSING
FINANCING SYSTEM. WHICH IS WHY
I THOUGHT INITIALLY WHY THIS IS
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION. UP TO
OTHER OBSERVATIONS I THINK IT'S
FAIR TO SAY THAT NONE OF US IF
WE HAD BUILT THE SYSTEM FROM
SCRATCH WOULD HAVE DIVIDED THE
RESPONSIBILITIES UP IN THE WAY
THAT WE HAVE- BUT GIVEN WHERE
WE ARE. IT'S A FAIR QUESTION A
WHAT WE DO MOVING FORWARD- AND
THEN ALSO JUST POINT OUT AND
THIS I KNOW IS SOMETHING THAT
WE DISCUSSED WITH THE AUTHOR.
THIS BILL DOES NOT ELIMINATE.
THESE AGENCIES IT SIMPLY SAYS
THAT WE ARE ASKING OR SAID J.
THE JOINT ESTABLISHED. AND THE
OP. OF A SINGLE HOUSING FUNDING
ALLOCATION COMMITTEE SO- NUANCE
IN THIS- BUT I HAVE ASKED THE
AUTHOR. IF THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD FROM THIS COMMITTEE TO
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE. THE DIVERSE
STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS TOPIC I
SUSPECT HE- KNOWS THAT THERE'S
A LOT OF WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE AND- AND I KNOW HE'S
COMMITTED TO DOING THAT SO.
JUST WANTED TO SHARE MY
PERSPECTIVE AND OF COURSE OPEN
UP TO OTHERS FOR COMMENT.
MISTER CAR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- AND I THINK THAT YOU
LAID OUT OF A PERSPECTIVE IN
AND- THE THAT I THINK- I SHARE.
I HAVE GREAT RESPECT FOR THE
AUTHOR AND I KNOW THAT HE- PUTS
A LINE A LOT OF TIME AND ENERGY
TRYING TO FIND. COLLABORATION
AND- IN IN GETTING TO- THE END
RESULT I ALSO TREMENDOUS
RESPECT FOR OUR TREASURER KNOWS
THAT SHE'S SHE DOES THE SAME. I
DON'T KNOW BASED UPON- THE-
NATURE OF THE OPPOSITION
THERE'S GOING TO BE AN ABILITY
TO GET TO THAT COMPROMISED
POSITION BUT I CERTAINLY WANT
TO GIVE THE AUTHOR THE BENEFIT
OF THE OF THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TRY- AND YOU KNOW WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD I THINK THERE'S
CERTAINLY ROOM FOR SO
EFFICIENCIES BUT- MID TO THE
UPPER OF THE TREASURES POINT
THEN THERE'S ALSO BEEN A LOT OF
GREAT WORK DONE UNDER THE
CURRENT SYSTEM AND SO WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE WE'RE NOT. GETTING
IN OUR OWN WAY OF THAT WELL
TRYING TO FIND AN EFFICIENT
MANNER REARDING THE FUNDING
AND I DON'T PRETEND TO KNOW
WHAT THE END SOLUTION IS BUT I
DO. TRUST THE AUTHOR THE TO PUT
THE TIME AND ENERGY AND TO TRY
TO GET TO THAT POINT SO I'LL BE
SUPPORTING IT WITH THAT WITH
THOSE CADETS AND APPRECIATE ALL
THE WORK. IS PUT IN. BEEN PUT
INTO IT. THANK YOU LETTER
KNOWLEDGE. ABOUT OUR COLLEAGUES
AND NETWORK. THEY YOU CHAIR
WHEN THEY THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS. ON AND YOU KNOW
WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE BILL
AS PRESENTED IN SOME OF THE-
STORIES YOU HEAR OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY FROM AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS ARE THOSE
TRYING TO SEEK FUNDING. WE KNOW
THAT CENTRALIZING THESE
OPPORTUNITIES INTO ONE SPACE
CAN BE A GOOD THING- DIFFERENT
POTS OF MONEY AND HOW SOMETIMES
THE INTER RELATE WITH EACH
OTHER. I THINK REALLY
NECESSITATE THAT WE NEED THAT
COORDINATION IT'S ENCOURAGING
TO HEAR FROM OUR TREASURER AS
WELL. THAT THEE OBSERVATIONS
THAT SHE'S ACTIVELY WORKING ON
RIGHT NOW AND I APPRECIATE IT.
VERY STRONGLY YOUR COMMENTS AS
WELL THAT YOU BROUGHT AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR. ALL THE
WORK YOU ARE DOING YOU CONTINUE
TO DO AND YOU WILL BE DOING IN
THE FUTURE- INTO SPACE AND AS
I'M TRYING TO KIND OF RECONCILE
THIS I DON'T WANT THIS TO
BECOME- FOR ME MAYBE A TURF
WAR. I WANT THIS TO WORK WELL.
AND AS YOU'RE CONSIDERING AND
THANK YOU ON. SOME OF OUR
GRAYSON AS WELL FOR. YOUR
INTERESTING CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH ALL THESE PARTIES I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT- I HAVE HEARD
FROM AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS IN MY DISTRICT- AND
SOME OF THOSE HAD DIALED IN
TODAY AS WELL WITH THEIR
CONCERN AND SO WHEN I'M- WHEN
I'M WHEN I'M NERVOUS ABOUT- I
THINK WHAT I'M- MAYBE UPPER
FLOODING ON THEIR NERVOUSNESS
IS THAT. YOU KNOW WHETHER MAYBE
IMPERFECTIONS WHILE WE CAN BE
WORKING ON SOME OF THESE IT
PROCESS FISHING SEES. THEY DO
KNOW HOW TO WORK THE SYSTEM. TO
BE ABLE TO MAKE PROJECTS
WORKING WE CAN'T DISRUPT. THAT
EITHER AND SO IF WE ARE STILL
HARD. PASSED ON SENDING US. YOU
KNOW- DEEP BE ABLE TO SEE.
THESE ASSIST. AND OPERATE AND-
WE MIGHT BE INJECTING A LITTLE
BIT OF RISK AND THAT THAT THAT
THAT THAT COULD BE US SPELL
SOME DANGER- I. MIGHT INVITE
YOU TO CONSIDER IS YOU'RE
CONSIDERING SOME THESE
IMPROVEMENTS- KEY- SPECIFIC
REQUIREMENT MAYBE NOT A HARD
FAST TRIGGER DATE. I CERTAINLY
WANT TO SEE WHAT A STRUCTURE
COULD LOOK LIKE ABOUT SOME KIND
OF A UNIFORM OUT LOCATION AND
YOU KNOW SORT OF A CONSOLIDATED
EFFORT HERE- BETWEEN ALL THESE
ENTITIES- BUT MAYBE THAT
TRIGGERED IT WOULD BE ON THE
CONDITION. OF AN AGREEMENT.
BETWEEN THE HEAD AND- HEAD.
LEADERS OF EACH OF THOSE
ENTITIES OF HFA IN B. C. S. H.
AN EIGHT CITY THX AT LAX- AND
THEN I THINK THE- OTHER KEY
POINT AS WELL. IS WHO IS REALLY
GOING TO BE THE THAT THE
CONVENER OF ALL THIS WHETHER
THAT'S HOUSING PCS AGE. WELL
THAT'S HOUSED IN THE C.
TREASURER'S OFFICE HAVING TO
RAISE A GOOD POINT ABOUT A
SEPARATION OF POWERS ISSUE- I
THINK THOSE ARE. MAYBE SOME OF
THE THINGS YOU WANT TO DRILL
INTO AND EVERYTHING SO I'D LIKE
TO. BE ABLE TO SEE THIS MOVE
FOR IT COULD BE HELPFUL. TO THE
ORIGINAL INTENT OF THIS-
WORKING ON THE DETAILS. I THINK
IT'S GOING TO BE- JUST
EVERYTHING. LIKE TO KNOW SHOW
SOME. WHAT THANK YOU MISTER SHE-
AND I. TO THANK YOU THREE THE
BILL UP I WANT TO LINE.
COMMENTS WITH. THE THAT ARE
MADE. MY MAKE. FROM SAN DIEGO
IN SAN JOSE AS WELL- I DO
BELIEVE THE TREASURES BEEN
DOING GREAT WORK- AND HAS BEEN
WORKING VERY HARD TRYING TO
STREAMLINE AND BRINGS TOGETHER
I THINK THE AUTHOR IN THE
TREASURE SHARE THE SAME.
OVERALL GOAL- TO ENSURE THAT.
WE CAN BUILD MORE QUICKLY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
COMMUNITIES THAT NEED IT SO
DESPERATELY- SO I THINK WE'RE
ALL. WORKING TOWARDS THE RIGHT
GOAL. I WOULD JUST URGE THE
AUTHOR WHO I THINK IS- WELL
RESPECTED AND NOW. A GREAT
AUTHOR ON AND VERY THOROUGH.
JUST TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
DIALOGUE- WITH THE TREASURE
WITH OPPOSITION AND FOLKS THAT
CALLED IN AND MAKING SURE THAT
WERE REALLY FLUSHING THIS OUT.
OF NOT HAVING ANY SORT OF
NEGATIVE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES AND I KNOW YOU
WILL BUT JUST WANNA- ECHOED THE
SAME COMMENTS AND- ALSO FOR THE
BILL TODAY BUT- HOPEFULLY
HOPEFULLY YOU'LL- YOU'LL KEEP
ON. AT MORE DIALOGUE IS NEEDED
THANK YOU. ANY FINAL. TO
REVISED. THANK YOU ARE SO I
AGREE WITH ALL THE COMMENTS
WE'VE HEARD SO FAR AND I THINK
WE'RE WE STRUGGLE SOMETIMES IS
WHAT WE HEAR AND FROM OUR
CONSTITUENTS OUT THERE
INCLUDING THE PEOPLE WHO BUILD
THESE FIRST THESE ARE
COMMUNITIES- AND THEN WHAT WE
HEARING HERE AND WHAT I FIND
OUT WHAT I WHAT I GRAPPLE WITH
IS IT SOMETIMES. THERE ARE
PEOPLE HAVE FIGURED OUT THE
CURRENT PROCESS AND ARE JUST
LIKE I JUST WANT TO DO THAT AND
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO CHANGE
AGAIN AND THEN THERE ARE PEOPLE
THAT HAVE BEEN HOPELESSLY
STRUGGLING TO GET THEIR
PROJECTS THROUGH THIS
UNCOORDINATED SYSTEM THAT MIGHT
BECOME COORDINATED THEY JUST
DON'T KNOW YET- SO YOU KNOW AND
THAT'S THAT'S WHERE I KIND OF
WENT ON THAT AND THAT'S OF THE
Y. JOIN YOU ON THIS IS. IS IT
YOU KNOW IT I THINK THESE ONE
STOP SHOP A CONCEPTS ARE GOOD
IT DOESN'T MEAN IT'S TAKING OUT
ANY PARTICULAR AGE ENTITY BUT
IT'S HELPING PEOPLE WHO ARE
COMING INTO THE SYSTEM WHO
MIGHT NOT BE AS FAMILIAR SOME
OF THESE OTHER FOLKS GET IN AND
YOU GET INTO A PROCESS WHERE
IT'S NOT SO FRUSTRATING I KNOW
AND- THERE CITIES IN MY
DISTRICT ARE. TRYING
DESPERATELY TO MEET THEIR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING RENO NUMBERS
AND THERE ARE THESE PROJECTS
HAVE BEEN SITTING IN THE IN THE
HOPPER FOR THREE OR FOUR YEARS
NOW WITH THIS FINANCING DILEMMA
AND- AND YES PART OF IT IS A
BONDING WE CAN FIX THAT IF WE
KNOW WHAT WHAT THE PROBLEM IS-
SO I LIKE EVERYONE ELSE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THIS MOVE FORWARD.
AND CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE-
WELL RESPECTED TREASURER ON ON
IT SEEN EXACTLY WHAT THINGS ARE
GOING TO BE HAPPENING THAT ARE
GOING TO FIX THIS PROBLEM- BUT
I YEAH CONCEPT OF STREAMLINING
ENABLE ENABLING PEOPLE HAVE ONE
STOP SHOP I THINK IS A GOOD
CONCEPT AND NOT AND THAT'S. WHY
I'M SUPPORTING IT TODAY. MR
CALLING. I THINK THAT'S GOOD
QUICK QUESTION TREASURE. A
TREASURY RIGHT HERE IN YOUR
LETTER OF OPPOSITION THAT- THAT
THE BUREAUCRATIC OVERHAUL THAT
AB ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE CALLS FOR
WOULD UNDERMINE MANY OF THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS REFORMS AND
SYNERGIES. I THAT IT PUT IN
PLACE- GOOD TIME YOU'VE BEEN
CHARGED TO COMMITTEES WHAT
REASON YOU HAVE TO BELIEVE THAT
IF THEY HAVE A NEW HOME THAT
YOU KNOW YOUR REFORMS WOULD BE
ACTIVELY UNDERMINED A REVERSED.
YES SO. THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE I
BELIEVE THERE'S A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY SEVEN. DIFFERENT
AGENCIES- AND THE WAY THE
SYSTEM IS RIGHT NOW THERE IS A
CHECK AND BALANCE THERE IS. A
SEPARATION OF DUTIES WE ARE ALL
RESPONSIVE TO OUR CONSTITUENTS.
INDIVIDUALLY AND I JUST WANT TO
ALSO ADD THAT IN NEW YORK WHERE
EVERYTHING IS UNDER ONE ROOF.
IT TAKES EIGHT YEARS. FOR THEM
TO GET PROJECT THEM EIGHT YOUR
PIPELINE. AND IF YOU ASK ANY OF
THE FOLKS WHO WERE ON THE LINE
ASK THEM HOW LONG IT TAKES. TO
OUR SYSTEM GIVEN THAT THEY
EITHER HAVE THE FUNDING
MECHANISM OR- THROUGH THE
COMPETITIVE PROCESS WE HAVE
THREE ROUNDS EVERY YEAR. AND
THEY ARE ALL ABLE TO COMPETE
AND THEY COMPETE BASED ON A
VERY TRANSPARENT POINT SYSTEM-
WHAT PEOPLE CAN WATCH OUR YOU
KNOW OUR OUR MEETINGS. AND SO
WE HAVE A VERY VERY EFFICIENT
SYSTEM COMPARED TO EVERY OTHER
STATE AND SO IF THE SYSTEM
ISN'T BROKE. WHY DO WE WANT TO
CHANGE IT. SO HAVING THE
GOVERNOR I WE BOTH GOT ELECTED
TWO YEARS AGO WE ARE BOTH
ALIGNED IN OUR MISSION. AND
SAID YOU KNOW ACHIEVING HIS
GOAL OF THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION HOMES AND I'VE DONE A
LOT. OF THE LAST TWO YEARS TO.
MAKE THIS AGENCY MORE EFFICIENT
ESPECIALLY ALIGNING TAKEN SAID
LACK LIKE UNDER ONE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR WHICH IS MADE A
TREMENDOUS DIFFERENCE. WE HAVE
NOW JOINT APPLICATIONS WHICH
HAS NEVER HAPPENED BEFORE SO WE
ARE MAKING GREAT STRIDES- WE-
APPROVED MORE HOUSING UNITS.
LAST YEAR. SOMEONE I THINK
SOMEONE TALK ABOUT NINETEEN
THOUSAND UNITS OF THE PRIOR
YEAR. LAST YEAR WE APPROVED
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND UNITS IN
AGAIN THE PROBLEM IS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WE ARE
LIMITED BY UPON CAPACITY. WE
ARE WORKING ON RECYCLING BONDS-
CHANGING THE LIMIT FROM 5225%
SO THAT WE CAN UTILIZE MORE. OF
OUR BOND CAPACITY AND ALSO
LOOKING TO OTHER STATES TO SEE
WHETHER WE CAN PURCHASE. UP TAX
CREDITS AND BONDS THAT THERE
USING. WE HAVE SUCH A GREAT
NEEDS SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
WORKING ON WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT I'M NOT ACTIVE
MEMBER OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF STATE TREASURES.
AND THIS IS TOP PRIORITY FOR ME
TO. TO GET SOME MORE BOND
CAPACITY HERE TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU THE NEW
YORK EXAMPLES INTERESTING SO
YOU THINK THAT THIS MIGHT
ACTUALLY SLOW THE PROCESS DOWN
IF WE CONSOLIDATE THINGS YEAH I
WAS ON THE PHONE CALL WITH THE
DEVELOPERS TWO DAYS AGO. AND
THEY SAID THAT THE SYSTEM NOW.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHETHER YOUR
PROJECT IS GOING TO GET
APPROVED IT REALLY DEPENDS ON
THE STAFF. AND WHAT PROJECTS
THEY WANT TO APPROVED SO
THERE'S NO TRANSPARENCY NO
ACCOUNTABILITY NO PUBLIC
MEETING. AND NO SYSTEM WHERE
DEVELOPERS KNOW WHETHER THEY
ARE GOING TO BE COMPETING WELL
ARE NOT COMPETING THEY
BASICALLY WAIT. AND HOPE THAT
THEY GET CALLED. THANK YOU.
MISTER CALDERON. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I ARE ALL JUST
A LINE MY COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM OAKLAND WHICH I
GUESS WOULD BE THE TRANSITIVE
PROPERTY AS EVERYONE ELSE ON
THE COMMITTEE- BUT I JUST WANT
TO THANK THE THANK AUTHOR I
KNOW YOU'RE A DEEPLY RESPECTED
VOICE ON THESE ISSUES ALSO. YOU
KNOW HAVE A FIRST HAND
KNOWLEDGE OF HOW DEEPLY
RESPECTED THE TREASURE IS ON
THESE ISSUES AND HOW WIDESPREAD
THE ADMIRATION IS ME FOR A
HOUSING COMMUNITY FOR THE WORK
THAT SHE'S DONE MADE TREMENDOUS
PROGRESS UNDER HIS LEADERSHIP I
THINK THAT'S UNDER HER
LEADERSHIP I THINK THAT'S
EVIDENT TO EVERYBODY HERE- YOU
KNOW BEING THAT THIS IS THE
FIRST POLICY COMMITTEE- IN THE
FIRST HOUSE- AND THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THIS- YOU KNOW LOOK FOR TO
THOSE CONTINUE TO PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS ARE. DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES ON THIS BUT IT'S A
IT'S A CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
ISSUE ONCE I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR FOCUSING ON IT- AND I WILL
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY. THANK
YOU ANY FINAL. I'M GONNA MAKE
ONE FINAL COMMENT WHICH IS AN
ASPECT OF THIS BILL THAT I
THINK CAN BELIEVE THAT BOTH THE
SUPPORT OF THE SPONSORS AS WELL
AS THE OPPOSITION CAN AGREE ON
AND I JUST WANNA POINT OUT
WHICH IS REQUIRES A PLAN.
WORKING WITH ALL THESE
DIFFERENT ENTITIES TO
STREAMLINE THE PROCESSES AROUND
PROGRAM GUIDELINES THAT ARE
CURRENTLY DISPARATE AROUND
APPLICATIONS AROUND THE
COMPILING PROJECT DATA
MONITORING THE PROJECT
FINANCIALS PHYSICAL PROPERTY
INSPECTIONS DETAILS ON HOUSING
DATA AND I WOULD JUST SUGGEST
SIDES WHEREVER THE DISCUSSION
LANDS ON WHETHER THE SHOULD BE
CENTRALIZED IN ONE ENTITY OF
THAT WORK HAS TO GET DONE AND
THAT FOR ME IS ALSO YOU KNOW
REASON WHY AT LEAST I HOPE THIS
VEHICLE MOVES FORWARD- TO
CREATE SOME CONSENSUS AROUND
THAT BUT THAT BEING SAID MISTER
ANY FINAL COMMENTS. LET ME ASK
YOU AUTHOR OF UNITY FOR CLOSING
REMARKS YES PLEASE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND I WANT TO
START OFF BY FOOTBALL THING
I'VE HEARD ALL OF YOUR COMMENTS
AND- THEY HAVE RESONATED AND I
WILL CONTINUE- TO WORK WITH ALL
PARTIES AND STAKEHOLDERS THAT
ARE INVOLVED AND IMPACTED
HAVING REACHED OUT AS EARLY AS
FEBRUARY TWO- THE STATE
TREASURER- TO START ENGAGEMENT
IN THAT CONVERSATION. AND WILL
CONTINUE TO DO SO THAT IS MY
DESIRE TO BE ABLE TO BUILD THAT
CONSENSUS AND BRING US TO A
PLACE WHERE WE CAN SERVE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BETTER
ESPECIALLY AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND- WHEN IT COMES TO
THE CHALLENGES OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND WHAT WE ARE FACING
AS A CRISIS- WHAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT WINNING ESPECIALLY WHEN IT
COMES TO THE FINANCING OF IT.
YES THERE ARE A FEW NATIONAL
CONGLOMERATES THAT HAVE LEARN
THE SYSTEM AND HAVE THE LEGAL
RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO
NAVIGATE BUT FOR RIGHT NOW-
THERE ARE MANY THAT CAN'T
NAVIGATE AND ARE BUILDING OR
DESIRING TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING HERE IN CALIFORNIA THE
CHALLENGES ARE MUCH BIGGER THAN
ONE SINGLE STATE AGENCY. AND I
APPLAUD I ABSOLUTELY- COMMEND
AND APPLAUD. THE STATE
TREASURER FOR THE GREAT I WORK.
THAT HAS BEEN DONE ON HER
PURVIEW AND TIME. AND OFFICE
BUT THE CHALLENGES REMAIN
LARGER THAN A STATE AGENCY OR A
PARTICULAR DEPARTMENT SO WITH
THAT I DO WANT TO BE CLEAR.
THAT THE ISSUES RAISED BY THE
STATE WATER THE TURNER CENTER
AND MY WITNESSES ARE NOT A
RESULT OF ACTION. OR IN ACTION
BY ANY INDIVIDUAL AGENCY OR
ADMINISTRATION. THE REALITY IS
THAT THE CURRENT DYSFUNCTION IN
OUR STATES AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FINANCE SYSTEM. IS A SYMPTOM OF
A STRUCTURAL PROBLEM THAT IS
LARGER THAN ANY ONE OFFICE. SO
WE NEED A SOLUTION OF THE TO
COMMENSURATE WITH THE SCALE OF
THE PROBLEM. AND I BELIEVE THIS
BILL WILL SET US ON A PATH. TO
IMPLEMENTING JUST SUCH A
SOLUTION AGAIN I AM COMMITTED
TO WORKING. ADDRESSING ALL THE
ISSUES THAT WERE BROUGHT UP
TODAY AFTER SOME NOTES. AND
CONSIDERING THE DATE AND OTHER
THINGS THAT WERE BROUGHT UP SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS
OUR MOTION OF THIS FOR. THERE'S
BEEN A MOTIONS ARE SECOND.
SECOND MATTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS CHIU HI CHIU I
SAY ARE TOO HIGH C. R. I.
GABRIEL GABRIEL I KALRA. KALRA
AYE KILEY KILEY I WORK FOR TI
QUICK SILVA CORKS SILVA I WICKS
WICKS I. WE ARE EIGHT TWO ZERO
YOUR BILL IS OUT. THANK YOU. I
KNOW WE'VE A NUMBER OF
COLLEAGUES THAT ARE TRYING TO
MAKE FLIGHT SO I'M GONNA
KNOWLEDGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN.
THANK YOU. VERY MUCH CHAIR TO
AND MEMBERS AB ELEVEN NO ONE
WILL PROVIDE CLARITY ON
EXISTING REQUIREMENTS FOR
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS AND
CALIFORNIA AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
BY AUTHORED AB TWENTY NINE
TWELVE THAT UPDATED THE TOOLS
AVAILABLE FOR HOAS TO PREVENT
FRAUDULENT ACTIVITIES WHICH WAS
SIGNED INTO LAW MY OFFICES HELD
SEVERAL MEETINGS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND WORKSHOP
LANGUAGE THAT RESPONDED TO
CONCERNS BY THE OPPOSITION. WE
SHARE THE SAME GOAL OF
SAFEGUARDING THE FINANCES OF
HOAS FROM FRAUD AND ABUSE WE
HOPE TO REACH CONSENSUS ON THE
REMAINING THRESHOLD ISSUE BY
ADOPTING A SLIDING SCALE
APPROACH BASED ON HOAS OVERALL
BUDGET. RATHER THAN THE NUMBER
OF UNITS TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
TODAY ARE THOMAS WHERE AN
ATTORNEY LITIGATED H. AWAY
FRAUD CASES. AND STACEY
DONNELLY WHO IS AN EXPERT IN
FINANCIAL MANAGEMENT FOR
COMMUNITY ASSOCIATIONS. THANK
YOU FIVE CAN JUST MENTION THAT
THIS BILL ENJOYS IN IRAQ- ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE- AND SO
IF POSSIBLE FOR WITNESSES IF
YOU CAN PLEASE KEEP IT SHORT.
WITH THAT LET'S SEE IF ANY
MEMBERS IN THE CHAMBER WHICH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. ARE YOU
SPEAKING ACTUALLY WE SHOULD GO
TO HAVE SORRY WE SHOULD GO TO
OUR MAIN WITNESSES- LET'S GO ON
THE PHONES. TO THOMAS WHERE AND
STACEY DONNELLY TO THE OPERATOR.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
STACY DONNELLY. I AM THE CFO OF
CONDOMINIUM FINANCIAL
MANAGEMENT MY COMPANIES PROVIDE
BUT KEEPING SEARCHES FOR COMMON
INTEREST DEVELOPMENT. AND WE
HAVE THE FORTY YEARS I'VE BEEN
PERSONALLY IN THE INDUSTRY FOR
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS. AB ELEVEN
NO ONE IS- TO PROVIDE SOME
CLEAN AB TWENTY NINE TWELVE
WHICH WOULD PUT INTO LAW IN
JANUARY OF TWENTY NINETEEN. AND
NOW THAT WE HAVE EXPERIENCED AB
TWENTY NINE TWELVE IN ACTUAL
PRACTICE. FOR A COUPLE OF YEARS
WE ARE SEEING AREAS THAT JUST
NEED SOME FURTHER
CLARIFICATION. CURRENTLY THERE
THANKS CALCULATION REQUIRED
WITH RESPECT TO TRANSFERRED
ALLOWED BY MANAGING AGENTS AND
THAT CALCULATION CAN CHANGE ON
A DAILY BASIS AS IT RELATES TO
BALANCE OF THE BANK ACCOUNT. SO
WE ARE ASKING FOR A MORE
DEFINITIVE THRESHOLD ON DOES I
AM TRANSFERRED TO THEIR ALLOWED.
THERE ALSO FURTHER PROTECTION
ON HOW HOAS INVEST THEIR MONEY
REQUIRING PROTECTION OF
PRINCIPLE. AND LASTLY I JUST
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT THERE'S
FURTHER PROTECTIONS WITH
RESPECT TO THE COMPUTER FRAUD
AND FUNDS TRANSFER FRAUD
INSURANCE MY COMPANY PERSONALLY
EXPERIENCED A LOT IN THIS ARENA
AND IT'S A FASTER GROWING WHAT
CEDAR FOR OUR INDUSTRY. SO I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
WOULD APPRECIATE A. THANK YOU
LET'S GO TO THE NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU HI MY NAME IS THOMAS
WHERE- IN ADDITION TO BEING THE
CURRENT LEGISLATIVE CO CHAIR
FOR THE COMMUNITY SENSATIONS
INSTITUTE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE ACTION COMMITTEE
HIS CLOCK A LAWSUIT ATTORNEYS
REPRESENT HOME ASSOCIATION FOR
THIRTY TWO YEARS AND I HAVE. A
PARTICULAR EXPERTISE DEALING
WITH THE TALIBAN CLAIMS- I
THINK STATE IS IN A GOOD JOB
OF- SPECIFYING- THE GOAL OF
THIS BILL- I JUST WANT TO FOCUS
ON ONE IMPORTANT PART OF IT
DEALING WITH THE INSURANCE. NOT
CIVIL CODE SECTION FIVE EIGHT
OH SIX MANDATES THAT HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATION TAPPED A TEAM COULD
TELL THE BOND INSURANCE BUT
THAT- TO CORRECT THAT BY
DIRECTORS OFFICERS MANAGEMENT
AGENCY AND MANAGEMENT COMPANY
EMPLOYEES. NOW THAT INSURANCE
COVERAGE THERE'S INSURANCE
COVERAGE TRADITIONALLY
SYNONYMOUS WITH SEVERAL PEOPLE
ON THAT IS NOW OFFERED TO
DIFFERENT TYPES OF INSURANCE
INSTRUMENTS INCLUDING- CRIME
INSURANCE POLICY AND EMPLOYEE
DISHONESTY POLICIES- AND SBO
ELEVEN A ONE CLARIFIES THAT
SUCH POLICIES WILL SATISFY THE
REQUIREMENTS- OF. THE STATUTE
SO LONG AS THEY BEAT THEIR
COVERAGE LIMITS AND SCOPE OF
COVERAGE BURKE PROVIDED FOR IN
CIVIL CODE SECTION FIVE EIGHT
OH SIX. AND MAKE SURE THAT AIM
BEING SURE AGAINST A STEP BY
THE DIRECTORS OFFICERS THE
MANAGEMENT AGENCY AND THE
MANAGEMENT COMPANY EMPLOYEES-
THANK YOU WE BELIEVE THAT- SB
ELEVEN A ONE IS A NON
CONTROVERSIAL BILL CONSISTENT
WITH THE GOALS OF AB TWENTY
NINE TWELVE THE PROTECTIVENESS
OF STATION FINANCES AND WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL THANK
YOU LET'S NOT GO TO THE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WE
HAVE- TOM. SIR FROM THE CENTER
FOR CALIFORNIA HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATION LAW AS WELL AS.
BILL RICHARDSON- TO THE
OPERATOR. HELLO WE CAN HEAR YOU.
OKAY MY NAME IS SIR AND I A
LITTLE COMMITTEE IS THE CAL.
THAT'S FOR THE- REPRESENT CALL.
HOMEOWNERS AND I LIKE TO BEGIN
BY NOTING THAT CALIFORNIA
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION TAKEN
TOGETHER HAVE ABOUT THIRTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS AND OUT. ALL
THE COLLECTED FROM HOMEOWNERS
OUR PRIMARY WITNESS THIS
AFTERNOON IF BILL RICHARDSON
WHO WAS A FORMER CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER AND MAYOR GIZMO BEACH
SHE SERVED FOR SIX YEARS THAT
THE BOARD PRESIDENT. OF HIS
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION- IT
WHICH IS- HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION
FIFTEEN YEARS WHO RANGE IN AGE
FROM. FIFTY FIVE TO NINETY
EIGHT. HERE'S ALL THE HAVE ONE
TWO DOLLARS IN A RESERVE
ACCOUNT. AND NOT ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND. UNIT OPERATING-
MISTER CHAIR I WOULD LIKE TO
YIELD THE REST OF MY TIME TO MR
WHICH SO WE CAN COMPLETE IN A
STATEMENT. MISTER RICHARDS
DIRECTED. HELLO WE CAN HEAR
THIS IS. WE CAN HEAR YOU HELLO
KITTY. BUT I'M GETTING THAT OUT
OF REACH- THAT IS STRANGE YEAH
COOL IN MY THINKING MATE MAY I
REQUEST A- REVISED THAT HAS BY
BUT- I CAN DO THE MISTER
RICHARD. YEAH MISTER CHAIRMAN
WE HAD A OF WITH THE AUDIO SO
COULD BE THE IN SEVERAL COME
HEARING THAT IT. ALL IS
PROBLEMATIC THE I WOULD LIKE TO
GO AHEAD AND READ MISTER
RICHARDS STATEMENT PLEASE THE
FORMER ON. LUIS OBISPO. OKAY
COUNTY. AND HE A GROUP OF HIS-
NOT FELLOW HOMEOWNERS THERE
HAVE BEEN. THE AND THE VERY
ABOUT FINANCE DECISIONS THAT
HAVE BY THE- THEIR GROUP IS- WE
ARE SUPPOSED TO BE KEPT A
DESERT PLAN WILL BE IN A FILE
INSTITUTION THAT IS FOR AND
THAT'S WHY THE MONEY IS RIGHT
NOW HOWEVER THE CONCERNED ABOUT
AB ELEVEN OH ONE IS THAT IT
CONTAINS NO IN. TOOL TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE BOARD ACTUALLY
DEPOSIT THE MONEY. IT AND
INSTITUTION THE MORE IMPORTANT
THAT THE MONEY STAYS THERE.
THIS IS A CONCERN BECAUSE THEY
ARE CALLED FOR. OF WHICH SHE
WAS DISCRIMINATED SOME YEARS IN
THE PAST BUT HE CONTINUES TO
MONITOR IT AND THAT THE CURRENT
BOARDS PERSUADE IN PERSUADED.
BY THEIR COUNSEL. HE MOVED ONE
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN
LEADERS OUT OF THE FEDERALLY
INSURED BANK AND HANDED OVER TO
MORGAN STANLEY AND WELLS FARGO
ADVISORS. PRIVATE COMPANIES
THAT ARE NOT FEDERALLY INSURED.
SO THE PROBLEM IS THERE'S NO
WAY FOR THEM TO ENFORCE THIS-
THE BOARD'S ACTUALLY
UNANIMOUSLY VOTED TO DO THIS.
AND SO FAR THE BOARD IS MOVING
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND OUT OF
THAT THE OF THE INSURED ELSE IN
ANOTHER FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
IS TO BE HANDED OVER TO BE
MORGAN STANLEY AND WELLS FARGO
ADVISORS. DESPITE MANY REQUESTS
THEY'VE BEEN UNABLE TO GET-
FINANCIAL DETAILS AND TO FIND
OUT WHAT EXACTLY. IS BEING DONE
WITH THEIR MONEY. UPDATE BUT
THEY DO NOT REFLECT THE VIEWS
THERE ARE NO LONGER IN
FEDERALLY INSURED. ACCOUNTS
THOUGH THEY FINALLY DID GO TO
ADULT PRACTICE ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES IN THE COUNTY DEPEND
UP WITH THE APPEARED. FIFTY S.
ELDER FINANCIAL ABUSE. WITH THE
FUTURE OFFICE THE TO IT TO THE
SEVEN OBISPO DEPARTMENT TO
INVESTIGATE. YEAH SO THE POLICE
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN REQUESTING
DOCUMENTS BUT THESE DOCUMENTS
ARE BEING SCREENED BY THE
ATTORNEYS FOR. TIME SO THE
BOARD. AT WITHOUT ENFORCEMENT
THE LAW IF YOU CAN THE BOARD
VOTED TO TRANSFER THE MONEY OUT
AND THERE'S NO WAY TO STOP THAT
FROM HAPPENING. YOUR ALTERNATE
CERTIFIED NINETY AREN'T
CONCERNED AWSKI'S ME IF I CAN
INTERRUPT. WHAT IS OPERATOR CAN
YOU RUN HELP LET'S PERSON WE
WE'RE OUT OF TIME I YEARS RUN
OUT OF TIME. YES OKAY WE'RE
DONE JUST THAT WEIRD THE NOBLE
GOT BUT WHAT CAN'T YOU I'M
SORRY I DID THAT. ALL RIGHT
THAT BRINGS US A TO. LET'S SEE-
ANYBODY. SUPPORTER OPPOSITION
ARE ACTUALLY SUPPORT IN A ROOM
AT THIS TIME. GOING WHERE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LOUIS
BROWN ON BEHALF THE COMMUNITY
ASSOCIATIONS INSTITUTE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE ACTION
COMMITTEE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IN HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS IF NEEDED. I THANK
YOU SIR IS THERE ANYBODY ELSE
NO THEY WILL GO TO SUPPORT ON
THE- REMOTE IT'S NOT APPEAR TO
BE ANY SO WE'LL BRING THAT
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. THERE'S
NOBODY IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION ANYBODY ON THE
COMMITTEE I'M IN ON THE- REMOTE
IN OPPOSITION. YOUR PEERS TO BE
NON. THEN THAT WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS. WE DID NOT DO
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINE I
THINK. THIS ARMED GENERAL OKAY
SORRY ABOUT THAT WE'RE GONNA GO
TO THE PHONE LINES NOW FOR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION FROM THE
PUBLIC SO N. INTEREST OF
KEEPING TYPE AND WE HAVE A KIND
OF A CALM THE LARGE SCHEDULE IN
A COMPACT TIME- WE'RE GONNA
LIMIT. THE AMOUNT OF TIME. TWO
TO FIVE MINUTES. WE'RE DOING
FIVE MINUTES A TOTAL. AND SO-
PLEASE BE BRIEF- GIVE YOUR NAME.
I THE ORGANIZATION YOU
REPRESENT WHEN YOU SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE AND THAT IS ALL AND THAT
ALLOWS AS MANY PEOPLE AS
POSSIBLE SO- MODERATOR IF YOU
CAN OPEN UP THE PHONE LINE FOR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK ON AB ALIVE AND ALL ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
ABOUT EIGHT IN Q. WHAT WERE TO
LINE THREE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I THANK THE VOTING.
RIGHT ONE SEVENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE MY NAME IS MATT CLARK
AND I'M A MEMBER OF THE BOARD
OF DIRECTORS FOR THE LADERA
RANCH MAINTENANCE CORPORATION
EIGHT SEVENTY FOUR HUNDRED HOME
COMMON INTEREST DEVELOPMENT
ORANGE COUNTY AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE ON AB ELEVEN- ONE THANK
YOU THANK YOU SIR NEXT BIGGER
PLEASE TAKE YOUR- BRIAN TO OR
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD AND- YES
THIS IS SHERRY MORRIS I'M A
BOARD MEMBER WITH THE
HILLSBOROUGH COMMUNITY
ASSOCIATION. AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB ELEVEN OH ONE THANK
YOU THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT WEEK
OR- THANK YOU RIGHT TO TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN REALLY
REALLY CLOSE TO THREE AND A
FIFTY FIVE PLUS IN SAN DIEGO
MEMBER D. A. I SUPPORT THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT WEEK- THANK YOU
I'M THREE THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS GUS
BITTER BORGATA CONSTITUENT FROM
PLASTER COUNTY AND A FORMER
DIRECTOR AND- A HOMEOWNER. AND
HAND OWNERS ASSOCIATION AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT SPEAKER
PLEASE. THANK YOU I'M THREE OH
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS EDWARD CHESHIRE I'M A LAWYER
AND FORMER BOARD MEMBER-
PACIFIC RIDGE NEIGHBORHOOD
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION THE SIX
HUNDRED AND SEVEN UNIT
DEVELOPMENT AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE. ELEVEN OH ONE THANK YOU
SIR NEXT BIGGER PLEASE. THANK
YOU ONE ONE EIGHTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
JENNIFER WATER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COMMUNITY MANAGER AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
BEAKER. THANK YOU RIGHT TO
SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
JACQUELINE I'M A FORMER
PRESIDENT OF CONTEMPO HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATION WITH ABOUT SEVEN
HUNDRED HOPE WHICH I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BATTLE THANK YOU
SIR NATIONAL ASIAN PLEASE.
THANK YOU RUN ONE TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JOINT ONE
GENERATION. HYGIENIC WHEN
DENNIS FROM COMMUNITY
ASSOCIATIONS INSTITUTE NICE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT BEAKER
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ONE TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO ASK. I DON'T
KNOW WHO. GAIL MARTIN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
WEEK- PLEASE. ONE EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS MARY BETH LEWIS I AM A
HOMEOWNER IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT WEEK-
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
GREAT WILL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY COMMENTS
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
THEY'RE BEING DONE YOU MAY
CLOSE- AS I SAID BEFORE I THINK
THE OPPOSITION AND TO ME WE
SHARE THE- SAME GOAL OF
SAFEGUARDING FINANCES OF HOAS
FROM FRAUD AND ABUSE AND WE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM
TO REACH CONSENSUS AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND- MISS
SECRETARY YOU CAN TAKE A ROLL
PLEASE. THANK YOU MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
JUDICIARY TO. SAY ARE TOO HIGH
THE ART BY GABRIEL. KALRA KALRA
AYE KILEY. NOT WARD HI FORTY
AYE CORK SILVA KIRK SILVA I
WEEKS. TWO CITIES. FOUR TWO
ZERO. WAITING FOR ALL THAT OKAY.
YEAH WILL HOLD THAT OPEN TILL
THE END OF THE ME AS FOUR ZERO
YOU SAID. OUR THANK YOU I'M
GOING TO TURN THE CHAIR OVER TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD AS I HAVE
TO RUN UP TO ANOTHER COMMITTEE
FAIRY. THANK YOU LESTER SIERRA-
NEXT UP WE WILL HEAR ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER NEWS ARIAN THAT WOULD BE
HE BE. THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR FOR
YOUR VERY QUICK TEMPO. OUT OF
RESPECT FOR MY COLLEAGUES WHO
ARE ALSO IN A- CRUNCH I WILL
JUST KEEP IT VERY BRIEF. AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE HELPS
COMMUNITIES RECOVER MORE
QUICKLY FROM DAMAGING
EARTHQUAKES IN THREE WAYS ONE
IT HELPS CLARIFY THAT. ARE
BUILDING CODE IS MEANT TO
SUPPORT RECOVERY AS WELL AS
SAFETY TO PROTECT LIVELIHOODS
AS WELL AS LIVES. TO IT ALLOWS
CITIES AND COUNTIES TO AMEND
THE STATE CODE TO ADDRESS
RECOVERY AS A LOCAL PRIORITY
THREE IT CHARGES THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING STANDARDS COMMISSION
TO SET MINIMUM. STATEWIDE
REQUIREMENTS RELATED TO POST
EARTHQUAKE RECOVERY- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU AND WITH ME IS MISTER
RYAN KERSTING. THANK YOU HAS
BEEN IN MOTION AND A SECOND-
OUR FIRST WITNESS INTO AND
SUPPORT WILL BE RYAN KERSTING.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS THE
IMPORTANCE OF AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY NINE I'M RIGHT PERSON
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF OVER
THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED MEMBERS AND
STRUCTURAL ENGINEERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA. WELL
WHO ARE THE EXPERTS WHEN IT
COMES UNDERSTANDING THE
PERFORMANCE OF OUR BUILDINGS
UNDER SEISMIC LOADS. MANY OF
YOU KNOW THAT'S NOT A FIRST
TIME TALKING ABOUT THIS I'LL DO
MY BEST TO KEEP OUR
CONVERSATION GRIEF. RIGHT NOW
JUST REITERATE FOR THE MOST
PART OF BUILDING CODES ONLY
FOCUS ON PROTECTING LIVES WHAT
DOES A GOOD JOB OF PROVIDING
THE SAFETY. THE TIME TO TRULY
TRULY RECOVER FROM THE NEXT BIG
EARTHQUAKE WILL TAKE MONTHS IF
NOT YEARS. THANKS TO RECENT
RELEASE FEDERAL PORT WE HAVE
THE DATA RECOMMENDATIONS AND
ALTERNATIVES FOR HOWTO GET
BETTER PERFORMANCE IN TERMS OF
IMPROVE RECOVERY FOR THOSE
BUILDINGS THAT PROVIDE THE
HOUSING AND OTHER SERVICES.
THAT ARE COMMUNITIES NEED IN
THE TIME MANY OF THEM. THE
RECENTLY RELEASED A REPORT WE
RECOGNIZE THE NEED AND
ENCOURAGES STATE AND LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS PURSUE THESE.
PROVISIONS WITHIN THEIR
BUILDING CODES. APPROPRIATE TO
THEIR SPECIFIC RISK AND
RECOVERY NEEDS. WHICH IS
EXACTLY WHAT THIS BILLS CALLING
FOR. THERE'S A CONSENSUS ACROSS
THE BREADTH OF INDUSTRY GROUPS.
AND WITHIN VARIOUS LEVELS
GOVERNMENTS THAT WE SHOULD BE
DESIGNING OUR BUILDINGS
RECOVERY NOT JUST SAFETY. THIS
IS AN EXCITING OPPORTUNITY FOR
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIANS DESERVE
A CODE. THE PRIORITIZE
BUILDINGS IN TERMS OF WHEN THEY
NEED TO BE FUNCTIONAL AFTER AN
EARTHQUAKE. WE KNOW HOW TO DO
BETTER. BUT WE NEED TO ACTUALLY
START DOING BETTER. WE'RE
SIMPLY ASKING FOR YOUR HELP. TO
ESTABLISH A PATH FOR US TO
PARTNER WITH THE BUILDING
pTHE CONVERSATION. AND IMPLEMENT
APPROPRIATE PROVISIONS WITHIN
CALIFORNIA BUILDING CODE. HELP
US MAKE THIS CHANGE YOUR
BILLING CODE. THAT DOES MORE
THAN JUST SAVE LIVES. AND
CONSIDERS RECOVERY WE NEED TO
BE RESILIENT. AND PROTECTS
FINANCIAL INTEREST AND SERVICES
NEEDED. BY OUR HOMEOWNERS.
BUILDING OWNERS BUSINESS
JURISDICTIONS AND AGENCIES. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
WE HAVE ABOUT ONE WITNESS I
BELIEVE ON THE LINE IN
OPPOSITION STILL BE OUR FERRARI
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION. I DO NOT SEE THEM
DIALED IN OUR MOBILE FERRARI IF
YOU ARE ON THE LINE PLEASE
PRESS STAR ZERO SO I CAN OPEN
YOUR LINE. I CURRENTLY DO NOT
SEE THEM DIALED IN. LET'S NOT
GO TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THEIR ANY MEMBERS IN THE
CHAMBER. ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ON THE REMOTE AND REMOTE
STATION. TO THE OPERATOR IF YOU
COULD ACKNOWLEDGE ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC THAT WISH TO
SPEAK- ARE. AN INDICATOR
SUPPORT FOR THIS ITEM. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE TWO IN Q. WHAT WE'RE
TRYING. THREE FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS RICHARD
MARCUSSEN REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN SOCIETY OF CIVIL
ENGINEERS. OVER NINETEEN
THOUSAND CIVIL ENGINEERS AND
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE PRACTICE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY NINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU RIGHT TO SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
PETER PROGRAM. I DONALD A
RESIDENT OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
AND I ARE PEOPLE WHO YEAH THANK
YOU. FIVE THREE FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE THREE
FOUR SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. OH
I'M SORRY I'M CALLING FOR AB
SEVENTY ONE I THINK I'M I'M IN
THE QUEUE BUT SHOULDN'T BE.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU NOW LET'S GO TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
OPPOSES ANYONE HERE IN THE
CHAMBER. ANYONE IN A REMOTE
STATION TO THE OPERATOR. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY NINE PLEASE PRESSONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
MISTER CHAIRMAN- THE FACILITY-
FERRARI- I WAS HAVING SOME
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES BUT I AM
ON AND WOULD LOVE TO SPEAK IF
ABLE WANT YOU WANT TO SPEAK AT
THIS TIME. TWO MINUTES PLEASE.
YEAH YEAH THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND- EXCELLING IN THE
DURING MY APOLOGIES FOR HAVING
TROUBLE GETTING IN. ASSEMBLY
ACCORDING TO HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION- HERE ALSO
REPRESENTING TODAY THOUGH THE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTIES
ASSOCIATION AS WELL THE
BUILDING OWNERS AND MANAGERS
ASSOCIATION- WHO ARE ALL. TO
YOU AT THIS MOMENT IN TIME BE
REMOVING OUR OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION IN LIGHT OF
THE RECENT AMENDMENTS. WE
ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT HAVING EACH
CD IN THE BUILDING STANDARDS
COMMISSION. WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND MOVIE NIGHTS
AND CORDON ISSUE FORWARD- WE
THANK THE AUTHOR THE SPONSORS-
WE'VE BEEN DILIGENT HOPE AND
VERY COMMUNICATED OVER THE
LAST. COUPLE WEEKS THE MIND-
YOU KNOW THE THING WE WANT TO
AVOID IS GET PRESUMING IN THE
STATUTE THE DIRECTIONS GO THE
AGENCIES WILL TAKE. AND WE
THINK WE CAN GET THERE SO HAPPY
TO BE REMOVING OUR APPLES LET
THE MINUTE POSITION IN MY GET
MY APOLOGIES TO EVERYONE. FOR
MY DIFFICULT TO GET NOW THANK
YOU. LET'S NOT GO TO OTHER MY
UP THAT WISH TO INDICATE UP
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS OVER THE PHONE. LET'S
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
COMMENTS. TO THE AUTHOR ANY
FINAL COMMENTS- THIS BILL
PROMOTES THE IDEA OF FUNCTIONAL
RECOVERY SO THAT IT PROTECTS-
LOCATIONS AS WELL AS LIVES AND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO MOVE THIS FORWARD. MOTION
OKAY SO MOTIONS BEEN MADE AND
SECONDED MADAM SECRETARY.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS CHIU HI CHIU I'D
SAY ARE TO. GABRIELLE KALRA
KALRA I KILEY HIGHLY NO. WAR
WAR I QUICKSILVER QUICKSILVER I
WEEKS. Q. THE CITY FOUR FOUR
TWO ONE SEVEN ONE YOU NEED ONE
MORE VOTE AND WE WILL HOLD THE
ROLE THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. LET'S NOT GO TO MS DAVIES
ITEM WHICH IS FILE ITEM NINE
EIGHTY FIVE OH TWO I WILL NOTE
THAT THIS ENJOYS A TO PASS
RECOMMENDATION FROM BOTH SIDES
OF THE AISLE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS TODAY I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB FIVE OR TWO. AT
FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH MY STAFF TO AMEND THE BILL
IN A WAY THAT. ADDS PROTECTION
AND ON VACATION FOR ELECTIONS
GOING FORWARD I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS. UNDER THE CURRENT
LAW WHEN IT H. AWAY HOLD AN
ELECTION FOR ITS BOARD OF
DIRECTORS IF THEY DO NOT HAVE
ENOUGH PEOPLE TO RUN FOR OPEN
POSITIONS THEY MUST STILL GO
THROUGH ALL THE FINANCIAL
PROCEDURES OF HAVING ELECTION.
THIS PLACE PLACES A HUGE BURDEN
ON HOAS AND ULTIMATELY THE COST
FOR THESE I NEEDED ELECTIONS
GET FUNNELED DOWN TO THE
HOMEOWNERS AND THE TENANTS. A
FEW YEARS AGO THE LEGISLATOR
PASSED A MEASURE TO ALLEVIATE
THIS SITUATION BY ALLOWING
LARGE HOAS TO DO A VOTE BY
ACCLAMATION. IF THE EXACT
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO SIGNED UP
FOR THE RUN. FOR POSITION
MATCHES THE NUMBER OF POSITIONS
OPEN. THAT WAS SB SEVEN FIVE
FOUR. UNFORTUNATELY THE MEASURE
ONLY APPLIED TO EACH ALWAYS WAS
SIX THOUSAND OR MORE UNITS.
SMALL H. O. AS WERE LEFT OUT.
AB FIVE UP TO IS A SIMPLE
MEASURE TO ENSURE THAT THESE
SAME ELECTION PROCEDURES MAY
APPLY TO THE HL HOAS OF ANY
SIZE. I SHOULD NOTE THAT THIS
BILL DOES NOT CHANGE ELECTION
PROCEDURES UNDER NORMAL
CIRCUMSTANCES. IF MORE PEOPLE
SIGNED UP TO RUN IN OPEN
POSITIONS. THEN THIS BILL DOES
NOT COME INTO PLAY A REGULAR
ELECTION SHALL HAPPEN. IN
ADDITION WHAT THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS WE'D GIVEN THE-HOMEOWNERS AN ADDITIONAL.
NINETY DAYS NOTICE UPON
UPCOMING ELECTIONS ON TOP OF
THE EXISTING THIRTY DA NOTICE.
LASTLY ACCORDING TO
STAKEHOLDERS DATA FOR AB FIVE A
TWO THERE ARE ONLY FIVE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY FOUR SO SHE ISSUES
WITH A THOUSAND OR MORE UNITS
IN CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING. 1%
OF THE TOTAL 60% OF THE
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA FIFTY
UNITS OR LESS TOTALING MORE
THAN THIRTY THREE THOUSAND. 52%
OF THE ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA HAVE BUDGETS OF LESS
THAN ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS SO THE EXPENSE OF AN ON
ELECTION COULD BE SIGNIFICANT.
AND I JUST LIKE TO SHARE
PERSONAL NOTES- I HAVE SERVED
ON MY H. AWAY FOR TEN YEARS I
KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY- BUT I STAYED ON
UNTIL JANUARY. AND UP SO I WENT
THROUGH THIS AND I CAN TELL YOU
THAT- FOR THE TEN YEARS I
SERVED ON IT. THAT'S PROBABLY
WHY I'M STILL ON BECAUSE NOBODY
WANTED TO RUN FOR THE H. AWAY.
AND WHEN WE DID DO ELECTIONS WE
COULD NEVER GET A QUORUM SO WE
HAD TO GO BACK AND SEE MALIN
MAIL IN MAIL AND TO THE POINT
WHERE. AGAIN WE STILL NEVER HAD
ENOUGH VOTES AND I CAN TELL YOU
ESPECIALLY DURING THE RECESSION
AND DURING CALL THAT. THE LACK
OF INCOME JOB LOSS THIS IS SUCH
A BURDENSOME TO HAVE TO
INCREASE H. ALWAYS AS A COSTS
GO UP- IN WE'VE GOT A LOT OF-
FAMILIES THAT ARE. YOU KNOW
RAISING KIDS AS WELL AS A LOT
OF SENIORS ON FIXED INCOMES SO
NOT HAVING A REYES IT SHOWED. A
DUES DUE TO MAINTENANCE AND SO
FORTH IT WOULD REALLY BE
BENEFICIAL- WITH ME TODAY VIA
PHONE TO ANSWER MY QUESTIONS
MIKE VON OF THE LOCAL L. A.
COUNTY. MAINTENANCE CORPORATION
AND TOM FREELY CEO OF THE CA
ASSOCIATION OF COMMUNITY
MANAGERS I RESPECTFULLY. ASK
FOR NOW VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU LET'S GO TO. YOUR. I GO TO
THE OPERATOR IF YOU COULD
ACKNOWLEDGE MIKE VON AND TOM
FEELEY FREELY. KEEP UP WIDER
OPEN. A GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MICHAEL
BOND AND THE RESIDENT OF THE
CITY OF RANCHO SANTA MARGARITA
A MEMBER OF THE SANTA MARGARITA
LANDSCAPE AND RECREATION
CORPORATION WHICH THE MASTER
HLA SERVING THE CITY OF RANCHO
SANTA MARGARITA WITHOUT
THIRTEEN THOUSAND YEAR. I'M
ALSO A RESIDENT OF THE ALRP
CONTENT MAINTENANCE
CORPORATION. A SMALL CONDO
ASSOCIATION WITH ONLY A HUNDRED
THIRTY TWO UNITS. MCCARTY SAID
RUN FOR ELECTION OF THE BOARD
OF OUR LOCAL ASSOCIATION TWICE.
THE FIRST TIME UNSUCCESSFULLY-
BEING A THIRD LEADING VOTE
GETTER ONE TWO WERE ELECTED AND
THEN ARAMBULA ACTION THE NEXT
TIME AROUND AND WAS SUCCESSFUL.
I WANT TO TAKE A- DAVIS
CERVANTES CALL FOR REFLECTION I
THINK WILL BENEFIT ALL
COMMUNITY INTEREST DEVELOPMENTS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
A MEMBER RESIDENTS BY ALLOWING
ELECTION DIRECTORS BY
ACCLAMATION. IN THE CASE OF
UNCONTESTED ELECTIONS. THIS
WILL ENABLE BOARDS TO BETTER
MANAGE H. AWAY BUDGETS AND
RESOURCES BY FOCUSING ON
BUDGETING PRIORITIES SUCH AS
MAINTENANCE PROGRAMS. WHICH TO
BENEFIT. ALL RESIDENTS AND
MEMBERS. I WILL NOTABLE.
CONTEST A LOT MAY BE MINOR KEPT
ALIVE GREAT AND SMALL ESOS.
LIKE OURS. ON A PER UNIT BASIS
ON LARGER. WERE ALLOWED BY ACT.
AS MALCOLM THANKS TO S. B. C.
BEFORE. THE THESE REASONS I
SUPPOSE AB OH TWO. ENCOURAGE
COMPLAINING THAT TO SEE IT IS
WELL THANK YOU. WE HEAR FROM
THE NEXT WITNESS MISTER CHAIR.
PLEASE GET IN MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS TOM REALLY
AND I'M CEO OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COMMUNITY
MANAGERS PRIOR TO THIS ROLE I
HAVE THIRTY YEARS OF HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATION MANAGEMENT
EXPERIENCE AND I CAN ATTEST
FIRSTHAND THAT IS BILL WOULD
BENEFIT HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATIONS
AND THEY'RE COMMUNITY MEMBERS
GREATLY NOTHING IN EIGHTY FIVE
OH TWO. WOULD REMOVE THE
HOMEOWNERS RIGHT TO RUN FOR
ELECTION NOR WOULD GET ANY
DECISION MAKING FOR DISCRETION
TO REPORT ON WHETHER TO HOLD AN
ELECTION IT IS SOLELY A
FUNCTION OF WHETHER THERE ARE
ENOUGH HOMEOWNER CANDIDATES IF
THE ELECTION IS ALL CONTESTED
THE FULL ELECTION WILL AND
OCCUR. IF THERE IS AN EQUAL
NUMBER OR LESS CANDIDATES IT
SIMPLY DOESN'T MAKE SENSE
CONTRA COSTA THE SECRET BALLOT
ELECTIONS WHEN THE RESULTS
ALREADY CLEAR I UNDERSTAND THAT
OPPOSITION BELIEVES THAT THIS
BILL WOULD ENABLE INCUMBENT
DIRECTORS TO REMAIN IN OFFICE
HOWEVER AB FIVE OH TWO WOULD
ACTUALLY ASSIST IN GETTING NEW
BOARD MEMBERS SEATED AS OPPOSED
TO CONTINUING EXISTING FOR MAKE
UP DUE TO THE INABILITY TO HOLD
AN ELECTION FOR IN SOME
INSTANCES. ALLOWING EXISTING
BOARD MEMBERS TO APPOINT TAKEN
POSITIONS WHICH IS MORE LIKELY
TO LEAD TO THE PROBLEM THAT THE
OPPOSITION IS WORRIED ABOUT AS
PREVIOUSLY NOTED SB SEVEN FIFTY
FOUR BY THEN SENATOR MOORLACH
WAS APPROVED BY THIS COMMITTEE
IN ENACTED IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN SB SEVEN FIFTY FOUR
CHANGED CIVIL CODE FIFTY ONE
HUNDRED TO ALLOW ELECTION BY
ACCLAMATION FOR SIX FOR
ASSOCIATIONS. WITH GREATER THAN
SIX THOUSAND UNITS AB FIVE OH
TO SUPPORTS AND COMPLEMENTS
EXISTING LAW MEMBERS IN CLOSING
EIGHTY FIVE OH TWO IS A COMMON
SENSE SOLUTION HELLO ENABLE
ELECTIONS TO OCCUR CAN IS TO BE
SEATED CAN HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATIONS TO SAVE MONEY I
ELECTIONS WERE THE RESULTS
WOULD NOT BE CHANGED BY
BALLOTING BALL WHILE ENSURING
THE NOMINATION PROCESS IS
THOROUGH TRANSPARENT AND OPEN.
ESPECIALLY NOW IT IS CRITICAL
TO LOOK FOR WAYS TO SAVE COSTS
RELATED TO HOUSING ENABLING AND
CABLE EFFICIENCY IN OPERATIONS.
FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY- EACH YEAR I BILL.
THANK YOU NOW LET'S GO TO
OPPOSITE WITNESSES WE HAVE TO
TEST AND ON THE PHONE TOM SIR
FROM CENTRE FOR CALIFORNIA
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION LAW AND
ATTORNEY ERIC SCHIFFER. HELLO
YES WE CAN HELLO. AUTHOR OF THE
CENTER IS ON A RECORD OF THE
BUILDING EIGHTY FIVE OH TWO.
OUR PRIMARY WITNESS TODAY IS
MATURING SHIPPER AND THE
JOURNEY CERTIFIED PUBLIC LAW
SPECIALIST AND HE WAS THE
PLAINTIFFS COUNSEL THEN YOU
COLLECTED THE GOOD NUMBER OF
BRITISH BEACH WALK H. AWAY. AN
IMPORTANT APPELLATE CASE THAT
UPHELD AND ENFORCED THE RIGHT
THE HOMEOWNERS ELECTION
PROCEDURES THAT PUT IN THE
DEEPEST STERLING ACT. I YIELD
THE REST OF MY TIME. TO MR ERIC
SCHIFFER. THANK YOU MISS CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS ERIC SCHIFFER- I AM THE
ATTORNEY AT THE LAW FIRM OF
SHOULD PRODUCE IN ORANGE COUNTY
CALIFORNIA I AM A CERTIFIED
APPEL A LOT SPECIALIST AND I
WAS. COUNSEL OF RECORD IN THE-
WITTENBERG VERSES BEACH WALK
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION DECISION
FROM TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN MY
PRACTICE DOES INVOLVE THE
REPRESENTATION OF BOTH
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS AS WELL
AS DISSENTING HOMEOWNERS- AND I
SPEAK TODAY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
FIVE OH TWO- BE ISSUE. AS I SEE
IT IS THE- PREMISE OF ELECTING
DIRECTOR NOMINEES BY
ACCLAMATION AS THE MODIFIED-
FIFTY ONE HUNDRED G. WOULD SET
FORTH- THE STATED GOAL IS TO
AVOID ELECTIONS BUT THAT IS
ACTUALLY A BIT OF A MISNOMER.
THERE IS IN FACT AN ELECTION IT
BUT IT'S ONE HELD EXCLUSIVELY
BY SEATED BOARD MEMBERS. THAT
HISTORICALLY ACCLAMATION IS A
VOTE BY CHEERING HER SHOUTING
RATHER THAN BY AN ACTUAL
BALLOT. SO THE QUESTION FOR
THIS- COMMITTEE IS. HOW
IMPORTANT IS THE BALLOT TO THE
LEGITIMACY OF THE ELECTION
PROCESS. SO I THINK IF WE START
WITH THE PREMISE THAT COMMON
INTEREST DEVELOPMENTS ARE IN
FACT BECAUSE I GOVERNMENTAL
ENTITIES IN FACT MANY CASES
HAVE SO HELD BECAUSE ACTIONS BY
THE H. AWAY BOARDS. CONSTITUTE
PRIVATE CONDUCT THAT IMPACTS A
BROAD SEGMENT OF SOCIETY AND
THEREFORE CONSTITUTES MATTERS
OF PUBLIC INTEREST. SO DENYING
A BALLOT VOTE ON MATTERS THAT
DIRECTLY IMPACT COMMUNITY IN
FACT IN MEMBERS HOMES PRINCES
LEGISLATION DIRECTLY IN THE
REALM OF VIOLATING
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS OR
ARGUABLY IT AT A MINIMUM
QUANTITY CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY THIS
LEGISLATION OPENS THE DOORS TO
ASSOCIATION BOARDS BE ABLE TO
SUMMARILY STRIP OPPONENTS OF
VOTING RIGHTS THAT AFFECT WHICH
WOULD AFFECT THE EQUALITY.
FAIRNESS AND INTEGRITY OF THE
ELECTORAL SAYS BYE BYE PASSING
A VOTE ALL. IT'S ALSO- ADDING A
MECHANISM TO QUELL DISSENTING
VIEWS BY FINDING WAYS TO NOT
ALLOW NOMINATIONS NOW WITH THE
STATED GOAL OF THIS LEGISLATION
IS COST SAVINGS BUT THAT CAN
BECOME SUBTERFUGE FOR ACTUALLY
CHILLING THE VOTING PROCESS AND
ACCORDING TO THE LEGISLATIVE
HISTORY OF CIVIL CODE FIFTY ONE
OH FIVE BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
FIVE- THE WHOLE PURPOSE OF THIS
AREA OF THE LAW WAS TO IMPROVE
THE INTEGRITY OF THE VOTING
PROCESS AND THE REASONING WAS
BECAUSE THEY WERE FINDINGS MADE
AT THE TIME THAT ALEXION'S OF
BOARD MEMBERS WORK QUOTA
CONTAMINATED BY OPPRESSION
MANIPULATION AND INTIMIDATION
OF MEMBERS CLOSE QUOTE. I
BELIEVE THIS PROPOSED
LEGISLATION IS A STEP BACKWARDS
FROM THAT GOAL UNDER THE
AUSPICES OF COST SAVINGS AND I
WOULD URGE A NO VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NOW LET'S GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. I'M GONNA
ASK THERE'S ANYONE HERE IN THE
CHAMBER. HE'S MEDICARE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN ON
THE OFF THE COMMUNITY
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
ASSOCIATIONS INSTITUTE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE ACTION
COMMITTEE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE
ON THE REMOTE STATIONS. AND ON
THE OPERATOR LINE OPERATOR.
GERMAN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB FIVE OH TO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT
OF AB FIVE OH TWO. AT THIS TIME
WE DO ABOUT FIVE IN OUR QUEUE.
WE'LL START WITH NUMBER TWO
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
MY NAME IS LOUISE BEACONS I
OPPOSE- AB. FIVE OH TWO. THANK
YOU LET'S GO TO THE NEXT
INDIVIDUAL HOPEFULLY IN SUPPORT
THANK. NEXT TO BE NUMBER TWO
SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NUMBER TWO SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES MADAM BOB TRYING
TO CHURN MEMBERS KEVIN BAKER
CONTINUING AMERICAN CIVIL
LIBERTIES UNION CALIFORNIA ALSO
IN OPPOSITION EXPATRIATE'S
HEARD. LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES- OUR HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATION DIRE SITUATION WHAT
I LOCAL GOVERNMENT ENTITIES AND
DINNER HOMEOWNER LECTION SHOULD
BE TREATED WITH THE SAME
RESPECT AND SENSITIVITY AS
GOVERNMENTAL ELECTIONS
DEMOCRACY IS JUST AS IMPORTANT-
AND COST SHOULD NOT BE AN
OVERRIDING CONCERN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU LET'S HEAR
FROM OTHERS AND I WOULD JUST
STATE IF YOU COULD STATE YOUR
NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
OTHER SUPPORTERS. NEXT IN QUEUE
IS NUMBER ONE SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL WE CAN
HEAR YOU YES WE CAN HEAR YOU
CAN HEAR ME YEAH YOU CAN HEAR
ME OKAY GREAT GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS MATT PARKS THEN I'M
WITH THAT COMMUNITIES IN THE
STATE AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE ON AN
EIGHTY FIVE OH TWO. THANK YOU.
NEXT NEXUS NUMBER THREE THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M ACTUALLY
IN OPPOSITION THIS IS GUS
PATRICK OR CONSTITUENT OF
PLASTER COUNTY AND HOMEOWNER
AND A FORMER DIRECTOR OF AN
OWNER'S ASSOCIATION PROBABLY
HAS IGNORED 5% OWNER PETITIONS
CALLING FOR BOARD RECALL
SPENDING CERTAINLY THINK THAT
INSTEAD WE SHOULD BE ADDRESSING
PUTTING A WRITE IN. BALLOTS
NEXT SPEAKER. THE NEXT TO
NUMBER THREE FORTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. CAN REALLY REALLY
FROM CURTIS ARE AND I THINK HE
FIVE PLEASANT ST DIEGO AND A
MEMBER OF THE A. I. THE PORCH.
THANK YOU. TEXAS NUMBER ONE
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JANET QUINTANA MEMBER OF THE A.
I. AND- SUPPORT THE BILL.
NUMBER ONE EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME I'M FROM CONCORD
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
ITSELF. NEXT IN QUEUE IS NUMBER
TWO OH NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS TERRY
MORRIS WITH THE HILLSBOROUGH
COMMUNITY ASSOCIATION AND
MEMBER OF C. A. I. I SUPPORT AB.
FIVE OH TWO. AT THIS TIME THERE
ARE NO- NO OTHERS IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOUS ARE
KNOWN IN THE QUEUE IN
OPPOSITION BECAUSE I KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF CONFUSION
ABOUT THAT. IN MILLION JUMP
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF AB FIVE
OH TO PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION. AT
THIS TIME WE DO HAVE ABOUT FOUR
IN THE QUEUE. GO TO NUMBER ONE
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH I DIDN'T WANT MY CALDWELL
DISTRICT I AM IN OPPOSITION TO
FEDERAL TO AYE METHODICAL
ACCOUNTING. THANK YOU NEXT
BIGGER. THANKS TO BE NUMBER ONE
TWENTY NINE EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD NUMBER ONE TWENTY EIGHT.
ONE TWENTY AIRLINES OPEN. THE
NUMBER ONE TWENTY SEVEN SORRY
TO TWENTY SEVEN NUMBER TWO
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO HELLO WE CAN HEAR YOU YES
YOU. WE CAN HEAR YOU HI. WE CAN
HEAR YOU YOU CLEARLY CAN'T HEAR
US OKAY. YEAH MY NAME IS MARCY
GADAMER FROM THAT SOLID. THE
BUT I'M ALSO CALLING ON BEHALF
OF MY FAMILY AND FRIENDS. A
LARGE COUNTY AND I IS STRONGLY
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
YOU DON'T NOT YET THANK. YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT BIGGER NEXT TO NUMBER
THREE OH ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS EDWARD CHESHIRE AND
I'M AN ATTORNEY HERE IN SAN
DIEGO AND A HOMEOWNER AND
FORMER BOARD MEMBER OF A SIX
HUNDRED AND SEVEN UNIT COMPLEX
HERE IN SAN DIEGO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB FIVE OH TWO
THANK YOU. WE'LL AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO FURTHER IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY COMMENTS. IS OUR
MOTION WITH THE SENATE FOREIGN.
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND A
SECOND ANY FINAL COMMENTS BY
THE AUTHOR I WOULD I JUST LIKE
TO MAKE JUST A COUPLE MOMENTS
OF OPPOSITION- IN REGARDS TO
THE BOARD'S DECISION MAKING
POWER- I JUST WANNA REMIND
EVERYONE THAT AB FIVE A TWO
DOES NOT PERMIT A BOARD TO MAKE
ANY DECISIONS ABOUT WHETHER
BUILDING. IS REQUIRED THE
DECISION IS SOLELY BASED ON THE
NUMBER OF CANDIDATES TO SUBMIT
THEIR NAME. AND AN OPEN
ELECTION AND NOT ONLY DO THEY
GET THIRTY DAYS WERE ADDING
NINETY DAYS SO THEY HAVE TO
OPPORTUNITIES HERE. TO MAKE
SURE THAT IF THEY'D LIKE TO RUN
THEY COULD. AND THEN ALSO
MAKERS TO IT SHOULD BE RUN LIKE
A GOVERNMENT- ELECTION I WANT
TO REMIND THEM FIRST OF ALL OF
THAT WITH THIS HOUSE DID PAST
SEVEN FORTY. SEVEN FIVE FOUR IS
WELL AND THEY HAVE NOT HAD ANY
CONCERNS WITH IT A SINCE IT'S
PASSED IN TWENTY NINETEEN.
ADDITIONALLY MANY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ELECTIONS LOW
ACCLAMATION UNCONTESTED
ELECTIONS FOR EXAMPLE WITH
REGARD TO SCHOOL BOARD
ELECTIONS- ALSO- IF WE HAVE
THE- GOVERNING BOARD MEMBERS AT
LARGE DO NOT EXCEED THE NUMBER
OF OFFICES TO BE FILLED AT THE
ELECTION- THE PETITION WOULD GO
AHEAD AND THEN ALSO DO. A
COMMISSION SO THAT- DOES SET
PRECEDENTS THAT IT DOES HAPPEN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT- I ASKED AN
UP. A YES THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR MOVING
THIS FORWARD AND- I AM
PERSONALLY INTIMATELY AWARE OF
THE FACT THAT MANY H. AWAY
STRUGGLE TO FIND CANDIDATES TO
RUN FOR BOARDS OF DIRECTORS-
AND I THINK THAT DOES SET IT
APART FROM. TYPICAL PUBLIC
GOVERNMENTAL ELECTIONS- I
APPRECIATE- THE AUTHOR WORKING
WITH OUR STAFF TO REALLY TRY TO
STRIKE THE RIGHT BALANCE
BETWEEN THE NEED FOR
EFFICIENCY. WITH THE RIGHTS OF
ALL ENJOYED MEMBERS TO HAVE
FAIR ELECTIONS WITH ADEQUATE
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND I KNOW THAT SHE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS MOVING FORWARD TO
TRY TO. ENSURE THAT WE FINDING
THAT BALANCE BUT- WITH THAT-
THERE'S A MOTION BEFORE TO
SECOND MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS CHIU HI CHIU I
SAY ARE TOO HIGH. BY GABRIELLE.
KALRA I. HIGHLY I. WARD FORTY
FIVE SILVA OKAY FIVE WEEKS TO
FOUR FIVE TWO ZERO SAN FIVE TWO
ZERO CORRECT YOU HAVE YOUR
VOTES TO GET THE BILL OUT WILL
ASK OTHERS TO ADD ON THANK YOU
AND STATE FOR MAKE MY FLIGHT.
THANK YOU GOOD LUCK. SO WHAT
COLLEAGUES I JUST WANNA LET
FOLKS KNOW WE HAVE ALLOWED
AUTHORS. WHO ARE NOT MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE TO TAKE SOME
ITEMS OUT OF ORDER AT THIS
POINT WE'RE GONNA START BACK UP
FROM THE TOP OF THE ORDER. OF
MANY OF THESE ITEMS WILL BE
PRESENTED BY DIFFERENT MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE- STARTING
WITH THE FIRST ITEM AB SEVENTY
ONE. ASSEMBLYMEMBER LUIS RIVAS
IS ITEM WHICH I WILL RAISE AND
I'M GONNA ASK MY VICE CHAIR TO
CHAIR THIS PORTION OF THE
MEETING. GREAT THANK YOU. SO I
WILL GIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHOOSING THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET
DOWN THERE AND INTRODUCED THE
BILL. YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES I AM PRESENTING
AB SEVENTY ONE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY WOMAN THREE OF US- AND
ALSO AS A JOINT AUTHORS THIS
BILL AND THE MYSTERY OF THIS-
WILL BE TAKING THE TECHNICAL
MOMENTS NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS
THAT REFER REVENUES NOT BE USED
FOR THE PURCHASE ORDER ELEMENTS
OF LAND ALSO JUST MENTION THAT
THE CEMENT THIS BILL WAS
AMENDED IN REDDING TAX
COMMITTEE- TO REMOVE THE
CORPORATE TAX AND MAKE OTHER
TECHNICAL MINUTES. AB SEVENTY
ONE WHAT ESTABLISH THE BRING
CALIFORNIA HOME ACT AND THE
MOST IMPORTANT ASPECT OF THIS
BILLS THAT WOULD ESTABLISH FOR
THE FIRST TIME AN ONGOING
SOURCE OF STATE FUNDING FOR
LONG TERM SOLUTIONS OF
HOMELESSNESS THIS IS A BILL
THAT COULD GENERATE UP TO A
BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY BY
CONFORMING STATE TAX LAW TO
FEDERAL LAW. IN ADDITION THIS
MEASURE HOLD GOVERNMENTS
ACCOUNTABLE AND CORPORATE
SIGNIFICANT ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY MEASURES TO ENSURE
THAT EVERY DOLLAR IS UTILIZED
EFFECTIVELY THIS IS A COMMITTEE
THAT WELL KNOWS THE MORAL AN
UNPRECEDENTED HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS THAT HAS BEEN COMPOUNDED
BY COVERED NINETEEN AND DESPITE
THE FACT THAT WE ARE THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD
ONE IN FOUR AMERICANS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
RESIDE IN OUR STATE. THAT MEANS
OVER A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS ARE ON
HOUSED EVERY GIVEN NIGHT WITH
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS MORE ON
THE BRINK OF HOMELESSNESS DUE
TO THIS PANDEMIC WE NEED TO
CHANGE OUR APPROACH WE NEED TO
GIVE CALIFORNIANS A FIGHTING
CHANCE TO BE HOUSED. THE
ONGOING INVESTMENTS PROPOSED BY
THIS BILL COULD MEAN THAT
TWENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE A YEAR
ON THE BRINK OF HOMELESSNESS
WOULD HAVE ACCESS TO A ROOF
OVER THEIR HEADS TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE AND FAMILIES
COULD ACCESS SAY SHELTER FORTY
THREE THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS COULD
MOVE INTO PERMANENT HOUSING.
OVER FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
COULD RECEIVE ADDITIONAL
SERVICES SUCH AS EMPLOYMENT
SUPPORT WITHIN THE FIRST YEAR
OF THIS BILL BEING SIGNED INTO
LAW THE PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE
HAS REPEATEDLY SHOWN THE
CALIFORNIANS RESOUNDINGLY
IDENTIFY HOMELESSNESS AS ONE OF
THE MOST PRESSING ISSUES OF THE
STATE. THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS.
IT DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU'RE AN
URBAN OR RURAL MEMBER- IF YOU
ARE INLAND OR ON THE COAST
NORTH OR SOUTH. WE KNOW THAT
HOMELESSNESS IS THE TOP ISSUE
FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS AND
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS. AND WITH THAT I'D LIKE
TO TURN IT OVER TO OUR
WITNESSES I WANTED JUST NOTE-
THAT TO CANCER AND TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS THAT FOLKS MAY HAVE
ABOUT THE MECHANISM OF THIS
BILL. WE ALSO HAVE ARTHUR
MANDEL FROM THE MAYOR- THAT THE
L. A. MAYOR GARCETTI'S OFICE
AS WELL AS CHRIS MARTIN WITH
HOUSING CALIFORNIA. BUT AT THIS
TIME I'D LIKE TO TURN IT OVER
TO OUR MAIN WITNESSES. FROM THE
UNITED WAY OF ORANGE COUNTY
MICHELLE MURPHY AND STEPHANIE
ASHLEY FROM BRILLIANT CORNERS.
I THANK YOU MR TO DO WE HAVE
THE- WITNESSES ON THE PHONE
MODERATOR. YES BOTH ARE ON THE
LINE ALL RIGHT LET'S GO AHEAD
AND HEAR FROM THEM. OKAY WHEN
WE HAVE MADE ALONG HERE ME. YES
MISS MISS MURPHY. THE RAM OKAY
MICHELLE MY- GOSH GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE MY NAME IS
MISS SUMMER FAMILY DIRECTOR OF
PUBLIC AFFAIRS WITH ORANGE
COUNTY UNITED WAY I'M HONORED
TO BE WITH YOU TODAY TO SPEAK
OF ONE OF THE OVER. THREE
HUNDRED NONPROFIT LEADERS
ELECTED IF. AND ADVOCATE IN THE
BROUGH HELD HOME COALITION
SUPPORTING AB SEVENTY ONE. I
KNOW BOTH IN MY CAPACITY AS A
LEADER IN A LARGE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATION I KNOW THE
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT BUT OUR
CURRENT APPROACH TO COMBATING
HOMELESSNESS IS NOT WORKING.
NINE STATE AGENCIES ADMINISTER
AND OVERSEE FORTY ONE DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS THAT PROVIDE FUNDING
TO MITIGATE MUCH. OF THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
RECENTLY PUT IT I LONG TERM
STRATEGY RATHER THAN A
PIECEMEAL STATUS QUO WOULD MAKE
IT MORE LIKELY THAT OUR
INVESTMENTS WOULD GO FURTHER
AND HAVE A MORE MEANINGFUL
IMPACT ON OUR HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS. AB SEVENTY ONE IS A
STATE WIDE STRATEGIC PLAN WE
NEED INCLUDING BOTH THE STATE
WHAT APPROACH AN ONGOING
FUNDING AT THE CBO LEADER
WORKING WITH MULTIPLE HOMELESS
SERVICE PROVIDERS I KNOW HOW
CRITICAL BOTH ARE. THE ONE TIME
INVESTMENT APPROACH HAS BEEN
VERY INEFFECTIVE FOR NONPROFIT
IMPACTING BOTH PARTICIPATION
AND EFFICACY. PIECEMEAL
APPROACHES LED. TO
UNDERWHELMING FUNDING OVERALL.
ON THE FUNDING GIVES YOU OF
THEY NEED TO BE AFFECT RATHER
THAN UP PLUG EVER YEAR IMAGE BY
TO NEW PROGRAMS. ADDITIONALLY
WITH THE STATEWIDE APPROACH CAN
PHYSICAL ACCOUNTABILITY AS IT
STANDS THERE IS LITTLE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND HELP
CALIFORNIANS IN COMBATING FROM
HOMELESSNESS SHE WAS SUCH A
DISJOINTED APPROACH HOW COULD
THERE BE. AB SEVENTY ONE
ENSURES THE GOVERNMENT COULD
CONDUCT NEEDS AND GAP ANALYSIS
IDENTIFY EXISTING PROGRAMS THAT
COULD BE TAPPED TO ADDRESS
NEEDS AND CALCULATE RESOURCE
GAPS. NEXT IT INSURES THE
GOVERNMENT ESTABLISHED
PERFORMANCE GOALS TO WHICH THEY
ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND IF
JURISDICTIONS DO NOT MEET THEIR
STATED GOAL WHEN AN ADDICT IS
TAKEN THEY WILL NOT RECEIVE THE
SAME AMOUNT OF FUNDING.
TRANSPARENTLY TRANSPARENCY
REQUIREMENTS IN AB SEVENTY ONE
ENSURE THAT RESOURCES ARE
TARGETED AT THE COMMUNITIES WHO
NEED THE MOST. BECAUSE EVEN
THOUGH THIS BILL COMES AT NO
COST TO INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYERS
THE PUBLIC DESERVES TO KNOW HOW
PUBLIC DOLLARS ARE BEING SPENT.
THIS BILL WILL EXPAND RESOURCES
FOR CBO LIKE MINE AND PAIR THEM
WITH A BOLD RESTRUCTURING OF
THE SYSTEM CALIFORNIA HAS IN
PLACE. TO ALLOCATE FUNDING AND
OVERSEE PERFORMANCE. IN THIS
MOMENT AS WE KEEP OUR COMMUNITY
SAFE FROM CARBON NINETEEN AND
ENVISION A BETTER FUTURE FOR
OUR STATE WE NEED TO ACT BOLDLY
AB SEVENTY ONE MEET THE SCALE
OF THE CRISIS AND IT IS WHAT
CALIFORNIA NEEDS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO VOTE
YES ON AB SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS MURPHY
AND THE SECOND ONE IS WE HAVE A
STEPHANIE ASHLEY. NONALIGNED
STEPHANIE. YES I AM THANK YALE
GOING AHEAD NOW THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY- GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS STEPHANIE
ACTUALLY AND THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA HOUSING SERVICES
DIRECTOR FROM BRILLIANT
CORNERS. WHICH IS A PART OF
HOUSING PROVIDER THAT OPERATES
EIGHT WIDE. WE ARE SO GRATEFUL
TO A FAMILY MEMBER RIVAS
OFFERING EXACTLY THE TYPE OF
BOLD SOLUTION NEEDED TO MEET
THE SCALE AND THE HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS IN AB SEVENTY ONE. BRING
CALIFORNIA HOME ACTIONS. FOR TO
LONG CALIFORNIA HAS TRIED TO
SOLVE HOMELESSNESS WITH PEACE
NOW PROGRAMS AND IT COMPLAIN
NOT WORKING. WHAT MAKES AB
SEVENTY ONE DIFFERENT IS THAT
IT'S A PERMANENT ONGOING
SOLUTION. HELLO THE BACK ON THE
GROUND THAT MAKES A HUGE
DIFFERENCE IT ALLOWS US TO
RECRUIT LANDLORDS TO TAKE
HOUSING COMPANIES AND PROVIDE
ONGOING SERVICES THAT MANY OF.
OUR CLIENTS NEED TO REMAIN HOW.
WE'VE SEEN ON THE FUND WENT. TO
MEET THEM. HAS RESULT- IT'S
EXACTLY THE MODEL BUNCH A
DECREASE OF ALMOST 40% IN
VETERAN THOMAS. THIS IS THE WAY
WE CAN BEGIN TO REVERSE THE
CYCLE THOMAS. AB FIVE ONE
INCOME. AND SIMULTANE THE
INFLOW OF CALIFORNIANS INTO
HOMELESSNESS. AND INCREASES
ACCESS TO PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING THE PROVEN SOLUTION TO
ENDING THE CYCLE. I BRING
CORNERS WE GET TO AND
HOMELESSNESS EVERY DAY. DONALD
A PARTICIPANT IN OUR SEPARATE
THE COMFORTABLE HOUSING SUBSIDY
POOL RECENTLY SHARED THAT.
SOMETIMES YOU THINK YOU'RE
GOING TO WAKE UP FROM THIS.
DREAM BECAUSE IT'S TOO GOOD TO
BE TRUE. THE DREAM HE ABOUT IT
SINCE THE FEELING OF HAVING HIS
OWN APARTMENT AFTER MORE THAN
FIFTY YEARS OF HOUSING
INSTABILITY. WITH THE PASSAGE
OF AB SEVENTY ONE WE CAN MAKE
THAT DREAM A REALITY FOR A
QUARTER OF THE CALIFORNIANS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IN
THE FIRST YEAR OF FUNDING
ALONE. AND PERHAPS EVEN MORE
SIGNIFICANTLY THE ENTIRE SYSTEM
OF PROVIDERS ACROSS THE STATE
CAN REDIRECT OUR FOCUS FROM
SCRAMBLING THROUGH FUNDING
BILLS AND BASS EVERY YEAR. TO
DOING WHAT WE DO BEST WHICH IS
ENDING HOMELESSNESS AND EVERY
CALIFORNIANS HAVE A HOME THANK
YOU. ACTUALLY AND WE WILL OFFER.
WE HAVE TO HAVE THAT RIGHT NOW.
AND ALL THAT YEAH OUR- OF.
SORRY ABOUT THAT I THINK YOU
MISS ASHLEY FOR YOUR- YOUR-
TESTIMONY NOW WE'RE GONNA GO TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WE HAVE
TWO WITNESSES TESTIFYING BY
PHONE THAT REAGAN AND DANTE
ACOSTA VOTER. MATT REAGAN ARE
YOU ON THE LINE. YEAH THANK YOU
I'M HERE ALL RIGHT MISTER CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MATT REGAN
FROM THE BAY AREA COUNCIL- I
WORK FOR AN ORGANIZATION THAT
NOT IDEOLOGICALLY OPPOSED TO
TAXES WE HAVE SUPPORTED MANY
TAXES IN THE PAST- PARTICULARLY
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING TENS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BE
SUPPORTED. GOVERNOR BRYANT
INCOME TAX INCREASE IN TWENTY
TWELVE- THE FIRST BUSINESS
GROUP IN CALIFORNIA TO DO SO
WE'RE NOT IDEOLOGICALLY OPPOSED
TO TAXES BUT WE ARE TO THE
SELECT- WE DEFINITELY NEED
SOLUTIONS TO HOMELESSNESS- MORE
HOMES WOULD BE A GREAT START WE
KNOW THAT- RECENT DATA FROM.
THE BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION SHOWS THAT YEAR
OVER YEAR PERMITS ARE DYING FOR
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES BY 24% FOR
DYING FOR MULTI FAMILY HOMES BY
41% FROM AN OLD RETIREMENT
ALREADY HISTORICALLY LOW
NUMBER. SO THE SOLUTION TO THIS
PROBLEM IS MORE. HOMES NOT
NECESSARILY MORE MONEY- HOME
PROGRAMS NEED BE FUND BUT THEY
NEED TO BE OVER HALL. EIGHT
COULD HARDLY ON- STATE
AUDITOR'S REPORT ON
HOMELESSNESS AND I'LL BE THE
QUICK QUOTE FROM THE COVER
LETTER FROM NOT REPORT- WITH
MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND. CALIFORNIANS WHO
EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS AND
TWENTY NINETEEN THE STATE HAS
THE LARGEST HOMELESS POPULATION
IN THE NATION. BUT IT'S
APPROACH TO ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS. IS DISJOINTED AT
LEAST NINE STATE AGENCIES
ADMINISTER AND OVERSEE FORTY
ONE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS THAT
PROVIDE FUNDING TO MITIGATE
HOMELESSNESS. YET NO SINGLE
ENTITY OVERSEES THE STATE'S
EFFORTS ARE AS RESPONSIBLE FOR
DEVELOPING A STATEWIDE
STRATEGIC PLAN. ALTHOUGH THE
HOMELESS COORDINATING AND
FINANCING COUNCIL WAS CREATED
AND PARKS TO COORDINATE
EXISTING FUNDING. AND ESTABLISH
PARTNERSHIPS WITH STAKEHOLDERS
TO DEVELOP STRATEGIES TO END
HOMELESSNESS IT HAS NOT DONE
SO. AS A RESULT THE STATE
CONTINUES TO LACK A
COMPREHENSIVE UNDERSTANDING OF
ITS SPENDING TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS. THIS IS NOT THE
TIME TO PUT MORE MONEY INTO A
DESTROYING TO PROGRAM THAT WE
KNOW CURRENTLY DOESN'T WORK WE
NEED TO PUT THE REFORMS IN
PLACE. AND THEN EXPLORE AVENUES
CRITICS NOT FUNDING. JUST LAST
WEEK THE SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS DELIBERATED A
PROGRAM FOR SLATE STATE
SLEEPING SITE. CAN'T CAMPS IN
PARKING LOT. THAT THE STATE
COMPTROLLER ESTIMATED WOULD
COST SEVENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER YEAR PER TENT THAT'S THE
MORTGAGE ON A MILLION DOLLAR
HOME. L. A. ALREADY HAS SUCH A
PROGRAM IN PLACE. IT COSTS TWO
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS
PER PERSON PER PER MONTH.
ASSUMING TWO PEOPLE PER MILLION
DOLLAR HOMES THAT IS ALSO THE
MORTGAGE ON A MILLION DOLLAR
HOME. SO WE CAN'T KEEP FUNDING
PROGRAMS LIKE THIS- UNTIL WE
FIGURE OUT HOW BEST TO USE
THESE DOLLARS AND GET THE BEST
FROM PA BANG FOR OUR BUCK. THE
REFORMS MUST COME FIRST AND
THEN THE FUNDING WE
RESPECTIVELY ASKED FOR A NO
VOTE. ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU
MISTER REAGAN. DAN CLAWSON AND
OR ARE YOU ON THE- YES I AM YOU
MAY PROCEEDS. PLEASE KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS AT TWO MINUTES. THAT
MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS AND HOW TO
BETTER ON THE VICE PRESIDENT
FOR TAX POLICY AT THE SILICON
VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP. I
SPEAK TODAY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
SEVENTY ONE. AB SEVENTY ONE
INCREASES TAXES ON TWO TYPES OF
INCOME. GLOBAL INTANGIBLE LOW
TAXED INCOME KNOWN AS GUILTY
AND REPATRIATION INCOME EARNED
BY WATER SUCH TAXPAYERS. LTM
REPATRIATION INCOME WERE PART
OF A FEDERAL LEGISLATION THAT
WAS PASSED IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
IS ASSERTED THAT TAXING GUILTY
IN REPATRIATION INCOME WOULD
MERELY CONFORM TO FEDERAL LAW.
THAT IS SEARCHING IS. BECAUSE
THE GUILTY AND REPATRIATION
PROVISIONS WERE PART OF A BROAD
INTERNATIONAL TAX REFORM THOSE
REFORMS INCLUDED A MAJOR
REDUCTION IN THE U. S.
CORPORATE INCOME TAX RATE FROM
35% TO TWENTY ONE PERCENT. TO
CHERRY PICK REVENUE RAISERS
LIKE GUILTY AND REPATRIATION
INCOME WITHOUT ALSO REDUCING
CALIFORNIA'S CORPORATE INCOME
TAX RATE SHOWS THE CONFORMITY
IS NOT WHAT AB SEVENTY ONE IS
ABOUT. REPATRIATION INCREASE
FEDERAL TAXABLE INCOME IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN TAXING THIS
INCOME NOW WOULD INVOLVE AND
UNPRECEDENTED RETROACTIVE TAX.
AB SEVENTY ONE WILL TAX GUILTY
IN REPATRIATION INCOME ONLY FOR
WATER'S EDGE TAXPAYERS THE
WATER'S EDGE ELECTION IS
REFERRED TO AS A LOOPHOLE WHICH
IT CERTAINLY IS NOT THE WATER'S
EDGE ALEXIAD BECAME UP ON THE
METAL PROVISION OF CALIFORNIA
TAX LAW TO TERMINATE AN
INTERNATIONAL TRADE DISPUTE
TRIGGERED BY CALIFORNIANS
WORLDWIDE UNITARY TAX SYSTEM.
AB SEVENTY WHAT WOULD ONCE
AGAIN EMBROILED THE UNITED
STATES IN THE ST INTERNATIONAL
TRADE DISPUTES THAT PROMPTED
PASSAGE OF THE WATER'S EDGE
ROLLS IN THE FIRST PLACE.
FINALLY THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD
ENCOURAGE ECONOMIC GROWTH IN
CALIFORNIA PLODDING TURGID
PLAYERS LEAD CALIFORNIA BY
INCREASING TAXES ON OUR JOB
CREATORS. THANK YOU PLEASE VOTE
NO ON AB SEVENTY ONE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SIR. SO NOW WE'RE
GOING TO BRING IT BACK FOR.
PEOPLE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
FOR OTHER TESTIMONY SO DO WE
HAVE ANYBODY IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM WHICH IS TO SPEAK YES
MA'AM. YES SIR GO AHEAD. PARKS
DIVERSE THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER PRE FOR
PERSONS IN SUPPORT IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. BEING A NON
ANYBODY IN THE REMOTE. LOCATION
IT IS NOT APPEAR TO BE ANY SO
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM. SB NINE ANYBODY ON THE
REMOTE. IT DOES NOT APPEAR TO
BE ANY SO AT THIS TIME WE WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES TO HAVE
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT PLEASE
STATE AND PLEASE FOLKS AND HERE
DID THIS PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
THE ORGANIZATION OF WHICH YOU
REPRESENT. AND WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE- THAT WAY WE
CAN GET AS MANY PEOPLE IN AS WE
CAN- IF THERE ARE TOO MANY
PEOPLE ON THE LINES WE MAY HAVE
TO LIMIT THE AMOUNT OF TIME TO
TEN MINUTES. TOTAL SO- THE
MODERATOR YOU HAVE ANYBODY ON
THE LINE. AND LATE IN GERMAN IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION AB SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN
ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. I AM SURE AT THIS
TIME WE DO HAVE MORE THAN
EIGHTY IN Q. OKAY WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO IS WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
TESTIMONY FOR TEN MINUTES. AND
THEN THE OTHERS WILL BE ABLE
TO- GO OUT TO THE WEBSITE AND
PUT IT IN OUR PUT IN THEIR
TESTIMONY- SO- FOLKS AGAIN SO
WE CAN GET AS MANY PEOPLE AS
POSSIBLE NAME ORGANIZATION
OPPOSE OR SUPPORT. SO MODERATOR
GO AHEAD AND CALL THE FIRST
PERSON. AND WE'LL START WITH
NUMBER TWO SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MISTER I CHEN MEMBERS
MONICA MILLER MORE FOR THE
ALBANY COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO THOUSAND ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT BEAKER.
THANKS TO BE NUMBER THREE
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BOB
MICHAEL RATIGAN ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA
CLARA COUNTY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR NEXT SPEAKER.
NEXT TO BE NUMBER THREE EIGHTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
VICE CHAIR MEMBERS MARKET
GUERRERO REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS COSPONSORED YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT SPEAKER. NEXT WE GO
TO THREE EIGHTY FIVE WOULD YOU
HEAD. SEPARATE FROM THE HOUSE
HELP YOU CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WEEK-
PLEASE. NEXT IS GOING TO BE THE
NUMBER THREE K<c.cyan> PLEASE GO</c>
AHEAD. THANK HI THIS IS ALEX
KEPPLER ON BEHALF OF THE
PARTNERSHIPS AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT RECORD. NEXT IS NUMBER ONE
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MICHAEL AND THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA PLANNING AND URBAN
RESEARCH ASSOCIATION HORSE
BURKE AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NEXT WEEK OR NEXT TO BE NUMBER
THREE SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER VICE CHAIR MEMBERS WENDY
**** REPRESENTING HAPPILY
SYCAMORES LOCATED IN THE L. A.
COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY
ONE. THANK YOU NEXT WEEK-
NUMBER THREE EIGHTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON I
DON'T TO BUDGETARY BIRDS
ROSANNA CAMACHO ELLIOT CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
ALAMEDA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WEEK- NEXUS
NUMBER THREE EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
SYLVIA POLICE SHOT ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS FOR
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT. NUMBER THREE SIXTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS MODELING
COOPER FROM NIELSEN MARKS WERE
ON BEHALF OF CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WEEK. NEXT IS
TWO THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GET OUT HIS ANNUALLY ON
BEHALF OF NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. THANK
SPEAKER. NEXUS LINE ONE NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINETY YOUR
LINES OPEN. NEXT WEEK REPLACE.
WELL MOVED IN LINE ONE THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON GENERAL POLITICS
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT WEEK. NUMBER THREE NINETY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CRISTINA CRISTINA
CRANKED ON BEHALF OF SILICON
VALLEY AT HOME ACTION ON IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT WEEK.
ACTUALLY ONE FIFTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
VICE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS WILLIAM
GOODWIN I AM CALLING FROM
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY HAS BECOME
A POIGNANT AND TIMELY MEMBER OF
THE REGIMENT UNITED NETWORK AND
I STRONGLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR NEXT SPEAKER.
WHEN I GO TO LINE THREE TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE TWELVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY IS
AN- IT IS I THE VERGE FOR THE
HELLO. THANK YOU NEXT PHONE. I
WILL NOW GO TO NUMBER THREE
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS REGINA SHIPMAN CALLING
ON BEHALF OF LUCIEN'S RESIDENT
EMPOWERMENT PROGRAM AND A
STRONG PARTNERSHIP WITH
RESIDENT UNITED NETWORK ARE
YOUR SUPPORT AB SEVENTY ONE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU. NEXT WEEK- NEXT TO NUMBER
THREE FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS A
LOCAL RESIDENT SACRAMENTO I'M
HERE THANK YOU UNITED NOT
WORKING STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT WEEK- PLEASE. NOW GO
TO NUMBER TWO FIFTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK GOOD AFTERNOON.
GO AHEAD MA'AM. BONTA CALLING
ON BEHALF OF PREPARATION FOR
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING HE TOOK
BONTA EIGHTY SEVENTY ONE OF ALL
THE BRING CALIFORNIA HOME
POLLUTION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT WEEK- NEXT
TO NUMBER THREE SIXTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO ARE
PREPARED TO PAY FOR EVERYONE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR NEXT
WINTER. NOW THE NUMBER THREE
NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMEN.
YEAH FROM WHAT WE HAVE TO LOOK
AT THIS WE ARE IN FRONT SUPPORT
OF AB SEVENTY ONE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR NEXT WEEK PLEASE.
NEXUS NUMBER THREE SEVENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES NICCOLO
DELUCA CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
OAKLAND MAYOR LIBBY SCHAAF THE
OAKLAND CITY COUNCIL A
NONPROFIT- HOW THE NUMBER IN
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SIR NEXT WEEK. NEXT WE NEVER TO
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
IRWIN YOU ON THE TOP. THE COURT.
THANKS NEXT BIGGER. NEXT NUMBER
THREE NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BERMAN DOTSON. SAN JOSE
RESIDENTS. SUPPORT THANK YOU
MA'AM. NEXT WILL BE NUMBER
THREE NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS.
DAKSH LIKE OFFER A PATH PEOPLE
IN THE HOME. FONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU SIR NEXT WEEK OR. THANKS TO
BE NUMBER TWO EIGHTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. EIGHTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL OF MY
RECORDS NUMBER ONE MY FIRST
YEAR AND I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT AB SEVENTY ONE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WEEK- NEXUS
NUMBERS THREE SEVENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
AGAIN TWENTY WHICH ARE YOU'RE A
YOUNG POLICEMAN LYING ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
WRONG SUPPORT AB SEVENTY ONE
THANK YOU SIR NEXT WEEK- NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO FIFTY
SEVEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR VICE CHAIR THIS IS
CHRIS WYSOCKI WITH WESTERN
MANUFACTURED HOUSING
COMMUNITIES ASSOCIATION AND WE
ARE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR NEXT WEEK PLEASE. NUMBER
THREE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON NICOLE
BORNEMANN WITH PRECISION
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT SPEAKER.
NUMBER ONE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS.
KOTHAMANGALAM FALL FORWARD
ARMENIAN FROM SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT WEEK REPLACE. NEXUS
NUMBER THREE EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
ALEX THE SAKE ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES HOMELESS SERVICES
AUTHORITY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU TO OUR NEXT SPEAKER
PLEASE. WELL NOW GONNA NUMBER
THREE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WELL CALL CALLING WITH
SACRAMENTO HOUSING ALLIANCE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY
ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM
NEXT NEXT BE COMPANIES. LEX'S
NUMBER ONE SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS JEFFREY
ROBINSON BLUE LAKE CALIFORNIA
NUMBER OF RESIDENTS UNITED
NETWORK PLEASE SUPPORT AB
SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU SIR NEXT
WEEK PLEASE. TEXAS NUMBER ONE
NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS JORDAN THANKS FOR
CALLING ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
YOUTH CONNECTION CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF AB DE DEVELOPMENT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WEEK-
NEXT WE NUMBER THREE EIGHTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIRTY HOP ON
BEHALF OF BILLS AFFORDABLE
FACTOR CALIFORNIA PROJECT OF
TOPICAL AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROVIDER IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WEEK OR. NEXT TO
NUMBER TWO OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. JULIE SNYDER WITH THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE A CO
SPONSOR THE MEASURE- WE'RE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MAN MODERATOR HOW MANY MORE
DO WE HAVE IN THE QUEUE. WE
CURRENTLY STILL HAVE FORTY
EIGHT IN THE QUEUE THANKS ARE
DUE IN ABOUT A TEN MINUTE CLIP
FOR ALL OF THEM WE'RE GONNA GO
AHEAD AND TAKE THOSE ADDITIONAL
SPEAKERS SINCE WE DID NOT DO IT
FOR. EARLIER SO GO AHEAD
CONTINUE WITH THE SPEAKERS. I
WILL NEXT GO TO NUMBER THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THRUSTING YOUNG FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
HERE IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WEEK- NEXUS
NUMBER FOUR OH ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS KEVIN LOVE
AND HOW AUTHOR AND A MEMBER OF
THE PRESIDENT'S UNITED NETWORK
SUPPORT AB SEVENTY ONE. THANK
YOU NEXT WEEK- NEXUS THREE
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IT SAYS IGOR
TRACK OF. TAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC
WINTERS COUNCIL B. ALAMEDA
COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THE
BERKELEY TENANTS UNION ALL
THREE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR CONSOLIDATING NEXT SPEAKER.
LEX'S THREE SIXTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MORE UPDATED ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURING TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION RESPECT WE OPPOSED
TO AB SEVENTY ONE OF THE
MANUFACTURING BREAKER THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR NEXT WEEK OR-
NEXT IN LINE ONE TEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS A
FAMILY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WEEK OR. NEXT IS ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TORY SURE I WAS A RESIDENT BEEN
ADDED NETWORK AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT WEEK OR-
SHE- WELL NOW I GOT A ONE
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MODERATOR MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE JOURNEY'S
NOT HERE ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL ALSO SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR NEXT
WEEK OR. WE'RE NOW GOING TO
NUMBER TWO TWENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NEXT B. GRADE TWENTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. REMOVE
THE NEXT WEEK OR PLEASE. WILL
MOVE ON TO NUMBER TWO FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JOE BARRETT. AND I LIVE IN SAN
DIEGO CREMATE THAT AND I'M A
MEMBER AT THE RESIDENT UNITED
NETWORK CALLING IN WHICH STRONG
SUPPORT ON AB SEVENTY ONE THANK
YOUNG. THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER.
NEXT IS ONE FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ALAN KNIGHT
I'M DISABLED LIVED EXPERIENCE
OF HOMELESSNESS MEMBER OF
RESIDENT UNITED NETWORK HERE IN
SUN VALLEY URGING YOUR STRONG
SUPPORT IN REGARDS TO AB
SEVENTY ONE TO SAVE LIVES LIKE
MINE THE NAME UNIVERSITY GROUP
PLEASE. THE EXORCIST FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
HELLO MY NAME IS RYAN DO LITTLE
CALLING- FOR THE ELAINE LOW
ASSOCIATION OF TYLER WILKES AND
I AM IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY
ONE THANK YOU FOR NEXT WEEK OR.
NEXT IS NUMBER TWO OH FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TO- FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NEXT BIGGER THAN.
WILL MOVE TO NUMBER ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ALLISON
RADIUM BY MEMBER OF THE IN
RESIDENT UNITED NETWORK AND I'M
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY
ONE. THANK YOU MA'AM ACT
SPEAKER. THANKS IS ONE SEVENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD- HELLO MY
NAME IS PATRICK GAP IT I AM A
FORMER FOSTER YOUTHS AND FORMER
HOME A FEW. THANK YOU OPPOSE
YOUR SUPPORT. EXPEED REPLACE.
NEXUS NUMBER TWO FIFTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MANNY
PACQUIAO ON BEHALF OF TECH THAT
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THANK YOU
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT WEEK OR-
NEXUS THREE SEVENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THAT THE
METHANE MONEY WITH RESIDENTS IN
AND A NETWORK AND HOMELESS
EXPERIENCE ADVOCACY AND
LEADERSHIP AND TRUMP SUPPORT OF
AB SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT SPEAKER. NEXT IS ONE
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS ANDREY AND DRIVING A
MEMBER RESIDENTS UNITED NETWORK
STOPPED IN CENTRAL VALLEY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY
ONE THANK YOU NEXT BEAKER. WELL
NOW GO TO NUMBER ONE EIGHTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME'S MARIN NINE DAYS I LIVE
IN CALI CALIFORNIA. WHEN I AM A
MEMBER OF RESIDENT UNITED
NETWORK AND I URGE YOUR SUPPORT
AND AB SEVENTY ONE. THANK YOU
NEXT WEEK OR. TEXAS NUMBER ONE
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS IN OCTOBER I'M A
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER WITH PUBLIC
POLICY COMMUNITY ORGANIZING A
COMMUNITY HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
OF SAN FRANCISCO AND COALITION
WITH RESIDENT UNITED NETWORK IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
WEEK YOU'RE- NEXT WILL BE
NUMBER THREE THIRTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JEFFREY
WINKLER I'M A RESIDENT OF LOS
ANGELES AND I AM AN AVID. ALL
QUESTIONING THAT A NETWORK ONE
AND THREE I AM SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WEEK- PLEASE. NEXUS THREE
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
VERY ALONG SHEIKH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL HOUSING
FINANCE AGENCY'S IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT WEEK-
NEXUS THREE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS TRYING TO
COME ON STAGE AND I'M LEAVING
TOWN A LAWYER. I'M A MEMBER OF
THE- AMERICAN NETWORK AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB SEVENTY ONE
THANK YOU NEXT WEEK OR PLEASE.
NEXT IS TWO EIGHTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YEAH THE RAINY I
LIVE. ONE YEAH OF OCTOBER THAT
IT. UNITED NETWORK AND I. FOUR
EIGHT SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR CALLING AND NEXT
WEEK- NEXUS THREE NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
JONAS LARKIN AND I'M FROM SAN
DIEGO I'M A MEMBER OF THE
ALMOST EXPERIENCED ADVOCACY AND
LEADERSHIP NETWORK CALL YOU IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF. EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU SIR NEXT
SPEAKER. NEXUS THREE SIXTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS ANNA THOMPSON WITH OHN
BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH IN
STRONG SUPPORT AS WELL AS
PATRICK THE FOSTER YOUTH WITH
CUT OFF EARLIER THAN. THANK YOU
NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE. NEXUS
NUMBER TWO FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MAX SPEAKER. SIX IS THREE
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEY
THIS IS JIMMY CARTER ON BEHALF
OF SORT THE FILES HERE IN THE
SAN FRANCISCO SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING PROVIDER NETWORK IS
STRONG SUPPORTER AB SEVENTY ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WEEK-
X. IS ONE EIGHTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO HELLO SIR GO
AHEAD HELLO YES WE CAN HEAR YOU.
MMHM YES WE CAN HEAR YOU SIR GO
AHEAD. OKAY YES IS A MISTER
CHRISTOPHER JENNINGS I'M OF
COURSE ISN'T WAS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BUILDING. DESIGN
CONSTRUCTION AND I'M A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF AB SEVERAL THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOUNG
CONSIDERATION OF THANK YOU SIR
NEXT WEEK- LEX'S THREE TWENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. IRAN
CORNET AUSTIN RESIDENTS AND
HADN'T GONE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT FIGURE.
NEXT TO NUMBER ONE SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I JOIN SHOULD
PRODUCTIVE MEMBER PRESIDENT
UNITED NOW WE'RE CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY
ONE THANK YOU NEXT WEEK OR-
NEXUS NUMBER THREE SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
EIGHT ANTI PAN AM- MEMBER UP
THE UNIT ELECTED IN UNITED
NETWORK IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU NEXT YEAR.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE THREE
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRPERSON AND-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
MRS FAILURE CUNNINGHAM I AM A
MEMBER OF RESIDENT UNITED
NETWORK. I RESIDE IN OAKLAND
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU
MANAGE SPEAKER. NEXUS NUMBER
ONE SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS DAMIEN
SCOTT WITH THE EAST BAY HOUSING
ORGANIZATIONS CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY ONE.
THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER. NEXUS
TWO OH TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO
OH TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. SOUNDS
LIKE NOT NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE.
AND I JUST AN UPDATE WE DO HAVE
FIFTEEN LEFT IN THE QUEUE
EXCELLENT I WILL NOW GO TO
NUMBER TWO OF SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS JOYCE ROBINS
FROM SAN DIEGO I'M A MEMBER OF
RESIDENT UNITED NETWORK AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT. AB SEVENTY
ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WEEK OR. NUMBER FOUR OH FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
QUAN ABOUT GOV- WITH EIGHT
BEHIND THE CALIFORNIA BETWEEN
EMPOWERMENT AND IN SUPPORT OF
SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU SIR NEXT
WEEK- NEXT TO NUMBER THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS COLIN HAWLEY CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF WEST
SACRAMENTO MEMBER OF THE FREE
CALIFORNIA PHONE POLLUTION THAT
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT WEEK
YOU'RE- NEXT IS FOUR OH SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
ROBERT COMMENTS FROM ECHO PARK
LOS ANGELES I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF PRESIDENT UNITED
NETWORK IN HOUSING CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY
ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WEEK OR- THIS IS FOUR HUNDRED
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS A TO MAKE THEM LAUGH I'M A
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH IN
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AND I'M
FROM SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY ONE.
THANK YOU NEXT BEFORE. NEXT IS
FOUR OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ANGELICA VELASQUEZ I LIVE IN
TULARE CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT
HOUSING FOR THE HOMELESS AND
SERVICES SO I ARE YOU SUPPORT
AB SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WEEK. FOR NEXT TO ME
NUMBER THREE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
CALLIE BETTER STRONGER WOMEN
UNITED ORANGE COUNTY AND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY
ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WEEK- NEXT TO NUMBER ONE FIFTY
FIVE IS GOOD AT. HELLO MY NAME
IS MADELINE JOHNSON I WOULD
MAKE A BRING CALIFORNIA HOME
DEAR COMMITTEE AND I'M STRONGLY
AND REPORT OF AB SEVENTY ONE
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT WEEK OR.
THANKS IS NUMBER THREE THIRTEEN
PLEASE GUIDE. BUDGETARY
NUMBERS- THAT THAT PULLING HAVE
NOT REPRESENTING ANYBODY THAT'S
AROUND BUT THINKING FOR MYSELF
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT WEEK- THIS IS NUMBER FOUR
OH NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON DAVID LOCAL
TECHNICIAN HOME SMOKING VALLEY
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY ONE THANK
YOU NEXT SPEAKER. EXES NUMBER
TWO NINETY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO EVERYONE MY NAME
IS RUBY RODRIGUEZ I LIVED IN
FAMILY ANDRO AND I'M A MEMBER
OF THE BUDGET UNITED NETWORK
AND- I WORKED WITH ST MERRY'S
CENTER AND I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT AB SEVENTY ONE. THANK
YOU NEXT SPEAKER PLANS. EXIT
NUMBER TWO TWENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TWO TWENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ON ONE NEXT B.
GROUP PLEASE. EXHIBIT NUMBER
FOUR ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON BRIAN FLORENCE
AUGUSTA- WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT WEEK- EXIT NUMBER FOUR
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MANY HERE ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA
LIFE SCIENCES ASSOCIATION-
PERSPECTIVE OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU SIR NEXT WEEK FOR. TO BE
NUMBER FOUR EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON EACH
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ROUGH GO OKAY ON YOUNG FORMER
BOILS SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER AND
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FOURTEEN
DELEGATES IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU. FOR
OUR NEXT SPEAKER. NEXT TO
NUMBER FOUR FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS CHRISTINA
MILLER ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ALLIANCE AND
HOMELESSNESS AND STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE.
NEXT WILL BE NUMBER FOUR TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS WILLIE STEVEN I'M
FROM OAKLAND CALIFORNIA AND I'M
WITH LULA- RESIDENT UNITED
NETWORK AND I'M A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF EIGHT P. SEVENTY
ONE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
SPEAKER. TO BE NUMBER FOUR
TWENTY SIX IS IT A. GOOD
AFTERNOON EXACTLY WARM UP IN
THE DOWNTOWN WOMEN'S CENTER OF
LOS ANGELES AND A MEMBER OF THE
BRING CALIFORNIA HOME COALITION
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WEEK- PLEASE. NEXUS
NUMBER FOUR TWENTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO. SUPPORT AB
SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE. AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO OTHERS IN
THE QUEUE PLEASE ONTINUE GREAT
NOW SO THAT'LL BRING US BACK
AND WE WILL GO TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MISTER WARD YOU HAVE A
COMMENT. GREAT I WANNA THANK
THE AUTHOR AND THE CHAIR FORCE
ARE PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF THE
ALL FOR THIS I KNOW THIS IS IT
AND TEN INTENSIVE BILL THAT SHE
HAS PUT A LOT OF EFFORT INTO IT
AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
REALLY ADDRESS A LOT OF OUR
HOMELESSNESS SOLUTIONS
COMPREHENSIVELY- AS A NEW
MEMBER I WAS A FORMER CHAIR OF
OUR C. OR C. IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AND OF COURSE OF THE
COUNCILMEMBER REPRESENTING SOME
OF THE MOST IMPACTED
NEIGHBORHOODS THIS ISSUE
STRIKES ME VERY- PERSONALLY
THAT I'VE INVESTED A LOT AND WE
HAVE TO DO A LOT BETTER FOR
STATE. WE KNOW WE'RE GOING TO
NEED A LOT OF ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES AND WE KNOW WE NEED
THOSE RESOURCES TO BE ON GOING
ON THIS IS GOING TO BE A MULTI
YOUR PROBLEM AND I APPRECIATE
THAT WE'VE HAD SOME REALLY
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WHAT WE
MIGHT BE ABLE TO DO WITH THIS
BUDGETS- CYCLE COMING UP WE'LL
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION BUT
THAT'S ONE TIME FUNDING THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A ON GOING
REVENUE STREAM I THINK IT'S
CRITICAL- AND IT NEEDS TO BE
HEALTHY WE HAVE A BIG PROBLEM
FACING A STATEWIDE- AND IT'S
GOING TO DEMAND. THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO PLAN FOR AND
EXECUTE APPROPRIATE SOLUTIONS
FOR HOMELESSNESS ON THIS THE-
IN THE SENATE VERY
COMPREHENSIVE BILL THAT BOTH-
ADDRESSES THAT FUNDING IT'S
IMPORTANT WHERE YOU GOING TO
PAY FOR IT BUT ALSO MAKE SURE
ON THAT WE ARE PROVING UPON OUR
ARE. WHERE THE FUNDING IS
DIRECTED- AND HOW WE ARE
HOLDING ACCOUNTABLE TO THEIR TO
THE TAXPAYERS AND HOW WE ARE
MOST IMPORTANTLY DIRECTING IT
TOWARDS EFFECTIVE SOLUTIONS- I
SEE IT'S GOING TO HIGHLIGHT A
COUPLE OF THINGS HERE- AND ALL
OF A PLACE MAKE A COMMENT
RATHER THAN BEING REALLY SEEK
OUT ANY ANY FEEDBACK- KNOWING
THAT THE AUTHOR AND HER TEAM
ARE LISTENING CLOSELY AS THIS
IS GOING FOR AND HAPPY TO MOVE
THE BILL- AS WELL. MISTER BANKS
HERE- FIRST OF ALL ON THE
MEMBERSHIP OF THE HOMES CORNING
FINANCING COUNCIL I KNOW THAT
THERE ARE OTHER SPECIFIC
DIRECTION TO UTILIZE MANY OF
THE DIRECTORS OF THE DIFFERENT
AGENCIES I THINK I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO IMPROVE UPON THE
MEMBERSHIP OF THEIR ANYONE BE
SOME FLEXIBILITY TO ALLOW. FOR
REPRESENTATIVES TO SOMETIMES
DIRECTORS MAY NOT BE AVAILABLE.
ON ACS. ALSO IS SUSPECT. ON
THIS BILL. ALL RIGHT TO. THE
ALLOCATED IN A CERTAIN WAY. I
WOULD ENCOURAGE- I THINK
FURTHER SPECIFICATION TO
ENSHRINE AND ENSURE. THAT MOST
OF THE FUNDING- IS REALLY
DEDICATED TOWARDS HOUSING. OR
SOMETIMES IT'S HARD REFERS TO
AS POSITIVE EXITS- SOMETIMES I
THINK SOME BEER THAT- LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT MAY NOT HAPPEN
TO ME NOT HAVING ACT TOGETHER-
ARE USING THIS MONEY WITH. ALL
GOOD INTENT- BUT DOESN'T
ACTUALLY PRODUCE MANY THE
OUTCOMES THAT WE EXPECT WE KNOW
WE NEED TO MAKE THOSE
INVESTMENTS AND HOUSING
SOLUTIONS- SO THAT NOBODY AN
IMPORTANT IMPROVEMENT- AND ALSO
WRITTEN NOTE AS WELL THAT. I
THINK THE BASELINE START TO RE
USING FOR. A GOOD- A GOOD BASED
WEIGHT OF THIS IS ON THE TWENTY
NINETEEN POINT IN TIME COUNT- I
WOULD CLAUSSEN. CONTINUING TO
USE THAT FOR TWO REASONS ONE- I
THOUGHT THE ONLY METRIC OF HOW
WE MEASURE THE HOMELESS
POPULATION THERE SO THERE MAY
BE OTHER WAYS. TO REALLY
IDENTIFY THE SCOPE IN THE
MAGNITUDE OF THOSE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IN A GIVEN REGION.
AND THAT NUMBER WILL CHANGE
OVER TIME HOPEFULLY IT WILL
CHANGE. IN THE NEGATIVE
HOPEFULLY THAT NUMBER WILL GO
DOWN. AND I KNOW WE'VE SEEN
THIS IN PREVIOUS BUDGET YEARS
WHERE WE'VE USED THE POINT IN
TIME COUNT AS- A SINGULAR
METRIC TO BE ABLE DECIDE WHO
GETS WHAT. BUT IF THE AREA IS
GOD'S ACT TOGETHER IF AN AREA
IS IMPROVING. YOU WOULD EXPECT
TO SEE A REDUCTION IN
HOMELESSNESS AND WE SHOULD NOT
PENALIZE. OUT REGIONS THAT HAVE
THEIR ACT TOGETHER AND THAT ARE
ACTUALLY DOING THINGS RIGHT. WE
SHOULD REWARD THOSE SAID LET'S
JUST BE- I CONTINUE TO BE
THOUGHTFUL ABOUT HOW WE ARE-
SORT OF BROAD BRUSHING. AND
THE- DISTRIBUTION OF FUNDS-
NEXT ON PERFORMANCE OUTCOMES
THESE ARE CRITICAL IN THIS IS
ACTUALLY A MAJOR IMPROVEMENT
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE DEFINING
THOSE. AND WE ARE HOLDING OUR
RECIPIENTS ACCOUNTABLE THOREZ-
I REALLY LIKE WITH THIS BILL
HAS AS IT. IS A GOOD STARTING
POINT. I WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
AUTHOR TO CONTINUE TO ENGAGE
THE NATIONAL ALLIANCE TO END
HOMELESSNESS. IN THE UNITED
STATES IN REGENCY COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS. THEY'VE DONE A
LOT OF DAVID INTERMENT STUDIES
ABOUT WHAT WE- BE MET- AND I
THINK IT'S SHOULD BE REFER. IN
POLICIES. I APPRECIATE THAT
THERE IS A STRONG REQUIREMENT-
TO MAKE SURE THAT COUNTIES AND
COCS ARE APPLYING FOR FUNDING
JOINTLY. COORDINATION IN A
REGION IS EVERYTHING TOWARDS A
SUCCESS TO BE ABLE TO REDUCE.
AND HOMELESSNESS- I ALSO
APPRECIATE THAT THERE IS A
PROVISION IN THIS BILL THAT'S
GOING TO BE- DIRECTING- DIETZ
C. D. H. C. S. TO WORK ON
FEDERAL PROVE FROM MEDICAL
BENEFITS I THINK IT'S MONEY
WE'RE LEAVING ON THE TABLE-
THAT WE CAN BRING HERE TO
CALIFORNIA. AND AGAIN THIS JUST
ADDS I THINK THAT THE
COMPREHENSIVE NATURE OF WHY
THIS BILL SO IMPORTANT AND SO-
SO. IMPORTANT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PASS AND THAT THE
GOVERNOR SIGN. LASTLY ALL
MENTION OF COURSE HOW WE PAY
FOR IT- I. I THINK THAT THIS
IS- IMPORTANT IN THE SCOPE THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT. SOMETHING IN
THE TWO BILLION DOLLAR RANGE I
THINK THIS WILL BE AN ONGOING
CONVERSATION- I WOULD CAUTION
THE AUTHORED ABOUT USING
SOMETHING THAT IS SO.
SINGULARLY FOCUSED I THINK
BECAUSE OF THE- NATURE OF WHAT
WE'RE SEEING STATEWIDE THAT WE
NEED TO LOOK AT- BROAD BASED
SOLUTIONS. AND IF WE'RE JUST
LOOKING AT ONE PARTICULAR AREA.
WHETHER IT'S NOT IN THIS CASE
EIGHT TAX PROVISION THAT. IS
GOING TO IF I JUST CONVERSATION
GOES FORWARD GOING TO INVITE-
INTERNATIONAL OPPOSITION-
CHALLENGES I THINK WITH A LOT
OF OUR MANY IMPORTANT
INDUSTRIES RIGHT NOW ABOUT.
POTENTIALLY PLACING COMPETITIVE
DISADVANTAGES- FOR CALIFORNIA'S
WORK WE'RE WE'RE THE WAY THESE
INDUSTRIES ARE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- I THINK BROAD BI
SOLUTIONS ARE THE WAY TO GO SO
I THINK THAT THEY SHOULD MOVE
FORWARD IS. UP TO CONTINUE TO
ENCOURAGE THE AUTHOR TO LOOK
FOR. ADDITIONAL RESOURCES IN A
WAY TO BE ABLE TO SPREAD AGAIN
NOT SHRINKING AS PIE BECAUSE WE
NEED BIG SOLUTIONS- BUT MAKE
SURE THAT IT'S BEING DRIVEN IN
A WAY- THAT IS NOT BROAD BASED
AND- IMPACT- SO WITH THAT I'M
HAPPY. TO MOVE THE BILL AND IT
WILL BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY.
RIGHT TO HAVE A MOTION BY.
MISTER WARD- MISSED QUICK SILVA.
TO MISTER SO OFTEN DID YOU WANT
TO COMMENT. I'M SORRY AND IT
THAT WAS A MR KALRA THE SECOND.
ONE GO AHEAD MA'AM. WELL I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING A- MAJOR BILL FORWARD.
SOME OF YOU MIGHT KNOW THAT I
SPEND MANY HOURS NOT JUST TODAY
BUT- THROUGHOUT THE WEEK SINCE
I'VE BEEN IN THIS LEGISLATIVE
BODY BUT EVEN BEFORE THAT
THINKING ABOUT HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS. I'VE BEEN
AFFECTED PERSONALLY REGARDING
HOMELESSNESS. AND THIS BILL
COVERS MANY MANY OF THE
CONCERNS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT IN
THIS COMMITTEE. AS SOME OF YOU
MIGHT KNOW WE HAVE TWENTY SIX
BILLS TODAY REGARDING
HOMELESSNESS OR AND HOUSING-
AND WE'VE HAD MANY BEFORE THIS
AND WILL HAVE MANY AFTER THIS
BILL ONE DEAL CANNOT FIX WHAT
IS BROKEN- FOCUSING ON A
REVENUE. A STEADY SUSTAINABLE
REVENUE IS CERTAINLY IMPORTANT.
WE'RE IN A TIME WHERE WE HAVE
REVENUES COMING INTO THE STATE
THAT WE DID NOT COUNT ON
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS ACTUALLY IN
SURPLUS WE COULD SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM TODAY IF WE HAD THE
WILL ANOTHER WILL IS TO LOOK AT
OUR BUDGET AND SAY HOW MANY
THINGS CAN WE CUT. HOW MANY
THINGS CAN WE CROSS OUT HOW
MANY THINGS CAN WE STREAMLINE.
BEFORE WE GO BACK TO THE
TAXPAYERS. AND ASK THEM TO PAY
MORE TAXES IN THIS CASE IT'S
NOT INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYERS. IT'S
ACTUALLY. CORPORATE TAX PAYERS.
AND I'VE SAID MANY TIMES IN
ORDER FOR US TO HAVE GOOD JOBS
WE HAVE TO HAVE EMPLOYERS WE
NEED EMPLOYERS AND THE
EMPLOYEES IN ORDER TO HAVE THAT
MIDDLE CLASS OPPORTUNITIES BUT
WHEN WE CONTINUE TO MOVE
TOWARDS ONE. ONE PART OF OUR
GOVERNMENT TO. FUND ANOTHER
PART WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN
AND WE HAVE SEEN THIS HAPPEN IS
A STEADY STREAM OF PEOPLE
LEAVING OUR STATE THE CENSUS
JUST RECENTLY CAME OUT
YESTERDAY SAYING THAT. LOS
ANGELES FOR THE FIRST TIME HAS
NOT GROWN. BUT THIS IS NOT THE
BURDEN OF BLAME MEAN WE HAVE
VERY LOW HOUSING PRODUCTION WE
KNOW LAST YEAR WE HAD MANY MANY
HOUSING BILLS THAT WENT. NOT
ONLY TO APPROPRIATIONS BUT EVEN
TO THE GOVERNOR THAT WERE NOT
SIGNED SO WE HAVE A PRODUCTION
ISSUE. WE HAVE A SHORTAGE OF
HOUSING WE HAVE MANY ISSUES IN
THIS BILL IS A BILL THAT I
THINK AS A BODY WE NEED TO MAKE
A PRIORITY AND REALLY MAP IT
OUT BEFORE I CAN SUPPORT IT.
THIS DOES NOT DISMISS THE
AUTHORS GOOD WORK I HAVE A HIGH
REGARD FOR HER YES MATTER FACT
TO MORE BILLS COMING RIGHT
AFTER THIS THAT I'M GOING TO BE
HAPPY TO SUPPORT. US AND IN NO
WAY DOES IT DIMINISH THE IDEA
THAT WE NEED TO STUDY FUNDING
STREAM BUT AGAIN WHERE DOES
THAT MONEY COME FROM. AND HOW
CAN WE LOOK IN. THE BUDGET WE
CURRENTLY HAVE WITHOUT LOOKING
OUTSIDE TO TAX MORE SO TODAY I
WON'T BE SUPPORTING THIS BUT I
WILL CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON THIS
ISSUE. ON A DAILY BASIS. THANK
YOU MISS CLARK SILVA- ANYBODY
ELSE WISH TO COMMENT MISTER
KILEY. I APOLOGIZE IF I MISSED
THIS IN THE TESTIMONY FROM
EITHER THE PRESENTER OR ANY OF
THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT BUT
WAS THERE ANY EVIDENCE CITED TO
A LINKING INSUFFICIENT FUNDING
WITH CALIFORNIA'S. HOMELESSNESS
SITUATION. I'M NOT SURE I
UNDERSTAND AS DEMAND OR STAY
THE COURSE YEAH WAS THERE ANY
EVIDENCE CITED THAT. LINKING A
LACK OF FUNDING- WITH THE FACT
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS A- YOU KNOW
A PRETTY SIZEABLE HOMELESSNESS
PROBLEM. I THINK THAT IF YOU
TALK TO ANY. INDIVIDUAL WHO
WORKS WITH OUR HOMELESS
COMMUNITY THEY WILL TELL YOU
THE LACK OF RESOURCES IS WHAT
HAS EXACERBATED THE SITUATION
ON OUR STREETS AGAIN I'M TRYING
TO ANSWER TRINITRON UNDERSTAND
YOUR YOUR QUESTION IS THERE ANY
EVIDENCE THAT YOU KNOW STATES
THAT SPEND MORE ON
HOMELESSNESS- THEN THAT OFFICER
DOING BETTER THAT SEEKS TO
DOING BETTER DOING SO BECAUSE
THEY'RE SPENDING MORE
HOMELESSNESS I'M JUST TRYING TO
SEE. WHERE PROPOSAL MONEY IS A
SOLUTION OR SEE IF THERE'S ANY
EVIDENCE TO SUGGEST THAT THAT'S
YOU KNOW THAT THAT'S THE
PROBLEM ISOMER ST YOU KNOW I
THINK I THINK PART OF THE
ANSWER IS IN RECENT YEARS
PARTICULARLY AFTER THE LAST
FOUR YEARS WE HAVE. SEEN
MASSIVE CUTS AT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WHEN IT COMES TO
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS OF
STATES HAVE HAD TO PICK UP THE
SLACK AND THE REALITY IS AND SO
MANY OF OUR JURISDICTIONS- WE-
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE
STRIVING MIGHTILY. TO ADDRESS
THE CRISIS- BUT FOR EXAMPLE LOS
ANGELES. EVERY DAY. THEY'RE
ABLE TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO HELP
HOUSE A HUNDRED THIRTY THREE
INDIVIDUALS. AND EVERY DAY A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY. INDIVIDUALS
BECOME HOMELESS. IN OAKLAND
THAT STATISTIC FOR EVERY ONE
PERSON THAT GETS HOUSED.
ANOTHER TO BECOME HOMELESS. IN
MY CITY FOR EVERY PERSON'S
HOUSE. ANOTHER THREE BECOME
HOMELESS SO. I KNOW THAT THERE
CERTAINLY PERSPECTIVE THAT WE
NEED TO DO A BETTER JOB WITH
THE MONEY THAT WE'RE SPENDING I
AGREE WE'VE GOT TO HAVE. REAL
ACCOUNTABILITY AND I THIS
MEASURE. ON HAS A VERY
SIGNIFICANT ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES AND IT IF YOU. ARE
ABLE TO. TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
AND HAVE TO GO THROUGH THAT OF
THAT'S OF HELP- BUT WE DO KNOW
THAT PART OF THE FUNDAMENTAL
PROBLEM IS WE- HAVE JUST HAVE
NOT HAD ENOUGH RESOURCES. AND
JUST IN THE LAST TWO YEARS
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO SPEND SOME
ONE TIME DOLLARS. BUT WE DON'T
HAVE ANYTHING THAT'S ONGOING
AND I DO THINK- TO RESPOND TO
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE
COUNTY. WE OUGHT TO USE A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THIS
YEAR'S- FEDERAL STIMULUS MONEY
TOWARD HOMELESSNESS BUT I THINK
ALSO A LONG TERM. SOLUTION AND
ONGOING REVENUE STREAMS
SOMETHING WE NEED AS WELL.
THANK YOU. OUR ANYBODY ELSE
MISSED CALL RHONDA JERRY
COMMENTS OKAY THEN I'LL CLOSE
WITH THE COMMENT PERIOD HERE- I
SHARE THE SAME CONCERNS THAT MR
SILVER AND MR WARD HAS AT HAVE
EXPRESSED WHICH IS WHEN YOU
DECIDE TO PUT ALL YOUR
FINANCIAL EGGS IN ONE BASKET TO
FUND SOMETHING- THAT BASKET HAS
THE POTENTIAL TO SHIFT AND- WE
GIVE AN INCENTIVE FOR THEM TO
NOT DO THE BUSINESS THAT THEY
WERE DOING HERE- BYE BYE BY
PUSHING HIM OUT WHICH TAKES OUT
JOBS IT CETERA. WHILE THE
CONTENTS OF THIS BILL ARE I
HAVE NO ISSUES WITH IT'S THE
FUNDING OF THE BILL THAT I HAVE
ISSUES WITH AND I DO THINK WE
NEED TO IF THIS IS THE PRIORITY
OF THE STATE AND WE HAVE A PLAN
THAT SAYS WHERE THOSE DOLLARS
HOW THOSE DOLLARS ARE GOING TO
BE SPENT AND IF IT'S- GOING TO
BE EFFECTIVE OR NOT. WHICH IS
HAS SOME ACCOUNTABILITY AND IT-
THEN WITHOUT YOU KNOW ABSENT
THAT- IT'S HARD TO SUPPORT SO
AT THAT- I WILL GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE. SO LET ME
FIRST JUST APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S CONSIDERATION I DO
KNOW- THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS ND LET
ME JUST SAY FEW THINGS TO.
ADDRESS WHAT I THINK OF BEEN
SOME MISCONCEPTIONS ON THIS SO
THIS BILL WE'RE PROPOSING A
CALIFORNIA SIMPLY CONFORMS WITH
FEDERAL TAX LAW- THIS GUILTY
TAX WOULD OFFSET THE IMPACT OF.
RECENT TAX CUTS BY THE LAST
ADMINISTRATION WHICH IT OFFERED
INCENTIVES FOR MULTINATIONAL
CORPORATIONS TO SHIFT PROFITS
OVERSEAS AND THEY'RE OPEN
TWENTY FOUR OTHER STATES THAT
HAVE ALREADY CONFORMED AND I'LL
JUST MENTION SOME OF THOSE
STATES. ALABAMA ARIZONA NORTH
DAKOTA IDAHO WEST VIRGINIA AND
OTHER STATES THAT WOULD
TYPICALLY BE CONSIDERED RED
STATES MORE CNSERVATIVE
STATES- AND I WILL ALSO
MENTION. THAT PART OF. A PART
OF THIS CORPORATE TAX PART OF
THIS TAX STRUCTURE- IT WOULDN'T
CREATE ANY COMPETITIVE
DISADVANTAGE FOR STATE BECAUSE
CORPORATIONS WOULD HAVE TO PAY
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY'RE
LOCATED SO THE IDEA THAT
SOMEHOW THIS IS DRIVING
CORPORATIONS OUT OF STATE IF
THEY IF THEY GO. THEY'RE GOING
TO EXPERIENCE THE SAME IMPACT-
I DO YOU KNOW APPRECIATE THE
PERSPECTIVE THAT MAYBE WE
SHOULD CONSIDER MORE BROAD
BASED TAX I WILL SAY- THERE WAS
ANOTHER COMPONENT WHEN AB
SEVENTY ONE WAS FIRST PROPOSED.
THAT WAS A MORE BROADLY BASED
TAX- IT WAS BROAD AND BECAUSE
IT WAS BROUGHT IT BROUGHT UP
OPPOSITION I AND THAT PIECE GOT
STRIPPED OUT IN THE RENDON TAX
COMMITTEE SO. I THINK THERE IS
A PERSPECTIVE- THAT AGAIN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE LARGEST
MULTINATIONAL CORPORATIONS-
THAT HAVE ENGAGED AND REALLY
FRANKLY A TAX AVOIDANCE
STRATEGY AND PART OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS JUST RECOUP OUR
FAIR SHARE AS A STATE- I'VE
ALREADY MENTIONED
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES AND I
KNOW. THERE WAS SET AT LEAST ON
THE OPPOSITION AND SOMEHOW THE
SUGGESTION THAT WE HAVE TO DO
MORE AS FAR AS PLANNING AROUND
HOMELESSNESS THERE'S ANOTHER
BILL THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
VOTING ON WHICH IS MY ABILITY
TO SIXTEEN. WHICH WOULD REQUIRE
THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ESTABLISH EXACTLY THAT PLAN AND
I THINK WE NEED TO DO. ALL
THESE THINGS AT THE SAME TIME
WOULD NEED TO BE LANDING WE
NEED A- AND WE NEED. A A
ONGOING SOURCE REVENUES IN OF
THIS FORD SO WITH THAT. A VERY
HOPE VERY MUCH HOPE THAT WE CAN
MOVE THIS FORWARD. WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE THIS CONVERSATION-
REGARDLESS OF WHAT HAPPENS WITH
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET THERE IS
GOING TO BE TREMENDOUS ONGOING
NEED. AND WE ARE EXPERIENCING
THE MOST INTENSE HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS IN OUR STATE'S HISTORY
BOTH BEFORE COVERED AND AFTER
COVERED THIS IS A MORAL CRISIS
TODAY AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. HI MR GABRIEL YOU CAME
IN LATE- DID YOU WANT TO
COMMENT ON THIS. RECORD YEAH
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR VICE CHAIR AND- APOLOGIES
IT'S COMPLICATED WITH OUR
HEARING SCHEDULED. AT THE SAME
TIME- WELL JUST BE BRIEF I WILL
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY I
AGREE VERY STRONGLY. THAT THIS
IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST MORE ON
PUBLIC POLICY CHALLENGES FACING
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT VEHICLE TO MOVE
BACK CONVERSATIONS FORWARD- I
DO AGREE WITH- WITH OUR CHAIR
ABOUT THE EXTRAORDINARY NEED
FOR ACCOUNTABILITY AROUND THIS-
I THINK THAT'S A THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY CENTRAL THEIR NUMBER
GOOD PROPOSALS MOVING THROUGH
THE LEGISLATURE. AROUND THAT.
WHAT WHAT I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT IN ADDITION TO RESOURCES I
THINK WE REALLY NEED TO THINK
ABOUT STRATEGY- AND HOW WE ARE
LOOKING AT THESE ISSUES- I. IN
MY COMMUNITY THERE'S JUST SUCH
EXTRAORDINARY FRUSTRATION ABOUT
THE LACK OF PROGRESS ON THIS
ISSUE- AND WHEN I TALK TO
PEOPLE IN MY COMMUNITY THEY
WILL SAY TO ME I HAVE VOTED
TWICE TO TAX MYSELF. IN LOS
ANGELES I VOTED FOR MEASURE H.
AT THE COUNTY LEVEL. VOTER HHH
AT THE CITY LEVEL. AND EVERY
TIME I LOOK OUTSIDE MY WINDOW
IT SEEMS LIKE THE PROBLEM IS
GETTING WORSE IT IS
HEARTBREAKING TO SEE WHAT IS
GOING ON. IN OUR COMMUNITY AND
SO. I'M LOOKING FORWARD IN IT
IN ADDITION TO IN ADDITION TO
THESE RESOURCES TO HAVING SOME
REALLY- REALLY ROBUST
CONVERSATIONS AROUND CHARGING
AND I THINK WE NEED TO HAVE
SOME SOME. SOME OF THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR FRIENDS
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT- ABOUT
WHAT THEY'RE DOING I REALLY-
BELIEVE VERY STRONGLY THAT WE
NEED THESE OF THOSE COUNTY
BUILDING MEASURE SO WE CAN DO
DATA DRIVEN POLICY MAKING. SORT
OF A SENSE OF WHAT
INTERVENTIONS ARE WORKING AND
WHICH ARE NOT- BUT I WOULD JUST
SAY. I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY BUT I'M REALLY
LOOKING FOR TO THIS COMMITTEE-
CONTINUING TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS BECAUSE THOUGH
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT THE
PEOPLE OF THE STATE ARE
DEMANDING OF US AND WE NEED TO
DO BETTER. THANK YOU MR GABRIEL
SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD WE HAVE A
SECOND. ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA.
SO. MADAM SECRETARY IF YOU
COULD CALL THE ROLL. MOTIONS TO
PAY. AS A MAN. TO THE- COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS TO. CHIU I'D SAY
ARE DON'T KNOW. YOU DON'T KNOW.
GABRIELLE GABRIEL I KALRA.
KALRA AYE. KILEY NO. KILEY
KNOW. WARD WART I. WORK SILVA.
WEEKS WICKS I. WANT TO CITY.
FOUR FIVE TWO TWO ZERO THE BILL
HAS FIVE VOTES- THE MEASURE
PASSES OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES. LET'S GO
TO MISTER BLOOM HAS BEEN VERY
PATIENTLY WAITING WE WILL GO TO
FILE ITEM TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY
FOURTEEN TWELFTH MISTER BOND.
WELL. GO ON- AB WORKING TRYING
TO. THIS IS ABOUT REMOVING
BARRIERS TO MULTI FAMILY. THEY
OR CALIFORNIA. BURKE. RIGHT
PLACE. EXISTING REFER REMAIN
LARGELY AND ACCESSIBLE TO LOW
INCOME PEOPLE AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR IT'S ALSO CRUCIAL TO
MEETING OUR CLIMATE GOALS BY
ENSURING THAT LOW WAGE WORKERS
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO LIVE
CLOSE TO WHERE THEY WORKS IS
SOMETHING WE TALK ABOUT ALL THE
TIME AND IF WE'RE SERIOUS ABOUT
ADDRESSING THE STATE'S HOUSING
NEEDS REVERSING ENTRENCHED
PATTERNS OF SEGREGATION AND
EXCLUSION AND REDUCING OUR
DEPENDENCE WE NEED TO INCREASE
DENSITY AND EXPAND INFILL
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
PARTICULARLY MIXED INCOME AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN HIGH
OPPORTUNITY AREAS IT'S EQUALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE PROTECT AND
INVEST IN SENSITIVE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE AT RISK OF
DISPLACEMENT WHETHER THE THREAT
IS FROM SKYROCKETING RENTS OR
FROM DISINVESTMENT.
DISPLACEMENT OF LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES WORSENS
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING CRISIS AND
ALSO FRUSTRATES EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE BY
DRIVING LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
TO AREAS WITH LESS TRANSIT
ACCESS AND LONGER COMMUTES.
EXISTING LAW REQUIRES THAT THE
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TAKE STEPS TO ADDRESS CHRONIC
CHRONIC DISINVESTMENT
INSENSITIVE COMMUNITIES AND
PROTECT AGAINST DISPLACEMENT.
AB FOURTEEN NINETY TWO WOULD
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT TO DEVELOP MAPS OF
BOTH HIGH OPPORTUNITY AREAS AND
SENSITIVE COMMUNITIES IN
COLLABORATION WITH STAKEHOLDERS
AND ACADEMIC EXPERTS. THESE
DATA BASED MAPS WILL AID IN
STATE AND LOCAL DECISION MAKING
AROUND LAND USE POLICIES AND
PUBLIC INVESTMENTS AND WILL
HELP ENSURE THAT BOTH THE
STATE. AND CITIES AND COUNTIES
HAVE CRITICAL INFORMATION. TO
ASSIST IN MEETING THEIR LEGAL
OBLIGATION TO AFFIRMATIVELY
FURTHER FAIR HOUSING. THE FACT
IS WE NEED TO BUILD A LOT MORE
HOUSING AND MAKE SURE THAT
EVERY JURISDICTION IS DOING ITS
FAIR SHARE TO PROVIDE A RANGE
OF HOUSING TYPES AT A RANGE OF
INCOME LEVELS. BUT WE ALSO NEED
TO DO THAT IN A WAY THAT
FURTHERS BOTH CLIMATE AND FAIR
HOUSING GOALS AS WELL. AB
FOURTEEN NINETY TWO WILL HELP
PROVIDE THE NEEDED TOOLS TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN. THANK YOU A
WITNESS- TODAY WE HAVE- IDEA
LAWLER- WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION AND MAYBE BRIAN A
GUSTO I'M NOT SURE. LET'S GO TO
THE OPERATOR IF YOU COULD SEE
IF ON A LAWLER OR BRIAN A
CUSTOMER ON THE LINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN GROUP ON
THE ALERT- HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION ONE OF
THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COVERED THE
DETAILS THE BILL WELL AND I
KNOW WE'RE SHORT ON TIME WILL
BE BRIEF THESE MAPS ARE NEEDED
RESTORE IT TO US AT THE STATE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN COMPLYING
WITH THEIR- OBLIGATION TO
AFFIRMATIVELY FURTHER FAIR
HOUSING AND TO INFORM DECISION
MAKING AS WE WORK TO ADDRESS
OUR HOUSING CRISIS IN AN
EQUITABLE MANNER AND- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
TO MOVE THIS IMPORTANT POLICY
FOR IT THANK. WITH THAT THERE
IS NO FOR OFFICE. SO LET'S OPEN
UP THE CONVERSATION WITH ANYONE
WHO WISHES TO STATE YOUR
OPPOSITION TO SUPPORT. THERE'S
NO ONE IN. THE COMMITTEE ROOM
IS OR ANYONE OF THE REMOTE
STATION. GOING OUT TO THE
OPERATOR IF YOU COULD
ACKNOWLEDGE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. AND LEGAL GERMAN IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO STATE SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT. THIS TIME WE DO HAVE
ONE IN THE QUEUE. WE'LL GO TO
NUMBER TWO FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH HER
NAME IS KATHERINE HEDGES I'M
CALLING FROM SAN JOSE AND
SUPPORT THE MEASURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. DID OF ONE MORE
QUEUE UP IT'LL JUST BE A MOMENT.
HELLO LINE TO THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CAN PICK UP THE ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ALONG
PROPERTY WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSOR THAT THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE AND URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO OTHERS IN
THE QUEUE. CONTINUE Q. R. LET
ME ASK THIRTY MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL NO ONE HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM KNOWN AT THE
REMOTE STATIONS BACK TO YOU ON
THE OPERATOR. NOW IF YOU'D LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. AT THIS
TIME THERE ARE NONE IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
APPRECIATE YOUR BILL THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF DISCUSSION ABOUT.
HOW WE- IDENTIFY HIGH
OPPORTUNITY AREAS AND SENSITIVE
COMMUNITIES AND WE HAVEN'T HAD
THE BENEFIT OF ANY. UNDERLYING
DEFINITIONS OR MAPS OF THIS
BILL I THINK WILL PROVIDE A
REALLY GOOD OPPORTUNITY FOR.
STATE AND LOCAL POLICYMAKERS TO
MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS WHICH
IS WHY I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT
ANY OTHER DISCUSSION FROM
COLLEAGUES IS OUR MOTION MOVE
FORWARD. MOTION IS OUR SECOND.
MR BERMAN FOUNDER COMMENTS
THANK YOU ALL I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE MADAM
SECRETARY. MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS TROOP. BY TWO
FIVE SAY ARE DON'T KNOW. FEAR
DON'T KNOW GABRIEL. GABRIEL I'D
KALRA. KALRA AYE KILEY. WARD
WARD I OKAY SILVA WICKS WICKS
BY. ONE FIFTY FIVE TO ONE YOUR
BILL IS OUT WE WILL ALLOW
OTHERS TO ADD ON THANK YOU
JERRY FLIGHT HOME- WITHOUT I
SEE MR GRAYSON'S HERE TO FINISH
UP HIS FINAL TWO BILLS FILE
ITEM ELEVEN AB. SIX OH TWO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
THE ASSEMBLY BILL SIX ZERO TWO.
I WOULD LIKE TO NOTE THAT I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. AB SECURE
TO ESTABLISH IS IMPORTANT NEW
STANDARDS FOR THE NEXUS STUDIES
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS PREPARE
WHEN IMPOSING DEVELOPMENT FEES
OR DEVELOPMENT IMPACT FEES. HIS
MOVE MOTION REQUIREMENTS THAT
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS FAVOR
EXISTING LEVELS OF SERVICE
CAPITAL OR PROVIDE A CAPITAL
FACILITIES PLAN FOR PROPOSED
EXPENDITURES. AND COMPLY WITH
THE PUBLIC NOTICE AND OPEN
MEETING REQUIREMENTS. HERE TO
SPEAK ABOUT SOME OF THE
RESEARCH BEHIND THIS BILL IS
DAVID GARCIA POLICY DIRECTOR OF
UC BERKELEY'S TURNER CENTER FOR
HOUSING INNOVATION WITH THE
MOTION SECOND HIS. COMMENTS
WILL BE BRIEF. LET'S GO TO. THE
LINE FOR HIS CHRISTMAS
TESTIMONY MR GRAYSON'S WITNESS.
OPERATOR. OPERATOR IF WE COULD
RECOGNIZE MISTER GARCIA FROM
THE TURNER CENTER OR-
POTENTIALLY LUIS MORA TODAY
FROM CALIFORNIA BE. I DO NOT
SHOW THAT- MR GARCIA HAS DIALED
IN. I THINK EVERYONE SAYS IT'S
FINE FOR US TO PROCEED. LET ME
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION WITNESS
ON ME SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM THAT WISHES
TO TESTIFY EITHER FOR OR
AGAINST SEE NON REMOTE LINES
FOR AGAINST. TO THE OPERATOR IF
YOU COULD OPEN UP THE LINES TO
SEE IF THERE ARE ANY. MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC THE WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. ABSOLUTELY I JUST
LIKE TO INFORM YOU MISTER
GARCIA HAS JOINED MR GARCIA
PLEASE TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU
APOLOGIES YOU'RE BEING A BIT
LATE HAVE A GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF MY
NAME IS DAVID GARCIA OF THE
POLICY DIRECTOR DETERRENCE AND
ACROSS THE INNOVATION I UC
BERKELEY AND I'M HERE TO LOOK
AT SOME OF OUR RECENT WORK.
FUNDED ON AN IMPACT FEES AND
HOW LEVY SIX OF TWO ALIGNS WITH
SOME OF OUR RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT SELL OVER THE PAST THREE
YEARS WE PUBLISH THREE UNIQUE
PIECES OF RESEARCH ON THIS
EXACT TOPIC WITH THE SUPPORT OF
THE STATE HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT AS A
PERSON ALL DAY THAT FEES. ARE A
VERY IMPORTANT SOURCE OF
REVENUE FOR CITIES LOOKING TO
MITIGATE THE REAL IMPACT THE
NEW HOUSING HAVE BUT AT THE
SAME TIME IT'S ALSO TRUE THAT
THESE ARE NOT ALWAYS CALCULATED
OR IMPOSED IN TRANSPARENT.
EQUAL MANNERS THE WEIGHT WHICH
MAY LEAD TO OVERLY BURDENSOME
P. AMOUNTS ON NEW HOMES WHICH
ULTIMATELY INCREASES THE PRICE.
FOR THAT NEW CALL INTO OUR
RESEARCH SUGGESTS THAT SIMPLE
CHANGES IN THE CALCULATION.
CONDITION OF IMPACT FEES CAN
MORE APPROPRIATELY ALIGN THE
CITY WITH THE ACTUAL IMPACTS OF
THE HOUSING WHILE ALSO LOWERING
DEVELOPMENT COSTS OVERALL SO
FOR EXAMPLE SHOOTING THREE PER
SQUARE FOOT CALCULATION FOR
CERTAIN FEES RATHER THAN A PER
UNIT BASIS. CAN IN SOME CASES
MORE ACCURATELY REFLECT YOU
IMPACTS AND RESULT IN MORE
REASONABLE COST SO THAT THIS
CHANGE ALSO CREATES A MORE
LEVEL PLAYING FIELD FOR
DEVELOPMENT OF SMALLER HOMES
WHICH CAN BE CHARGED
DISPROPORTIONATELY HIGH AMOUNT
HE'S IN JURISDICTIONS THAT.
JUST USE PRE APPLICATIONS- SO
AGAIN IMPACT THESE ARE REALLY
TECHNICAL COMPLEX ISSUE BUT
THEIR PROPER CALCULATION AND
ALLOCATION IS REALLY IMPORTANT
TO ENSURE THAT THESE ARE TRULY
REFLECTIVE OF NEW IMPACTS- THIS
BILL TAKES REASONABLE STEPS
TOWARDS BRINGING MORE
TRANSPARENCY IN THE BEST
PRACTICES. AND SO I WOULD URGE
TO SUPPORT TODAY AND WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HIS
CONTINUED. WORK ON THIS REALLY
IMPORTANT TOPIC THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE WERE GOING TO. THE
OPERATOR FOR ANYMORE OF THE
WISH TO SPEAK AND IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
SIX OH TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR
SUPPORT OF AB SIX OH TWO. AND
WE DO OF EIGHT IN OUR QUEUE.
WE'LL START WITH NUMBER FOUR
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEY
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS LUIS
MONTERO WITH CALIFORNIAN BE
HERE TO SUPPORT SB SIX AND TO
ATTACK WITH DOCTOR OF IT THANK
YOU. NEXT TO BE NUMBER ONE
FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON- MISTER CHAIR NUMBER
SOMETHING THAT IS NOT LIKE HOW
PUBLIC AFFAIRS CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE FAMILY TO GO
PLANNING AND URBAN RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION OFTEN AND IT'S
BURKE TMG PARTNERS SECOND
FEATURE COALITION EXAMPLE INTEL
BUILDERS IN SUPPORT AND HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA. THE
CROWD COSPONSORED THANK YOU.
NEXT IS NUMBER THREE THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HAPPENING
CHAIRED MEMBERS- TACKLING WITH
ALAMEDA FOR EVERYONE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ALGONA
NUMBER TWO EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS ADAM
BOOKBINDER CAN SIMPLY DISTRICT
TWENTY EIGHT REPRESENTING SOUTH
BAY IN BE IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX
OH TWO. NUMBER NUMBER THREE
FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON THIS IS TOMMY LEE
FROM WHAT THAT THE CALIFORNIA
I'M A RECENT COLLEGE GRAD AND
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT AT.
EIGHTY SIX THIRTY. NUMBER FOUR
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MICHAEL GETTING HERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
AND WISH TO THANK MR GRAYSON
FLORES TIRELESS LEADERSHIP ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE. I'M GONNA
NUMBER FOUR FORTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
THE PHILADELPHIA CLAIMS ON
BEHALF OF SILICON VALLEY AT
HOME ACTION FUNDS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NUMBER FOUR THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON- ADAM JET THANK ON
BEHALF OF THE HOUSING ACTION
COALITION IN SUPPORT. GO TO
NUMBER FOUR FORTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WHERE WOULD YOU THINK
EVERYONE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NUMBER FOUR FORTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HENRY FONG WITH
PEOPLE FOR HOUSING ORANGE
COUNTY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTY TWO THANK YOU SO MUCH. AT
THIS TIME THERE ARE NO OTHERS
IN OUR QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
LET ME ASK IF THERE ARE ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC- THE WISH
TO OPPOSE THIS BILL. TO THE
OPERATOR. AND NOW HERE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SIX OH TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN
ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION AB. SIX
OH TWO. I CURRENTLY HAVE THREE
IN THE QUEUE AND WE'LL START
WITH NUMBER TWO EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
UNDERESTIMATE AS ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF FREMONT IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION UNLESS
AMENDED I'VE LISTED IN OUR
WATER THANK YOU. WELL NOW GO TO
NUMBER ONE TWENTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON TRACY
RIGHT WITH THE WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTS THE CALIFORNIA
OFFICE ON BEHALF OF. THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
COUNTY FOR URBAN COUNTY
CALIFORNIA THE BIGGEST CITIES
IN AMERICAN SAYS HOW CHOI. WITH
OPPOSE THE LAST POSITION THANK
YOU. THIS IS NUMBER FOUR FORTY.
THE LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN ANTHONY CAN
WITH THE CALIBER. SPECIAL
ASSOCIATION OUT WE ARE STILL
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED BUT LOOKS
FORWARD TO WRAPPING THAT UP-
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
AUTHOR THANK YOU. AND THERE ARE
NO OTHERS IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE THANK AT THIS TIME-
WE'VE CONCLUDED. FEEDBACK ON
THE PUBLIC ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM OUR COLLEAGUES.
DREISER THANK YOU SO YOU KNOW
I'VE I'VE HAD A LOT OF
EXPERIENCE WITH THESE NEXUS
STUDIES AND BELIEVE ME PEOPLE
MOST OF THE- PEOPLE I SERVED
WITH THE IF PUBLIC OFFICIALS
ELECTED OFFICIALS THAT I'VE
SERVED WITH- A TRY TO
VEHEMENTLY- CONTROL HOW THESE
ARE BECAUSE IT DOES AFFECT HOW
YOU GROWTH IN THESE IN THIS
STUDY IS IF THEY'RE GOING TO DO
ONE SIZE FITS ALL HOW DO THEY
HOW DO THEY ACCOUNT FOR THE
DIFFERENCE AND LOCAL CONDITIONS
SUCH AS IF YOU WANT TO BUILD A
STRUCTURE UP IN PLACERVILLE UP
AND LAKE TAHOE FOR EXAMPLE.
VERSUS A STRUCTURE DOWN IN
ALHAMBRA- THE AVAILABILITY OF
WOOD IN ALL THESE OTHER IN A
AND A DISTANCE IT HAS TO BE
TRAVEL TO DO THAT RAISES THOSE
COSTS CONSIDERABLY IS DOES THIS
TYPE OF STUDY- ALLOW FOR THOSE
KIND OF DIFFERENCES OR DID THEY
JUST DECIDE WHAT IT SHOULD COST
GREAT QUESTION OF TO GIVE ME
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
CLARIFICATION SO THIS WOULD NOT
BE UP A ONE SIZE FITS ALL IT'S
ACTUALLY A TEMPLATE. TEMPLATE
FOR WHICH IN A JURISDICTION
COULD TAKE WITH THE BLANK LINES
AND CUSTOMIZE IT TO THEIR
ENVIRONMENT THEIR SETTING
WHETHER IT'S A BERMAN OR
WHETHER YOU'RE IN A RURAL
SETTING- THIS IS JUST A
TEMPLATE THAT IS NOT REQUIRED
IT'S ACTUALLY THERE AS A TOOL
IF THE. JURISDICTION SO CHOOSES
TO USE IT. CORRECT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- SO YOU I MY BIGGER
CONCERN- WITH THIS IS THAT- YOU
KNOW. A LOT OF A LOT OF THESE
NEXUS STUDIES I. D. PEOPLE WHO
OPPOSE THEM AND GENERALLY IT'S
ALWAYS YOU KNOW THE DEVELOPMENT
INDUSTRY OPPOSES THEM I DON'T I
DON'T BLAME THEM. IT RAISES THE
COST FOR DOING DEVELOPMENT
ACOSTA BUT IT THE END OF THE
DAY. WHAT THEY THINK IS GOING
TO HAPPEN IS THIS MASSIVE DROP
BECAUSE I THINK EVERYBODY HAS
INFLATED THOSE NEXT TO STUDY SO
MUCH. AND PUT THOSE IMPACT FEES
UP SUPER HIGH BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S LIKE DONE LIKE AND ****
NILLY PROCESS IT'S A VERY LONG
PROCESS IT TAKES UP TO YEARS-
TO DO THOSE. AND I DON'T THINK
THEY'RE GOING TO SEE THE DROP
THAT THEY THEY'RE HOPING TO
SEE. AND TAKING AWAY THE LOCAL
VERY LOCAL CONTROL- IT IS A
CONCERN BUT I KNOW IT IT'S
OFFSET A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT SO. THOSE
ARE MY COMMENTS THANK YOU THANK
YOU. IT'S PAST YOUR THIRTY ANY
RESPONSE TO THAT YES AND AGAIN
IT'S NOT A MANDATE THIS IS A
TEMPLATE THAT IS PROVIDED AS A
CHOICE. AND THE FACT IS. WE
HOPE THERE IS A BACKDROP
BECAUSE THERE ARE GOOD PLAYERS
GOOD ACTORS OUT THERE CITIES
MUNICIPALITIES SPECIAL
DISTRICTS. ALL OF THEM ARE IN
LINE HOWEVER- AS IDEAL AS THAT
MAY BE WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
GOOD ACTORS AND THAT THERE ARE
SOME JURISDICTIONS THAT CHARGE
IMPACT FEES. AS HIGH AS 17% OF
THE COST OF THE UNIT SO THIS IS
TO ADDRESS THOSE THAT MAY NOT
QUITE BE IN LIFE HI I
UNDERSTAND THAT AND- YOU KNOW I
RESPECT THAT ALSO THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH. SOME OF ANY
OF THE FINAL COMMENTS. I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
MOVING THIS FORWARD I KNOW THIS
IS BEEN A NUMBER OF YEARS OF
WORK THAT YOU'VE BEEN DOING
YOUR FRIEND REALLY LEADING THE
SPACE AND HOW TO ENSURE THAT
THERE IS. RATIONALITY IN THE
IMPACT FEE DISCUSSION YOU KNOW
I THINK THE FACT OF THE MATTER
IS- THIS. WE HAVE SEEN
JURISDICTIONS SORT OF ALL OVER
THE MAP IT'S BEEN A VERY OPAQUE
AND TRANSPARENT AND- INFORMAL
INCONSISTENT PATCHWORK OF
GUIDELINES AND PRACTICES IN
PART WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO.
IS REALLY RATIONALIZE THE
PROCESS WE'RE GIVING LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ABILITY TO
CONTINUE TO DO IT WE'RE JUST
SAYING WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
THERE THAT THAT IT'S FACT
BASED. IN ITS IT'S- IT'S BASED
ON ON WHAT'S ACTUALLY HAPPENING
SO I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS
AND- ALSO HAVE A CO AUTHORED IF
THAT'S SOMETHING YOU'D LIKE.
AND WITHOUT A LESSER ANY FINAL
COMMENTS YOU ANY FINAL WORDS.
YES AND YES THAT WOULD BE
WONDERFUL TO HAVE A COOPER I.
JUST FOR THE FACT THAT THE
COMMITTEE WOULD KNOW. THIS
STARTED SEVERAL YEARS AGO WITH
THE STATE WIDE TOUR AFTER-
STUDY THAT WAS DONE BY TURNER
CENTER. AND IT CULMINATED INTO
A WORKING GROUP. FOR THIS PAST
YEAR. THAT HAS MAPPED A
STAKEHOLDERS ACROSS THE BOARD
AND STATEWIDE. INCLUDING
SPECIAL DISTRICTS COUNTIES
BIGGEST CITIES AND DEVELOPERS
SO. WE'RE STILL IN THAT WORKING
GROUP SO OFTEN MEETINGS. AND AS
IT WAS STATED WE WILL GET TO-
SOME GOOD PLACES. WITHOUT MADAM
SECRETARY DID SOME OF THE
COMMOTION. OKAY THIS PROMOTION
AND A SECOND. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ASIANS CHIU HI SHOOT FIVE
THEY ARE TOTAL VOTING. TO
GABRIELLE GABRIEL I KALRA KALRA
AYE KILEY AYE KILEY AYE WARD BY
WARD I WOKE SILVA KIRK SILVA I
WEEKS. WEEKS BY. I WILL BE
SEVENTY ZERO SAN YOUR BILL
PASSES LET'S GO TO YOUR THIRD
BILL FILE ITEM TWELVE AB SEVEN
FIVE THREE. I AM PLEASED TO
PRESERVE EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTY
THREE WHICH EXTENDS THE SUNSET
OF THE UNDERGROUND STORAGE TANK
CLEANUP FUNDING CREATES A
STAKEHOLDER TASK FORCE THAT
WILL STUDY PRIORITIZING USING.
OR THE USE OF THE FUNDS FOR
BROWNFIELD REMEDIATION FOR
HOUSING. IT THAT IS NOT TO
CREATE A NEW TAXES OR FEES IT
MERELY EXTENDS THE SUNSET OF
THIS INCREDIBLE RESOURCE. AS
STUDIES A PATHWAY TOWARD
REMEDIATING BROWNFIELD SITES IT
JOB IN TRANSIT RICH AREAS. SO
THE BOND REIMBURSES UNDERGROUND
STORAGE TANK OWNERS FOR COST OF
CLEANING UP FUEL LEAKS IT ALSO
FUNDS PROJECTS THAT CLEAN UP
ENVIRONMENTAL CONTAMINATION
FROM A VARIETY OF SOURCES.
INCLUDING ON BROWNFIELD
PROPERTIES. SO IT MERELY
EXTENDS AGAIN THE SUNSET OF THE
PHONE CREATES A STAKE TASK
FORCE. AND IT SUPPORTS THE
STATE'S GOALS OF REDUCING
CARBON EMISSIONS AND BUILDING
URBAN HOUSING. MY WITNESS IS
BROWNVILLE PRACTITIONER MARCUS
ME BACK. TO THE OPERATOR IF.
YOU COULD RECOGNIZE MISTER
MARCUS ME BACK. THANK YOU THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. MY NAME
IS MARK IS THE BANK I'VE BEEN
AN ENVIRONMENTAL CONSULTANT AND
BROWNFIELD PRACTITIONER. IN
CALIFORNIA SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY. UNDERGROUND STORAGE
TANK CLEANUP FUND FACILITATED
ENVIRONMENTAL RESTORATION AND
PROTECTION OF HUMAN HEALTH IT
LITERALLY TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIA SITES. AFFECTED
LARGELY BY RELEASES OF
PETROLEUM PRODUCTS FROM
UNDERGROUND TANKS. EXAMINATION
OF POSSIBILITIES FOR PROGRAM
EXPANSION TO SERVEA BROADER
UNIVERSE. OF NON PETROLEUM
BROWNFIELD SITES COULD NOT COME
AT A BETTER TIME. THE NEED FOR
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT IN
CALIFORNIA IS CLEAR AND THE
NEED FOR WORK FORCE HOUSING AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN URBAN
COMMUNITIES. IS PERHAPS GREATER
TODAY THAN EVER BEFORE. THE
MANY POTENTIAL OPPORTUNITY
PROPERTIES IN URBAN AREAS ARE
CONSIDERED BROWNFIELD SITES
PLANNED BUT BECAUSE THIS STORE
QUEUES IS PERCEIVED TO POSSESS
A VIRAL ATTRIBUTES THAT MAKE
REDEVELOPMENT FOR HOUSING
IMPOSSIBLE. IN REALITY MANY OF
THE STATE'S POSSESSED
MANAGEABLE ENVIRONMENTAL
COMPLICATIONS. AND BUT FOR A
RESOURCE TO ASSESS AND
REMEDIATE A PAST
OVERDEVELOPMENT AND LEAN
ABANDONED FOR DECADES. AN
EXAMINATION OF THE CLEAN UP
FUNDS ABILITY TO BE APPLIED TO
THE REHABILITATION. OF THE
HOUSING APPROPRIATE SITES AS
WELL AS ITS POSSIBLE
APPLICATION OTHER
ENVIRONMENTALLY DAMAGED LAND
FOR OTHER OBJECTIVES IS WELL
TIMED AND CRITICALLY NEEDED.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATOR.
THANK YOU THERE IS NO ORMAL
OPPOSITION WITNESS- LET'S SEE
IF THEY'RE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THE WISH TO SPEAK FOR
AGAINST THIS. ANY MEMBERS OF
PUBLIC HERE IN THE CHAMBER. ANY
MEMBERS PUBLIC ON. AT A REMOTE
STATE. ON THE LINES LET'S START
WITH ANY MEMBERS THE PUBLIC THE
WISH TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HANDLING JIM IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT- PLEASE
PRESS. ONE ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO
FOUR SUPPORT. AND WE DO HAVE
ONE IN OUR QUEUE. WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWO FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LOOKS LIKE THEY REMOVED
THEMSELVES FROM THE QUEUE- AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO OTHERS IN
LINE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND
ANYONE. IN LINE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. ENACTED LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO
PROPOSITION. WE HAVE NONE IN
OUR QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE THANK
YOU BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. THE SORT OF EMOTION
AND THE SECOND ANY FINAL
COMMENTS. JUST APPRECIATE YOU
BRING THIS BEFORE I'LL SAY I
THINK MY STAFF AND I LEARN MORE
ABOUT UNDERGROUND STORAGE TANKS
THAN. WE HAD WANTED TO KNOW BUT
I'M GLAD WE DO KNOW THAT AND I
THINK WE ALL APPRECIATE YOU
DEAR PRIORITIZING BROWNFIELD
REMEDIATION PARTICULARLY WANTED
SPORTS INFILL HOUSING SO HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THIS MOVING FORWARD.
ANY FINAL COMMENTS. THIS BILL
IS A JOINT BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CLOSE
CONSIDERATION AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN IPHONE MADAM
SECRETARY. MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS TWO FIVE TWO
FIVE THEY ARE SO NOT. THEY ARE
THE NO GABRIELLE. GABRIEL I'D
KALRA. KALRA AYE KILEY NO KILEY
NOEL WARD. WARD I CORK SILVA.
THANKS TO BYE WEEKS. WEEKS I
SIXTY TWO. YOUR PASSES. THANK
YOU SO MUCH SO COLLEAGUES WE'RE
GOING TO THE TOP OF THE ORDER-
AND GOING TO GO. MOVING TO FILE
ITEM TO AB TEN FORTY THREE AND
I'LL JUST MENTION- MISTER KALRA
WILL PRESENT ITEMS TWO AND
THREE THEN WILL GO TO THIS
QUICK SERVICE ITEMS. THAT
MISTER WARD WILL PRESENT MS
GONZALEZ IS ITEM AS WELL AS
SOME OF HIS OWN. AND THEN WE
WILL PROCEED FROM THERE SO FILE
ITEM TO AB TEN FORTY THREE
THREE OF US PRESENTED BY MISTER
CAR. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
BIRDS ON THE HAVE A SETTLEMENT
THREE OF US OR LIKE TO START
BY. THANKING THE CHAIRS
COMMITTEE STUFF WITH A THOROUGH
EVALUATION I WANT TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
AS AMENDED AT TEN FORTY THREE
WILL ADD AN ADDITIONAL INCOME
CATEGORY THE STATE HOUSING LAW
COMPRISED OF INDIVIDUALS LIVING
BELOW THE FIFTEEN PERCENT. OF
THE AREA MEDIAN INCOME. STATE
HOUSING PROGRAMS ALLOW THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE TO
DEFINE INCOME CATEGORIES
PROVIDE FORMULAS FOR
CALCULATING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
COSTS. CURRENT LAW DEFINES FOUR
INCOME CATEGORIES WITH THE
LOWEST CATEGORY COMPRISED OF
HOUSEHOLDS LIVING BELOW THE 30%
OF THE AREA MEDIAN INCOME.
HOWEVER THERE'S GREAT DISPARITY
BETWEEN HOUSEHOLDS GROUPED
TOGETHER INTO INTO THIS
CATEGORY. FOR EXAMPLE IN TWENTY
TWENTY THE ANNUAL INCOME FOR A
HOUSEHOLD OF FOUR. IN THIS
CATEGORY WAS THIRTY THREE
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED. HOWEVER
HOUSEHOLDS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS OF THOSE WERE ON
THE BRINK OF HOMELESSNESS.
REPORTED INCOMES OF LESS THAN
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS. A
RECENT REPORT FROM L. A.
COUNTY. WHICH INCLUDED AN
ADDITIONAL CATEGORY TO CAPTURE
THEIR MOST LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS. INDICATED THAT ABOUT
10% AND 10% OF L. A. COUNTY
RENTERS LIVE BELOW THE 15% OF
THE AREA MEDIAN INCOME. THAT IS
HOUSEHOLDS ALMOST 90% 9090%
SPENT MORE. THAN 50% OF THEIR
INCOME ON HOUSING COSTS. AB TEN
FORTY THREE ADDRESSES THIS GAP
IN OUR STATE HOUSING POLICY. BY
ESTABLISHING A PERSONS AT RISK
OF HOMELESSNESS CATEGORY. AND A
FORMULA TO CALCULATE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING COSTS FOR THIS GROUP.
THIS NEW CATEGORY WOULD BE MAKE
IT MADE UP OF INDIVIDUALS
LIVING BELOW THE 15% OF THE
AREA MEDIAN INCOME. AB TEN
FORTY THREE IS SPONSORED BY L.
A. COUNTY THAT THE PROVIDE
TESTIMONY I WOULD LIKE TO TURN
OVER. TO AMY BOWE DIRECTOR
RECTOR OF THE LOS ANGELES
DEPARTMENT OF REGIONAL PLANNING.
TO THE OPERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE ALARMIST BOTHA TO SPEAK.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK THIS
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS AMY ABOUT
IRAQ AND I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
REGIONAL PLANNING FOR THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES. I AM
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. THANK YOU ALSO TO
ASSEMBLY WOMAN RIVAS FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON THIS IMPORTANT
TOPIC IN HER CHAIR CHU AND THE
CONSULTANT FOR WORKING WITH US
ON THIS BILL. AB TEN FORTY
THREE WHAT AMEND THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE TO DEFINE A NEW
INCOME CATEGORIES FOR
CALCULATING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
COSTS. AS DISCUSSED THIS NEW
DEFINITION WOULD BE COMPRISED
OF FAMILIES LIVING WITHIN THE
00215% OF THE AREA MEDIAN
INCOME BRACKET. CURRENTLY THERE
IS NO FORMULA IN THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE TO CALCULATE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING COSTS FOR
HOUSEHOLDS OF LESS THAN 30% AND
MINE SH THIS PROPOSED NEW
INCOME CATEGORY. BETTER
CAPTURES THOSE RESIDENTS WHOSE
SOLE SOURCE OF INCOME AND
SUPPLEMENTAL SECURITY INCOME
SUCH AS THE ELDERLY OR THE
DISABLED. AS WAS NOTED SINCE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE COUNTY HAS
ISSUED AN ANNUAL AFFORDABLE
HOUSING OUTREACH REPORT
PREPARED BY THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP CORP
CORPORATION. OF THE MOST RECENT
REPORT FROM TWENTY NINETEEN
ACTUALLY SHOWS EVEN WORSE
NUMBERS THAN THOSE JUST QUOTED
THAT'S MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY NINE THOUSAND AS
OPPOSED TO ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY ONE THOUSAND. OF
PRINTERS ARE NOW WITHIN THAT
15% AND MY CATEGORY. MORE
DISTURBINGLY OF THESE
HOUSEHOLDS 69% IDENTIFY AS
PEOPLE OF COLOR. INCLUDING 136%
BLACK MAX 17% BLACK AND 16% API.
AMENDING THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
CODE WOULD ALLOW THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS OR THE STATE. TO
REQUIRE SATISFIED UNITS BE
PROVIDED AT THIS VERY SPECIFIC
INCOME LEVEL OR REQUIRE
REPLACEMENT UNITS BE MADE
AVAILABLE. IT IS A SIMPLE
AMENDMENT THAT WOULD HAVE FAR
REACHING POSITIVE BENEFITS IN
STABILIZING HOUSING OPTIONS FOR
IN SHORT THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES SUPPORTS THIS BILL AND
ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT AS WELL
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND I YIELD THE
REMAINDER OF MY TIME. IF WE CAN
NOW GO TO ANY WITNESSES. IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM PLEASE MARCH
DIVERSE OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU LET'S GO TO THE
REMOTE STATIONS ANY WITNESSES
OF WHICH TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OR
IN OPPOSITION. LET'S GO NOW TO
THE OPERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
WISH TO REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT
AGAIN NAME. ORGANIZATION AND
THE FACT THAT THEY SUPPORT.
HANLEY'S NUMBER IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
AT TEN FORTY THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT. WE DO HAVE FOR IN OUR
QUEUE. WE'LL START WITH NUMBER
THREE EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DEFERENCE ON BEHALF OF
HELPING CALIFORNIANS FROM
SUPPORT OF AB TEN FORTY THREE
THANK YOU. NEXUS NUMBER FOUR
FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD- GOOD
AFTERNOON SHERRIN REPORT WITH
THE CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN
FORTY THREE THANK YOU. TEXAS
NUMBER TWO THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. INDICUS THE ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
NUMBER THE NUMBER TO FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO FIFTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE- FROM
TECH EQUITY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE THANK YOU LET ME NOW
ASK YOU TO OPEN UP THE LINES
FOR ANYONE WHO MIGHT OPPOSE AB
TEN FORTY THREE. AND NOW IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION TO AB TEN
FORTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. I GOT ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION AB TEN FORTY THREE.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE NOBODY IN OUR
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
I THINK THERE WAS SPENT OF
SECRETARY WAS HER A MOTION AND
A SECOND. OKAY AS I WOULD SAY
TO THE AUTHOR APPRECIATE HER
GAUGE IN ON THIS AND ALSO WANT
TO THANK. OUR SPONSOR FOR GREEN
TO- REALLY CLARIFY THE
TERMINOLOGY IN THIS BILL TO
ACCURATELY DESCRIBE WERE
TALKING. ABOUT SINCE WERE
SETTING PRECEDENT WITH THIS NEW
CATEGORY OF INCOME I THINK WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT- THAT
IT'S CLEAR- BUT WITH THAT HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL ANY FINAL
COMMENTS. SPECT S. RIVAL MADAM
SECRETARY. MOTION NEEDS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMEDIAN APPROPRIATIONS TRUE HI
TWO I SAY I DON'T KNOW. IF THEY
ARE NO GABRIELLE. KALRA I.
KALRA AYE. KILEY NO KILEY NO.
WORD FOR DIET COKE SILVA. KIRK
SILVA I WICKS. CITY FORTY TWO
SIR. ALL RIGHT WE'LL WAIT FOR
OTHERS TO ANALYSTS MOVED FILE
ITEM THREE AB TWELVE TWENTY.
THANK YOU MR AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY WOMAN THREE OF US I
WOULD LIKE TO START BOB I THINK
YOU MISTER CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE
THOROUGH EVALUATION OF THIS
LEGISLATION FOR CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS. THE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN LOOKS FORWARD TO WORKING
OUT THE LANGUAGE OF
STAKEHOLDERS AND APPROPRIATIONS
ON HER BEHALF I'LL BE ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AS
CHARACTERIZE ON PAGE FIVE OF
THE NELSON'S. LAST SESSION
ISRAEL RIVAS AUTHORED AB
EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE WHICH IS AN
ATTEMPT TO DEVELOP A
COMPREHENSIVE POLICY SOLUTION
FOR THE ISSUE OF HOMELESSNESS.
AB TWELVE TWENTY IN THE FOM
BEFORE YOU TODAY AS A RESULT OF
ONGOING CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT
RESTRUCTURING CHANGES. SO WE
CAN ENSURE WE'RE PROVIDING
GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY AND
OVERSIGHT TO HOW THE STATE IS
COMBATING HOMELESSNESS. AS
AMENDED AB TWELVE TWENTY MAKES
A NUMBER OF STRUCTURAL CHANGES
TO THE CURRENT HOMELESS
COORDINATING AND FINANCING
COUNCIL. THIS MEASURE RENAMES
THE HOMELESS COUNCIL TO THE
CALIFORNIA INTERAGENCY COUNCIL
ON HOMELESSNESS. HIS NAME MORE
ACCURATELY REPRESENTS THE
PURPOSE OF THE COUNCIL. ALMOST
AT THE STAGE FOR THE
RESTRUCTURING OF THE COUNCIL
MEMBERSHIP AND COMMITTEES. THE
COUNCIL IS TASKED WITH VARIOUS
GOALS AND AMONG THEM ARE
IDENTIFYING RESOURCE TO PREVENT
HOMELESSNESS CREATING
PARTNERSHIPS AMONG STATE
AGENCIES. PROMOTING SYSTEM
INTEGRATIONS TO INCREASE
EFFICIENCY. MAKING POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND OTHERS.
MEMBERSHIP WILL CONSIST OF
DIRECTORS AND SECRETARIES OF
THE STATE INDIVIDUALS WITH
LIVED HOMELESSNESS EXPERIENCE
INCLUDING UNACCOMPANIED YOUTH
UNDER TWENTY FIVE YEARS OF AGE.
IN MARCH THE HOMELESS COUNCIL
ADOPTED ITS FIRST EVER ACTION
PLAN FOR PREVENTING AND ENDING
HOMELESSNESS IN THE STATE THE
ACTION PLAN PROVIDES THE
DETAILS ON HOW THE HOMELESS
COUNCIL CHIEF ITS GOALS.
ADDRESSING A PROBLEM AS COMPLEX
AND INTERCONNECTED AS HOMELESS
AS NOT ONLY REQUIRES THE
INVOLVEMENT OF DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES ACROSS THE STATE. BUT
WE MUST ALSO ENSURE THE
COUNCILS COMPRISE A STATE
LEADERS AND EXPERIENCED
INDIVIDUALS WERE COMMITTED TO
IMPLEMENTING THE ACTION PLAN
AND REDUCING HOMELESSNESS. THIS
ACTUAL PLAN COMES AT A CRITICAL
TIME AS THE BIDEN HERE'S
MINISTRATIONS BEGAN TO FOCUS ON
THE ISSUE OF HOMELESSNESS AS
WELL. AS SUCH THE STATE MUST
ENSURE PROPER AND EFFICIENT
COORDINATION AMONG STATE
AGENCIES DEPARTMENTS AND OTHER
RELEVANT STAKEHOLDERS OTHER
STATES IN THE COUNTRY HAVE
SIMILAR COUNCIL STRUCTURES SO
THIS IS A STANDARD MODEL. WE
KNOW THE THAT HOMELESSNESS IS A
STATE WIDE CRISIS THIS
LEGISLATION THAT LEGISLATURE
AND SPECIFICALLY THIS COMMITTEE
HAS DEDICATED SUBSTANTIAL
ENERGY AND RESOURCES TO COMBAT
HOMELESSNESS. WELL STATE
FUNDING PLAYS A CRITICAL ROLE
IN THE FIGHT AGAINST
HOMELESSNESS FUNDING ALONE WILL
NOT SOLVE SYSTEMIC ISSUES WE
MUST ENSURE THE COUNCILIS
COMPRISED OF STATE LEADERS AND
DEPARTMENT HEADS WHO ARE BEST
EQUIPPED TO EFFECTIVELY
COORDINATE AND RESPOND TO
HOMELESSNESS. I HAVE WITH ME
TODAY- CHRIS MARTIN POLICY.
DIRECTOR FOR HOUSING CALIFORNIA.
IT'S GONNA TO MR. I'M ASSUMING
HE'S ON THE PHONE LINE. TO THE
OPERATOR. FIRST GOOD EVENING
CHAIRED A MEMBER- COULD START A
POLICY DIRECTOR TALKING
CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA THE
NONPROFIT ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
WITH A MISSION TO ENSURE THAT
EVERYONE IN CALIFORNIA HAS
ACCESS TO A STATE SAVE ON THE
PORTAL PLACE TO LIVE SINCE ITS
INCEPTION IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SIXTEEN HOMES COORDINATING AND
FINANCING COUNCIL HAS BEEN
TASKED WITH MANY THINGS MOST
NOTABLY COORDINATING THE
STATE'S RESPONSE TO
HOMELESSNESS WHILE ALSO
ADMINISTERING OVER A BILLION
DOLLARS RESOURCES INTO.
RECENTLY THE COORDINATING
COUNCIL ADOPTED ITS FIRST EVER
ACTION PLAN FOR PREVENTING AND
ENDING HOMELESSNESS AND ALSO
LAUNCHED IN THE HOME WITH DATA
INTEGRATION SYSTEM WHICH WILL
ENABLE THE STATE LOCAL PARTNERS
TO MAKE MORE INFORMED DECISIONS
FOR IMPROVING PROGRAMS
FOSTERING COLLABORATIONS AND
ADDRESSING INEQUALITY IN A
RESEARCH REPORT THE L. A. I
THINK A PROBLEM AS COMPLEX AND
INTERCONNECTED OF HOMELESSNESS
REQUIRED THE INVOLVEMENT OF
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES ACROSS
THE STATE AND COLLABORATION
AMONG ALL LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS. WE KNOW
THAT STRUCTURAL CHANGES ARE
NECESSARY FOR THE STATE TO
BETTER ATTRACT THE NEEDS OF
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AB TWELVE TWENTY
MAKES CHANGES TO THE HOME
ACCORDING TO FINANCING COUNCIL
BY RENAMING IT THE CALIFORNIA
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS AND CHANGING THE
MEMBERSHIP OF THE COUNCIL TO BE
THE SECRETARIES AND DIRECTORS
OF AGENCY FEES REASONABLE
CHANGES ARE LINED WITH THOUGH
THE WAY MANY OTHER STATES HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY APPROACHED
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL THE SWELL
OF THE FEDERAL INTERAGENCY
COUNCIL AND WILL HELP THE HOME
ACCORDING TO FIND A COUNCIL
BETTER COORDINATE AMONG
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS SHOULD
SHOULD THE STATE GOAL OF ENDING
HOMELESSNESS. FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PLAZA FAMILY WOMAN
THREE OF US FOR HER LEADERSHIP-ON THE ISSUE AND URGES HER AYE.
VOTE ON THE TOP TWENTY THANK
YOU. WITH THAT LET'S NOW GO TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THE WISH
TO SPEAK AND SUPPORT OPPOSITION.
C. KNOWN HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM. BUT ASK IF THERE'S ANYONE
IN THE REMOTE STATION. AND
ASSUMING THERE'S NOT LET ME ASK
THE OPERATOR TO ALLOW ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS ITEM TO
REGISTER THAT SUPPORT. UNLADEN
JOHN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE TWENTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN
ONE ZERO FOUR SUPPORT. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE SIX IN Q. IT
WILL BEGIN WITH NUMBER THREE
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CHECK ONE ORIGINALLY HAPPENED
HELPING CALIFORNIANS FROM
SUPPORT AND EIGHTY TWELVE
TWENTY THANK YOU. NEXT TO BE
NUMBER FOUR FORTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CHEN REPORT WITH THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING IN SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE
TWENTY THANK YOU. NUMBER FOUR
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING OUR MEMBERS WAS
PART THEY WOULD CALIFORNIA BE
HERE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. NOT
GONNA NUMBER TWO FIFTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO FIFTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MOVE
THE NUMBER TO FIFTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
KATHERINE HEDGES I'M CALLING
FROM TECH EQUITY. IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANKS IS NUMBER THREE THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND ASSEMBLY- THAT
BILLING- REPRESENTING MYSELF ON
THAT IN TRANSPORT THANK YOU.
I'M NOT GOING TO NUMBER FOUR
FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING L. KEPT THERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIPS AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IN SUPPORT. NOT GONNA
NUMBER FOUR FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MAYOR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS RACHAEL K.
YANG L. FROM BLAENAU INSTRUCTOR
FOR THE BILL THANK YOU.
CURRENTLY OF NO OTHERS IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK
YOU NOW IF YOU COULD OPEN UP
THE LINES FOR ANYONE IN
POTENTIAL OPPOSITION. AND
MILLION GERMANS YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWELVE TWENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. YEAH ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. WE CURRENTLY HAVE
NONE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE LET'S BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY DISCUSSION.
COULD I MOTION MOVE FORWARD.
MOTION AND A SECOND BUT MR
WARDEN IS QUICK SILVA ANY FINAL
COMMENTS BUT FAST RATHER. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS TROOP. HI Q. I
SAY ARE TOO HIGH C. R. NO I'D
GABRIEL. CHOLERA KALRA AYE
KILEY KILEY I WORK. FOR TI
QUICK SILVA. THANKS I WEEKS.
FOUR FORTY TWO ZERO THAT ITEMS
HIS OUT. LET'S GO TO FILE ITEMS
FOR FIVE MISS CORRECT SILVA ARE
YOU READY TO PRESENT. OH I'M
SORRY I JUST SIR I SEE MISS
FRIEDMAN HERE LIKE TO GIVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT FOR BILL.
FOR CALLING UP FILE ITEM TWENTY
TWO AB FORTINO ONE. MISS
FRIEDMAN THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN%
MEMBERS YOU KNOW HOUSING IS A
TOUGH SUBJECT AND THERE'S OFTEN
A LOT OF DISAGREEMENTS ABOUT
THINGS BUT I HAVE TO SAY THAT
WHEN YOU HAVE A BILL THAT'S
BEING SUPPORTED BY THAT YOUR
CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE'S IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY AND IT
GETS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I THINK
WE MAYBE HAVE A SWEET SPOT-
THIS BILL IS ALLOWING
DEVELOPERS TO TAKE A MORE
MARKET- DRIVEN APPROACH. TO THE
WAY THAT HOUSING IS PUT
TOGETHER A MANY CITIES PROP
ALMOST ALL CITIES IN CALIFORNIA
REQUIRED NEW RESIDENTIAL OR
COMMERCIAL DEVELOPMENT TO
PROVIDE ON SITE PARKING SPACES
IN THE AMOUNT OF THE REPAIRS IS
PRETTY ARBITRARY AND IT VARIES
ACROSS THE STATE APARTMENTS
OFTEN INCLUDE ONE OR TWO
PARKING SPACES PER UNIT AND
COMMERCIAL PROPERTIES MUST
PROVIDE ONE SPACE FOR EVERYONE
TO TWO HUNDRED SQUARE FEET.
FREQUENTLY CAUSING MORE SPACE
BE PROVIDED FOR PARKING AND FOR
THE BUSINESS ITSELF AND THIS IS
A FACTOID THAT I PICKED UP THAT
I THINK IS REALLY SHOCKING
ACROSS THE COUNTRY WE DEVOTE
APPROXIMATELY ONE THOUSAND
SQUARE FEET OF SPACE- OF SPACE
FOR EVERY CAR THAT'S IN
EXISTENCE BUT ONLY EIGHT
HUNDRED SQUARE FEET OF HOUSING
FOR EVERY PERSON THAT LIVES IN
THE UNITED STATES. SO IT SHOWS
THAT OUR PRIORITIES IN MY MIND-
BOOK IF YOU CONFUSED BUT THESE
ONE SIZE FITS ALL MANDATES THAT
CITIES PUT ON DEVELOPERS ARE
OFTEN DOESN'T REALLY GIVE YOU A
VERY GOOD RESULT- MANDATORY
PARKING REQUIREMENTS HAVE LED
TO AN OVERSUPPLY PARKING. LOS
ANGELES COUNTY ALONE HAS
EIGHTEEN POINT SIX MILLION
PARKING SPACES THAT'S TRUE FOR
EVERY RESIDENT THE POLICY
ENCOURAGES CURTIS WITH
DEPENDENCE AND DISCOURAGES MASS
TRANSIT USES INCREASING VEHICLE
MILESTRAVELED IT'S ALSO ONE
URBAN AREAS OF FAIR AND EVEN IN
SUBURBAN A ROLLER IS OFTEN A
VERY INEFFICIENT USE OF SPACE
IT REQUIRES PEOPLE TO WALK
FURTHER THEREFORE DRIVE FURTHER
AS OPPOSED TO OLDER DOWNTOWNS
WE TYPICALLY HAVE. ROWS OF
SHOPS WITH PARKING. SOMEWHERE
ELSE OR IN A STRUCTURE.
MANDATORY PER REQUIRE ALSO
WORSEN HELLO. OF YOUR SHORTAGE
BY RAISING THE COST OF HOUSING
PRODUCTION. ON AVERAGE A GARAGE
COSTS TWENTY FOUR TO THIRTY
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS PER SPACE
TO BUILD. A COST IS PASSED ON
TO HOUSEHOLDS REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER OR NOT THEY OWN A CAR.
ADDITIONALLY ONSITE PARKING
TAKES UP SPACES THAT COULD
OTHERWISE BE USED FOR
ADDITIONAL PARKING UNITS. AND
IT'S INSIDE THIS IS BILL I'VE
BEEN CONTACTED BY PEOPLE THAT I
KNOW PERSONALLY IN MY OWN CITY.
WILL HAVE A HOUSE WHO WANTED TO
PUT A COUPLE OF UNITS BEHIND IN
THE MULTI FAMILY AREA BUT WE'RE
TOLD THEY COULDN'T BECAUSE THEY
WOULD HAVE HAD TO ASK ADD SEVEN
MORE PARKING SPACES. ON A SMALL
LOT IN AN AREA WHERE THEY
REALLY DIDN'T NEED THE PARKING.
AB FORTINO ONE DOES NOT
PROHIBIT DEVELOPERS FROM ADDING
PARKING IN PLACES THAT HAVE
DONE THIS LIKE BUFFALO NEW YORK
AND SAN DIEGO. THE TRUTH IS A
DEVELOPER STILL AT PARKING BUT
THE RIGHT SIZE THE PARKING FOR
THE DEVELOPMENT THAT THEY'RE
PUTTING TOGETHER. AND IN
BUFFALO WHAT THEY FOUND WAS
THAT- MULTI THAT- DEVELOPERS
THAT WE'RE DOING MULTI USE-
MIXED USE DEVELOPMENTS WORK
WITH EACH OTHER TO SHARE
PARKING AND SE THAT SPACE A
LOT MORE EFFICIENCY.
EFFICIENTLY THE BILL CONTINUES
TO REQUIRE THE M. CODE REQUIRED
PARKING FOR DISABLED PEOPLE FOR
DISABLED PARKING AND FOR
ELECTRIC VEHICLES. THE MEASURE
WOULD REDUCE CAR DEPENDENCE
LOWER CARBON EMISSIONS AND
ENCOURAGE MORE HOUSING BE BUILT
OR TRANSIT. AND ALLOW
DEVELOPERS TO BUILD HOUSING FOR
LOWER COST IF THEY COULD THEN
PASS ALONG TO RESIDENTS. SO
AGAIN THAT MISSING MIDDLE AB
FOUR ZERO ONE IS SPONSORED BY
CALIFORNIA YIMBY SPUR ABANDONED
HOUSE IN THE- HOUSING L. A. AND
THE COUNCIL OF INFILL BUILDERS.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT THIS
AFTERNOON- KIMBERLY DELLINGER
DONE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND MIA KANG SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT FROM RELATED
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU IF WE CAN NOW
GO TO OUR MAIN WITNESSES TO
ASSEMBLY ACCOUNTING OR.
KIMBERLY DILLINGER DONE.
RELATED CALIFORNIA AND OF WORK.
AND A BOARD MEMBER WITH THE
COUNCIL INFILL BUILDERS ONE OF
THE BILL'S CO SPONSORS I'VE
BEEN DEVELOPING AND BUILDING
AFFORDABLE AND MIXED INCOME
HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA FOR THE
LAST TWENTY FOUR YEARS AND I'M
HERE TO TESTIFY IN STRONG
SUPPORT AT EIGHTY FORTINO ONE
PARKING REQUIREMENTS PERHAPS
THE SINGLE MOST IMPORTANT
DRIVER OF HOUSING COSTS IN
CALIFORNIA TODAY. AS YOU HEARD
EXAMPLE PARKING REQUIREMENTS
MAKE NEW DEVELOPMENT IN PEOPLE
READING THOUSANDS OF POTENTIAL
HOUSING SITES TAKEN UNDER
UTILIZED THE PROJECT THANK YOU
GET BUILT ON SITE PARKING AND
ADD AN AVERAGE OF ABOUT THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER SPACE TO
BUILD AND AS YOU KNOW THE PART
BECAUSE WITHOUT DIRECTLY ON THE
DEVELOPER'S RENTERS AND HOME
BUYERS BY ELIMINATING MINIMUM
PARKING REQUIREMENTS IN TRANSIT
RICH AREAS ALLOWING DEVELOPERS.
FLEXIBILITY TO RIGHT SIZE THE
PARKING WE BELIEVE EIGHTY
FORTINO ONE WILL CUT TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS OFF THE
COST OF NEW HOUSING PRODUCTION
LOWER HOUSING COSTS FOR
RESIDENTS WHO DON'T OWN CARS
I'M WANTED NEW POTENTIAL FOR
CALIFORNIANS VACANT AND UNDER
UTILIZED LAND SUPPLY. UNLEASH A
MARKET DRIVEN APPROACH TO
PARKING IN ADDITION A RESEARCH
HAS SHOWN THAT EIGHTY FORTINO
ONE WILL ACTUALLY PROVE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF CALIFORNIA
CAN'T BE BONUS LAUNCH AN
INCLUSIONARY HOUSING PROGRAMS
LKE THE TNC PROGRAM IN LOS
ANGELES AB FORTINO ONE WILL
PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY TO
DEVELOPERS TO BALANCE THE
ADDITIONAL DENSITY AND PARKING
THE- ALLOWING FOR MORE DEALS TO
PENCIL OUT IN THE VERY PLACE WE
WANT TO HELP THE- IN EXISTING
COMMUNITIES NEAR TRANSIT.
DEVELOPERS BUILD FOR THE MARKET
AND THE MARKET STILL WANT
PARKING THE RECENT SURVEY OF
LHC PROJECT SHOWS THAT
DEVELOPERS CHOSE TO MAXON
DENSITY INCENTIVE AND PROVIDE
OVER 80% MORE PARKING AND THE
PROGRAM ACTUALLY REQUIRED AB
FORTINO ONE WILL PROVIDE
FLEXIBILITY TO DEVELOPERS TO
SERVE A WIDER RANGE OF HOUSING
TIGHT. WILL HELP SMALL
BUSINESSES LKE RESTAURANTS IN
TRANSIT RICH LOCATION TO
PERMANENTLY EXPAND THEIR
OPERATIONS OUTDOORS I CREATE
MORE PRODUCTIVE USES FOR EMPTY
PARKING SPACES. AB FOURTEEN R.
ONE WITH THANK MOST DIRECT
ACTION THE THEY CAN TAKE TODAY.
TO UP THE TERM BECAUSE- ON
CLIMATE. LOWER THE COST OF NEW
INFO HOUSING. SUPPORT SMALL
BUSINESS. FOR THE THREE WE WERE.
REQUEST THAT THE IPHONE AND WE
THANK YOU FOR HER INCREDIBLE
LEADERSHIP THANK YOU. WE GO TO
OUR NEXT WITNESS. GOOD EVENING
CHEN MEMBERS NINETY IS CAN BE
DONE AND I ABOUT THE K.
BUILDING IN ASSOCIATION. OUR
MEMBERS DON'T FOR ALL IN
CALIFORNIA SINGLE MULTI FAMILY
OWNERSHIP RENTAL AND INCLUDING
INFILL. HAS BEEN REFERENCED
SEVERAL TIMES TODAY DURING THIS
HEARING AND WE ARE ALL WELL
AWARE CALIFORNIANS IN THE MIDST
OF A HOUSING CRISIS AND ONE OF
AFFORDABILITY AND AVAILABILITY
ACROSS THE ENTIRE SPECTRUM OF
HOUSING. THERE ARE MANY
POLICIES IN PLACE MANY REASONS
THAT HOUSING IS UNAFFORDABLE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND YOU HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TODAY THE BILL
BEFORE YOU TO ADDRESS A NARROW
BUT A VERY KEY COMPONENT. OF
THE ACTUAL COST OF CONSTRUCTION
CONSTRUCTING HOUSING UNITS. AS
STATED PARKING IS VERY
EXPENSIVE TO PROVIDE. REMOVING
MINIMUM PARKING REQUIREMENTS OF
A DIRECT IMPACT AND SAVINGS TO
THOSE WHO OCCUPIED UNITS AS
WELL AS CREATING THE POTENTIAL
FOR MORE UNITS TO BE
CONSTRUCTED AND MADE AVAILABLE
TO THE LONG LIST OF
CALIFORNIANS. SEEKING A PLACE
TO CALL HOME. FIFTEEN RECOGNIZE
TO OTHER POLICIES THE DECLINING
RELIANCE ON INDIVIDUAL
AUTOMOBILES. UNDERSTANDING
COURAGE IS THAT TRUE
LEGISLATIVE AND REGULATORY
POLICY PREFERENCES FOR INFILL
DEVELOPMENT NEAR TRANSIT.
ELIMINATING MINIMUM PARKING
REQUIREMENTS IS CONSISTENT WITH
THOSE STATE POLICIES. AND WILL%
RESULT IN GREATER AFFORDABILITY
IMPACTED UNITS. WE DO
APPRECIATE THAT THE BILL
PROVIDES FLEXIBILITY SHOULD
PARTICULAR CIRCUMSTANCES
DICTATE THAT THAT CERTAIN
PARKING AVAILABILITY- BE MADE
AVAILABLE IN ORDER TO MAKE THE
PARTICULAR PROJECT VIABLE.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
GOOD FOCUSED BILL THAT GOES
DIRECTLY AT THE COST OF
CONSTRUCTING HOUSING THANK YOU
AFTER THE AFTER CALL BRINGING
IT FORWARD AND WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I THOUGHT. AT THIS
TIME LET'S GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
OH I'M SORRY I REALIZE WE NEED
TO GO TO THE OPPOSITION. IF WE
COULD CALL UP OF MS CITY
ACOSTA- FROM THE WESTERN CENTER
ALONG PARTY. TO THE OPERATOR.
OPERATOR I DON'T SHOW THAT ARE
MISCAST YOU AS DIALED IN- I
BELIEVE THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO
BE A REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
WESTERN CENTER NOT SURE IF
THERE IS ONE. AND IF NOT WE
WILL GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. INDICATING SUPPORT
OPPOSITION LET'S START HERE IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM THERE ARE NO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK. LET'S GO TO THE
REMOTE STATIONS. NO MEMBERS OF
THE PARTY WISHING TO SPEAK. IF
I CAN NOW GO TO THE PHONE LINES
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THE
WISH TO. I WISH TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THEIR SUPPORT OF THE BILL IF
YOU COULD PLEASE NAME MISTER
NAME YOUR- ORGANIZATION AND THE
FACT THAT YOU SUPPORT. TO THE
OPERATOR. LADIES ONLY IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
FORTINO ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT. AND WE DO OF ABOUT
TWENTY IN OUR QUEUE. SERVICE
LINE TO FORTY THREE YEARS AGO
AT. AS CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS
IS JACK OPENED GEHRY CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER IN SUPPORT. IT'S
TO BE NUMBER FOUR TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS LUIS
MONTEREY ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIAN BE A CROWD TO
SPONSOR OF THIS GREAT BILL.
NUMBER ONE FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MEMBERS OF THE MATTER
NOT LIKE HOW PUBLIC AFFAIRS I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA TO
CONTINUE COALITION GMG PARTNERS
IN THE PAYMENT WITH THE
PLANNING AND URBAN RESEARCH
INVESTIGATION ALL IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXUS NUMBER
THREE THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EVENING CARE MEMBERS- TACKLING
WITH- YOU'D BE ACTION AND
ALAMEDA FOR EVERYONE- CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO NUMBER TWO FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANKS
VERY MUCH HI CATHERINE
PATTERSON SANTA ESSAY FROM TECH
FACULTY CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE THANK
YOU. NEXT TO BE NUMBER FOUR
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING JUST IN OUR FROM
THE SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP
GROUP WE'RE PROUD TO SUPPORT
THIS IMPORTANT BILL THANK YOU.
NOT GOING TO NUMBER ONE NINETY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
LEARNED THEY LENT THEIR
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION WE DO HAVE
AT THE PORT OF THE MINUTES
ADDITION BUT LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
OPERATIC CONCERTS ALSO HELP
FORTY FIFTEEN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING TOOL THAT PROVIDES. LOS
PARKING REDUCTION THANK YOU SO
MUCH. BUT A LINE TO EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING I
AM OUT OF BOOKBINDER CITY
COUNCIL DISTRICT TWENTY EIGHT
OF THE APPS THAT THEY CAN BE
PROBABLY SUPPORTING EIGHTY
FORTINO ONE. NOW GO TO LINE FOR
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. ASSEMBLY
SIMON FROM NEW WAY HOMES WE
CONDITIONALLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THE DEFINITION MAJOR TRANSIT
STAFF WERE TO BE THE THING OF
IT IS ANOTHER TEMPORARY A LOT
FOR THE MONTEREY BAY REGION IS
NOT EXCLUSION THANK YOU. WE'LL
GO TO LINE FOR FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DAVID WALKER
NUMBER OF EUROPEAN LEAGUE
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB
FORTINO. ONE NEXUS NUMBER FOUR
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF HIS ROGER DICKINSON
ON BEHALF OF THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMISSION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. WE'LL GO TO
LINE FOR SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS KELLY
CALLING FROM THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE LINE FOR FIFTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. IT CAN MEMBERS I'M
GONNA PATENT IF YOU DON'T COUNT
ME IN SANTA CRUZ CALIFORNIA
COMING IN FROM SUPPORT OF AB
FORTINO. ONE THE LINE FOR SIXTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MAX
CANNOT THREATEN OF OXNARD
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF VENTURA
COUNTY INDIAN STRONG SUPPORT.
TO LINE FOR SIXTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WELL ROB NIELSEN PALO
ALTO- THE NEXT THE FOR EVERYONE
CALLING IN SUPPORT. NEXUS
NUMBER FOUR SEVENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WE'RE ALSO WITH AN
ANSWER FOR EVERYONE ALTON
SUPPORT OF AB FORKING OUT ONE.
TO NUMBER FOUR SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HENRY FONG WITH- PEOPLE
FOR HELPING ORANGE COUNTY OR
HAVING IN THE CAN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FOUR OH ONE IF
YOU. NEXT NUMBER FOUR FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
A BORDER WITH EAST BAY FOR
EVERYONE- IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NEXUS FOUR FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING ADAM
GENSERIC WITH THE HOUSING
ACTION COALITION IN SUPPORT.
NEXOBRID ALIVE FOR FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I TOBY
MARSHON- CALLING ON BEHALF OF
WEBSITE FOR EVERYONE AND LOS
ANGELES AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NEXT IN LINE FOR
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THIS IS BOB
NAYLOR ON BEHALF OF FEELS SEVEN
COMPANY IN ORANGE COUNTY
BUSINESS IN SUPPORT OF AB
FORTINO ONE AND BY THE WAY THE
NINERS NFL DRAFT PICK IS NEXT.
GO NINERS. WELL NOW GO TO LINE
FOR SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NICKELBERRY FOR AARON RODGERS
THIS IS JOSH APRAKSIN OF SOUTH
PASADENA TO RESPONSIBLE GROWTH
WE ARE STRONG SUPPORT OF
FORTINO ONE GO CHARGERS. NEXT
IS GOING TO BE LINE FOR SEVENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MICHAEL
IN THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
PLANNING URBAN RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION OR SPUR PROUD CO
SPONSOR THE BILL IN STRONG
SUPPORT. NEXT IN LINE FOR
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS MARK SMITH I AM
PACIFIC ENTERPRISE DEVELOPMENT
IN SEOUL BUILDER AS WELL AS
THE- CARE ACT GOT CANCELED
UNTIL BUILDERS PROUD CO SPONSOR
THE BILL AND THE WEST THIRD
STREET PARKING AND PUBLIC
IMPROVEMENT ASSOCIATION A
STRONG SUPPORT. WELL NOW BEEN A
LINE FOR SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS TANIA OUTLAY
FROM LOS ANGELES I'M A RECENT
COLLEGE GRAD AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF FORTINO ONE AND GO
ROUND. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
NO OTHERS IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE. THAT'S NOT GOOD-
MEMBERS ONLINE WHO MAY WISH TO
OPPOSE THIS MEASURE OPERATOR IF
YOU COULD PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINE. AND IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO AB
FORTINO ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AGAIN OPPOSITION TO
FOURTEEN OH ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. CURRENTLY ABOUT FIVE
IN OUR QUEUE. WILL BEGIN WITH
NUMBER TWO THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I THINK THAT THE ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER LONG
PROPERTY REALLY APOLOGIZE FOR
THE CONNECTIVITY ISSUES SO I
WILL KEEP MY REMARKS PRETTY
BRIEF HERE- WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED AB
PARKING HERE WHY NOT WATCH AND
CENTER HOLY AGREES THAT THE
COURT THE AUTHOR YOU CAN CALL
TO REMOVE EXCESSIVE PARKING
REQUIREMENTS AND ENCOURAGE
HEALTHIER COMMUNITIES LAST SO I
AND I'M GREENHOUSE. GAS
EMITTING CARD UNFORTUNATELY AB
FORTINO ONE CURRENTLY DOESN'T
STRIKE THE RIGHT BALANCE
BETWEEN IT POLICY OBJECTIVES
AND THE STATE CRITICAL GOAL OF
INCREASING AVAILABILITY OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. WE BELIEVE
IT MUST BE CONSISTENT QUALITY
OF CAPTURING THAT VALUE THAT IS
BEING CREATED BY THE REMOVAL OF
THE PARKING TO PRODUCE HOUSING
AFFORDABLE TO LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. SO IN ORDER TO G.
DR COLD WITHOUT HAMPERING THE
MECHANISM BY WHICH DEVELOPERS
INCREASE THE PORTABILITY GREG
WE RECOMMEND A COUPLE OF
AMENDMENTS TO WHICH IS AT THE
ELIMINATE PARKING MINIMUM FOR
NON RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENTS
NEAR TRANSIT AND ELIMINATE
PARKING. RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENT NEAR TRANSIT WHERE
THE DEVELOPER UTILIZES AND
SPEAK ON THE CLOCK. WE THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FREEMAN OR STAFF
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR HEARING
OUR CONCERNS AND LOOK FORWARD
TO FURTHER CONVERSATION. TO GET
TO THE PARK COMMISSION THANK
YOU. BUT YOU'RE FROM MEMBERS
UPON. OF SHOULD WE JUST FROM
THE OPPOSITE WITNESS FOR THE
REST OF THE- COMMENTERS PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION AND THE FACT OF
YOUR OPPOSITION. WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE NINETY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I MEAN BROKEN COALITION
FOR SAN FRANCISCO NEIGHBORHOODS
SPEAKING ON MY OWN BEHALF IN
OPPOSITION. NEXT TO NUMBER TWO
NINETY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. ANY
CHAIR MEMBERS OF SAMBA STAR
WITH RAINY PUBLIC POLICY GROUP
REPRESENTING THE CITY OF CORONA
IN OPPOSITION AB FOURTEEN R.
ONE THANK YOU. NOW READ ONLINE
FOR ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BRIAN I GOTTA BE HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION. IN THE
PUBLIC INTEREST LAW PROJECT
ALIGN OURSELVES WITH THE
COMMENT OF WESTERN CENTER
BOULEVARD AND. WELL NOT A LINE
FOR SEVENTY SIX WE'VE GOT.
MISTER KAREN MEMBERS ON THE
RESTAURANT MEET AS ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF PLEASANTON
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
NEXT TO NUMBER FOUR SIXTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING
NEED LA ABOUT THE PRESENT IN
THE CITY OF THOUSAND OAKS AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. WILL NOW
GO TO NUMBER FOUR SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU ARE
ROUGHLY HALF OF THE TOWN OF
TRUCKEE AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
CURRENTLY OF NO OTHERS IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE GREAT
THANK YOU LET'S BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY DISCUSSION MR
WARD I THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRING THIS FORWARD- WE DID
SOMETHING SIMILAR IN THE CITY
OF SAN DIEGO ABOUT TWO YEARS
AGO NOW AND- DIDN'T COME
WITHOUT OPPOSITION A LOT OF
CONCERN OUT THERE BUT WE FOUND
WAS THAT IN THE DOWNTOWN AREA
IN PARTICULAR- RESIDENTIAL
SURVEY FOUND THAT ABOUT 30% OF
OUR DEVELOP PARKING SPACES
WENT. UNUSED AND SO
DEVELOPMENT- COSTS ARE HIGH-
FOR PARKING AND SO WE'RE TRYING
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE MAKING
HOUSING MORE AFFORDABLE WE WANT
TO TAKE THAT OUT PHILIP THE
MARKET DECIDE AND WE ACTUALLY
IT'S AN PROJECTS SEE VARIANCES
AND NOW THEY CAN DO THAT-
EXPLOSIVELY- THROUGHOUT THE
CODE. TO MAKE SURE THAT IF THE
MARKET IS INTERESTED IN
PRODUCING UNITS DOESN'T MEAN NO
PARKING FOR ANYTHING BUT IF
THEY WANT TO TRY THAT FOR A
RENTER OR A HOMEOWNER THAT
SEEKS TO UNIT NOT TETHERED THE
PARKING. WERE ABLE TO DELIVER
PLACES WITH LOWER RENTS SO I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BEING
ABLE TO EMULATE THE STATE WHAT
I THINK IT WILL BE HELPFUL AND
ALL IT HASN'T BEEN ALREADY OF
ALL OF THE BILL. IS PROMOTION.
OF THE FORESTS ARE SECOND.
SECOND OKAY THE A SECOND. ARE
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION. TO THE
MOISTURE. I APPRECIATE. HM I'M
MORE THAN A MAJOR WITH
DIFFERENT DIFFERENT YOU KNOW IN
OUR AREAS- ACTUALLY I WAS IN
URBAN AREAS WHERE THEY HAVE
THIS PROBLEM OF- HARPER HIRED
IN THE AREA AND YOUR CARD IS
EVERYWHERE GOING NEIGHBORHOOD.
IN FRONT OF THEIR HOUSE AND IF
NOT ENOUGH- LOCAL LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
THE ABILITY. TO YEAH TO WHAT
THEIR NEEDS ARE UNIQUE- PERSON
SPOKE SHARKS. I THINK YOU. I
CAN TELL YOU WHAT THE IN FRONT
CALLED IN BECAUSE TRUCK
DOWNTOWN HAS A REAL GOES RIGHT
THROUGH. AND SO THAT'S
CONSIDERED A HIGH TRANSIT AREA
AND YOU WILL FOR DAYS WHEN ARE
JUST DRIVING AROUND DRIVING
AROUND LOOKING FOR SOME PARKING
SOMEWHERE. AND THAT'S SUPER
FRUSTRATING TO PEOPLE AND- IN
IN OUR OUR CITY I KNOW OVER THE
YEARS WE HAVE NEGOTIATED WITH
DEVELOPERS ABOUT THE PARKING
REQUIREMENTS. AND WHEN WE COME
OUT WE COME TO SOME AGREEMENT
TO REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF PARKING
AND TODAY I GO TO SOME OF THOSE
THE DEVELOPMENTS THERE EITHER
COMMERCIAL OR OFFICE. AND IT IS
A NIGHTMARE TO TRY AND PARK
JUST LIKE WE PREDICTED SO I
PREFERRED TO LEAVE THESE TYPE
OF DECISION MAKING. AND USING
THE EXACT TOOLS THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT IF IT'S WEIRD IF
THAT WORKS FOR THEIR
COMMUNITIES LIKE IT MARKS DOWN
IN SAN DIEGO SO I'M KIND OF A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT GUY I WANT
THOSE DECISIONS MADE LOCAL AND
THAT'S WHY I'M NOT A STRUGGLE
WITH THE- THE KIND OF THE STATE
MANDATING THIS AND TAKING THAT
CONTROL AWAY FROM THE
GOVERNMENT. THANK YOU. HEY
COMMENTS. I JUST WANTED TO
THANK THE AUTHOR- FOR TAKING
THIS ON AND- ALSO APPRECIATE
YOU AND YOUR STAFF AS WELL AS
STAKEHOLDERS ON BOTH SIDES FOR
ENGAGING WITH MY STAFF
EXTENSIVELY ABOUT THIS AND LET
ME SAY THAT- I VERY MUCH
SUPPORT THE GOALS OF WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO IN FACT AND
SAN FRANCISCO WHEN I WAS ON THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS- I
AUTHORED THE FIRST LOCAL
ORDINANCE TO ELIMINATE PARKING
MINIMUMS ARE IN OUR DOWNTOWN
AREAS NEAR TRANSIT. AND THEN
OUR CITY MOVED TO ELIMINATE
THESE- PARKING MINIMUMS
THROUGHOUT THE CITY AS A NUMBER
OF OTHER CITIES HAVE DONE AND I
THINK THE GOALS OF ENSURING
THAT- IF YOU KNOW. THE FACT IS.
THIS POLICY IS ENCOURAGE
CARBAPENEMS HAS DISCOURAGED
MASS TRANSIT HAS INCREASED
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED- IS
SIGNIFICANTLY NOT JUST
IMPACTING OUR HOUSING GOALS OUR
CLIMATE GOALS. ARE AND
APPRECIATE WE'RE TRYING TO DO
HERE- I ALSO KNOW AND WE'VE HAD
MANY CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE
CONCERNS IT'S BEEN RAISED.
CRITICALLY WITH REGARDS TO.
SOME OF OUR MOST MORE RECENT.
DISCUSSIONS AROUND DENSITY
BONUS LAW. AND THE TRADE OFFS
THAT WE MADE BETWEEN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND PARKING FOR MY
PERSPECTIVE IF WE CAN REWIND
THE CLOCK I DON'T THINK. WE
WOULD HAVE TIED SOME OF THESE
PAST DENSITY BONUS AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. OBJECTIVE
TO PARKING MINIMUMS BUT WE DID
AND THAT'S NOT SOMETHING WE'RE
TRYING TO WORK THROUGH BUT- I
APPRECIATE YOUR- YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO KEEP ENGAGING
WITH STAKEHOLDERS ON THAT TOPIC
AND- IT AND KNOW IF THERE ARE
GOOD CONVERSATIONS THAT COME
OUT OF THAT I LOOK FOR TO HEAR
ABOUT IT- BUT AT THIS TIME I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
MOVING FORWARD. AS IT CAME OUT
OF THE LAST COMMITTEE. I AND
WITH THAT. INVESTORS ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION THERE'S BEEN
A MOTION AND A SECOND. PLEASE
LET US KNOW IF YOU HAVE ANY
FINAL WORDS FIRST OF ALL I HAVE
NO IDEA WHAT KIND OF SPORTS
PEOPLE WERE TALKING ABOUT BUT-
IT'S GOOD- THANK ALL. I
HONESTLY DON'T KNOW FOOTBALL
THAT REQUIRES A LOT OF PARKING
OKAY SO. I YOU KNOW I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE OF THE CONCERNS THAT
WERE RAISED AND WE'VE BEEN
THINKING FOR A LOT OF THESE AS
WELL AND FROM THE ADVOCATES TO
ABOUT AFFORDABLE HOUSING. YOU
KNOW ALL THIS A VERY QUICKLY
THAT YOU KNOW CITIES ALSO HAVE
A LOT OF TOOLS AT THEIR
DISPOSAL TO DEAL WITH PARKING
MANAGEMENT. HOW WE GOT RID OF A
LOT OF THE PARKING REQUIREMENTS
IN OUR DOWNTOWN IN GLENDALE
BUILT A COUPLE STRUCTURES. AND
ACTUALLY FORCED PEOPLE TO WALK
AROUND THE DOWNTOWN IT WAS A
HUGE IMPROVEMENT FOR THE SHOPS.
AND RUNNING MORE TRANSIT IS A
GOAL AND I'M COMMITTED TO
TRYING TO GET MORE MONEY TO ALL
OF OUR CITIES- THROUGH MY ROLE
OF TRANSPORTATION TO DO THAT
TRANSIT. SO I DO THINK THAT
THERE ARE SOLUTIONS HERE BUT
PUTTING IT ALL- THIS ONE SIZE
FITS ALL AND DEVELOPERS IT'S
SOMETHING THAT JUST ISN'T
WORKING ESPECIALLY BECAUSE I DO
KNOW THAT THE YOUNGER
GENERATION. IS TAKING RIDE
SHARE VEHICLES MORE AND A TON
OF HIS VEHICLES I HAPPEN TO
BELIEVE ARE JUST A NUMBER OF
YEARS AWAY AND THEN WHAT ARE WE
GONNA DO WITH ALL OF THESE
GIANT EMPTY PARKING LOTS. NOT
TO MENTION THAT MOST CITIES
HAVEN'T DONE PARKING
INVENTORIES AND THERE'S A LOT
OF UNUSED PARKING BOTH
COMMERCIAL AND RESIDENTIAL THAT
CAN BE USED SO MUCH MORE
CREATIVELY. I'M TO PARK PEOPLE
SO I DO APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH ALL OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND WESTERN CENTER
AND ALL OF OUR FRIENDS AND WITH
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND THEIR
CONCERNS. I DO FIND IT A LITTLE
IRONIC. TO SAY WE'RE REQUIRING
MORE PARKING AND WE KNOW WE
NEED SO THAT WE CAN TRY TO
BARGAIN SOMETHING AND GIVE IT
BACK- I THINK IT RATED ITS FACE
THERE'S SOMETHING KIND OF WRONG
WITH THAT. AND I WILL ALSO SAY
THAT MOST DEVELOPERS OF FROM
WHAT I'VE BEEN LEARNING TAKE
THE PARKING PRODUCTION ONLY TO
SERVICE. THAT HIGHER DENSITY
THAT THEY'RE GETTING SO IT'S
JUST BECAUSE IF THEY'RE GETTING
THAT HIGHER DENSITY YOU NEED
THE REDUCTION OTHERWISE YOU
HAVE TO ADD SO MUCH PARKING
THAT IT DOESN'T WORK OUT. BUT
WILL CONTINUE TO TALK WITH THE
ADVOCATES AND REALLY APPRECIATE
MISTER CHAIR YOUR WILLINGNESS
TO KIND OF GO ALONG THIS
JOURNEY WITH US AND- THANKS
EVERYONE I DO HOPE THAT
EVERYBODY CAN FIND. A WAY TO
VOTING FOR. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MADAM SIR. YOU HAVE A
MOTION AND- SECOND. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL- MORE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS TO HI CHIU I SAY
ARCHER NOW. YOU KNOW GABRIELLE
KALRA. RIGHT KALRA AYE KILEY
AYE KILEY I. WARD FOR TI QUICK
SILVA. STILL BY WEEKS. TWO
THREE FOUR FIVE TWO ONE. YOUR
BILL IS OUT. IN I THAT'S REYES
EXACTLY THAT'S GONNA DO IF
THAT'S ALRIGHT MISTER REAVIS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
WHAT'S IT. THANK YOU FOR THE
INDULGENCE OF OUR COLLEAGUES
FROM ORANGE COUNTY. FILE ITEM
NINETEEN AB THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO
WELL- GOOD EVENING EVERYBODY-
COLLEAGUES IN MISTER CHAIR
PRECIADO OPPORTUNITY PRESENT
THIS BILL- COMMITTEE TODAY AND
I'LL START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS REALLY
APPRECIATE I THINK THE- THE
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING WITH
OUR OFFICE TO ADDRESS CONCERNS
RAISED BY STAKEHOLDERS. AND AS
WE ALL KNOW- TOO WELL
UNFORTUNATELY THAT THERE ARE
MANY FACTORS THAT HAVE
CONTRIBUTED. I CONTINUE TO- TO-
IMPACT- OUR STATE'S WORSENING
HOUSING CRISIS- THE IMBALANCE
BETWEEN THE AVAILABLE SUPPLY OF
AFFORDABLE HOMES AND- GROWING
HIGH DEMAND FOR HOUSING HAS LED
TO EXCESSIVE RENT BURDENS
HOUSING INSTABILITY. AND
INCREASING HOMELESSNESS YOU
KNOW THE REALITY IS IN MOST
CITIES AND COUNTIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA LOCAL PLANNING AND
REGULATORY SYSTEMS DIRECTLY AND
INDIRECTLY. RESTRICT THE
PRODUCTION OF HOUSING- AND DO
SO IN MANY WAYS AS WE JUST
HEARD A BY REQUIRING SOME
PARKING SPACE MINIMUMS-
IMPOSING BUILDING HEIGHT
LIMITS. HAVING LENGTHY-
SUPERMINI AN ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW PROCESSES AND HAVING
VERY RIGID ZONING- OR DENSITY
AND YOU SPACE PLANE SYSTEMS.
AND AS STATE OFFICIALS IN AS
THIS LEGISLATURE HAS HAVE BEEN
ATTEMPTED TO DO MORE IN
ADDRESSING CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING
CRISIS. THERE ARE INCREASING
INSTANCES OF LOCAL HIGH HOUSING
MEASURES THAT- ARMED CONFLICT
WITH STATE HOUSING LAWS AND
STATE HOUSING REQUIREMENTS. AS
THE ANALYSIS FOR THIS BILL-
NOTES FROM THIS COMMITTEE IF A
LOCAL VOTER APPROVED MEASURE
CONFLICTS WITH STATE HOUSING
LAW. EITHER AT THE TIME OF THE
MEASURES ADOPTION OR AS A
RESULT OF NEWLY ADOPTED STATE
HOUSING LAWS THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IS PLACED IN A- A
PERILOUS LEGAL- OPPOSITION AND
SO CLEARLY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ARE ANY CHALLENGING SITUATION.
HAVING TO BALANCE LOCAL
PLANNING AND REGULATORY HOUSING
MEASURES AND THEN WORKING TO
COMPLY WITH EVOLVING STATE
HOUSING LAW. SO OFTEN LOCAL
OFFICIALS FACE A CATCH TWENTY
TWO. GIVEN THAT EITHER FAILING
TO IMPLEMENT LOCAL HOUSING
RELATED MEASURES. OR FAILING TO
COMPLY WITH CERTAIN ASPECTS OF
STATE HOUSING LAW CAN BOTH
RESULT IN COSTLY LITIGATION. SO
THIS LEGISLATION THIS BILL
CREATES A PROCESS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO AVOID THIS CATCH
TWENTY TWO- TO AND TO SEEK A
JUDICIAL VALIDATION THAT A
LOCAL MEASURE OR VOTER
INITIATIVE IS IN CONFLICT. WITH
STATE HOUSING LAW. AND SO
CONSISTENT WITH ESTABLISHED
STATE VALIDATION PROCEDURES THE
OPTION FOR JUDICIAL VALIDATION
CREATED BY THIS BILL. WOULD
RESULT IN AN EXPEDITED JUDICIAL
RULING. ON THE ISSUE A QUESTION
OF STATE AND LOCAL PREEMPTION
RELATED TO HOUSING LOS. AND
WOOD- IT WOULD PROVIDE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WHO CHOOSE TO USE
THIS OPTION OR TOOL. WITH LEGAL
CERTAINTY ABOUT THEIR HOUSING
OBLIGATIONS OR REQUIREMENTS.
IT'S HERE WITH ME THIS
AFTERNOON OR THIS EVENING AD
TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY AND
ADDRESS ANY TACKLE QUESTIONS
ARE SERRA KARLINSKY A SENIOR
POLICY ADVISER FOR SPUR AND
CHRISTOPHER ELMENDORF A LAW
PROFESSOR UC DAVIS WITH
EXPERTISE IN LAND USE WITH THAT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK A
MYSTERY OF US LET'S GO TO THE
MAIN WITNESSES TO MS KARLINSKY
AND TO PROFESSOR. ELMENDORF. TO
THE OPERATOR. CARE MISTER CHAIR
UP. THIS CALL IS CLEAR MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS YES CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES WE CAN THANK YOU GOD
BLESS YES PLEASE OKAY WONDERFUL
THANK YOU. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MY NAME IS TERRA KARLINSKY AND
I AM SENIOR ADVISER FOR. A
PUBLIC POLICY THINK TANK
FOCUSED ON CREATING A
SUSTAINABLE EQUITABLE AND
PROSPEROUS REGION AND STATE.
HOW TO SPONSOR AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY TWO. I'D LIKE TO FOCUS
MY COMMENTS ON MY DISABILITY
THAT. I LIVE IN A SMALL TOWN
CALLED PIEDMONT WHICH IS AN
INCORPORATED CITY WITHIN THE
CITY OF OAKLAND. HE'S NOT AS
WEALTHY AND 70% WHITE IT WAS
ONCE KNOWN AS THE CITY OF
MILLIONAIRES THE AVERAGE HOME
PRICES ON THE TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. IN THE WAKE OF
THE MURDER OF GEORGE FLOYD MANY
BLACK CONNECTOR STAND BY AND
ALLOW BUSINESS AS USUAL. PEOPLE
IN THE VOLUNTEER ORGANIZATION
CALLED THE PIEDMONT RACIAL
EQUITY CAMPAIGN OR CRACK. AND
CRACK HOUSING WORK WE QUICKLY
LEARNED THAT THE TO THE
PIEDMONT HAS WITHIN ITS CITY
CHARTER. REQUIREMENT DATING
BACK NEARLY A HUNDRED YEARS BUT
ANY DINING CHANGES NEED TO BE
APPROVED BY VOTERS. WE ALSO
LEARNED AT PIEDMONT IT'S LIKELY
TO BE ALLOCATED A MUCH SIX
HUNDRED UNITS AND HAVING TO
PLAN FOR ITS PART. OF ITS
REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ALLOCATION. I A HUNTER AND
SIXTY. HUNDRED AND- UNITS AND
VERY INCOME HOUSING. THERE'S NO
WAY FOR PIEDMONT ACCOMMODATED
THREE ALLOCATION WITH THE
CURRENT CHARTER RESTRICTIONS.
WE ALSO LEARNED THAT THERE ARE
OTHER SHOULD FICTIONS LANDSCAPE
AND SHARE THE CHALLENGES AND
ENTRENCH CONSTRAINT. THESE
CONSTRAINTS ON PARTS OF THE
STATE HOUSING LAW AND ENSHRINE
RACIAL SEGREGATION. THEY DO SO
NOT BY ACCIDENT BUT BY DESIGN.
ENTRENCH CONSTRAINT CODIFY
INCLUSIONARY ZONING FOR
APARTMENT BUILDINGS THE SMALLER
HOMES ARE RENDERED ILLEGAL.
INCLUSIONARY ZONING GRANT
COUNTY THAT THERE HAS BEEN GOAL
OF RACIAL. AND ECONOMIC
INTEGRATION. MANY SIGNIFICANT
CONSTRAINTS ARE THE WHICH THE
STATE AND TO ALLOW ON A COMMON
MORE AND DIFFERENT TYPES AND
LEVELS OF AFFORDABILITY IN
ORDER TO FURTHER IF THERE HAVE
BEEN CALLS. BUT HE SAID IT OR
NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO FURTHER
FAIR HOUSING WITHOUT AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO. FINALLY
I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE
OF LOCAL CONTROL. MEASURES
STARTING LOCAL CONTROL OF
ECONOMY WORKS IN THE BACK
MAJORITY JURISDICTIONS IN THE
STATE. AND THAT RESTORED LAND
USE DECISIONS TO LOCALLY
ELECTED BODIES WHO NEED TO USE
THEIR GOOD JUDGMENT AND
DISCRETION ABOUT BALANCING THE
DESIRES. THE NEIGHBORS WITH
APARTMENTS IN STATE LAW. WE
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE BY
EMPHASIZING THAT THE TOOL
COMPLETELY OPTIONAL FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF MY
COMMENTS AND WE URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT AB. THIRTEEN TWENTY
JAIL AND WITH THAT PASSWORD.
KAREN MEMBERS CAN YOU HEAR ME.
WE CAN HEAR YOU. THANK YOU I'M
CHRIS OUTDOOR I'M A LAW
PROFESSOR AT UC DAVIS AND MY
REMARKABLE PRODUCT PROVIDE
LEGAL CONTEXT FOR THE BILL. AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO YEARS OF
THE WELL ESTABLISHED LEGAL
LEGAL MECHANISM TO HELP
THIRTIES AVOID THE TRAIN WRECK.
IT WILL OTHERWISE RESULT
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING CLIMATE
ADAPTATION IT CRASHED INTO
VOTER ADOPTED GROWTH CONTROL
THE LOCAL LEVEL. THIS LEGAL
MECHANISM IS CALLED VALIDATION.
IT WAS ORIGINALLY DEVELOPED
PROVIDE INSURANCE TO MENISCAL
BONTA THAT'S RICH. A CRAZY
COUNCIL PASSED A RESOLUTION
AUTHORIZING THE ISSUANCE OF
DEBT IS A WINDOW OF TIME IN
SHOW UP IN COURT TO CONTEST TO
CONFIRM THE VALIDITY OF THE
RESOLUTION. OR TO REQUIRED TO
SCHEDULE VALIDATION ACTION TO
HELP OTHERS WHAT MATTERS. AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO BUT USE
THIS MECHANISM TO CONFIRM THE
VALIDITY OF A REVOLUTION DAY
KNOWLEDGE. CITY HARDER
PROVISION WORKLOAD ROOFTOP THAT
MEASURE HAS BEEN PREEMPTED BY
STATE HOUSE ALL. AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY TWO DOES NOT TELL
PREEMPTIVELY LOCAL MEASURES
THAT ARE NOT NOW CREATE IT. NOR
DOES IT CHANGE LEGAL STANDARD
FOR PREEMPTION. JUST CREATE THE
PROCEDURAL FRAMEWORK THROUGH IT
CITIES MAY OBTAIN LEGAL
CERTAINTY AT LOW RISK ABOUT
THEIR OBLIGATIONS. WE NEED FOR
THE BILL WELL ILLUSTRATED BY
THE GRAPH. AND PETER'S THAT
NEEDED TO BE HELPFUL OR SORRY
YOU MAY BE UP AND IT IS THE
CHARTER REQUIRES VOTER APPROVAL
OF MAJOR OF ANY VISION THE CITY
VOTERS HAVE CONSISTENTLY
REJECTED HOUSING ELEMENT. MORE
THAN TWO YEARS AGO THE CITY
COUNCIL DECIDED TO SEEK A
JUDICIAL DETERMINATION WHETHER
THE VOTER APPROVAL REQUIREMENTS
IT'S CHARTER IS PREEMPTED BY
STATE LAW. GET THE CASE WILL
HAVE BEEN HEARD. YOU WON'T BE
HEARD UNTIL AFTER THE CITY'S
HOUSING ELEMENT DO. LOCAL ANTI
HOUSING ACCESS TO INTERVENE IN
THE CASE AND THEY ARGUED THAT
THE COURT LACKS JURISDICTION
AND CANNOT PROVIDE AROUND. AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO WOULD
PROVIDE YOUR PATH OR WORK FOR
ANY UNITS IN OTHER CITIES.
BEFORE CLOSING I WOULD LIKE TO
EMPHASIZE THIS BILL IT'S BEEN A
REAL GROUP AFTER. SPUR ABOUT
THE BALL ROLLING I ADDED SOME
IDEAS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
CONTRIBUTED MORE IDEAS AND
WE'RE WORKING WITH
ENVIRONMENTALISTS AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING APPLICANTS
TO MAKE THE BILL BETTER. I
ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT THE BILL AND BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE THANK YOU. HELLO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- WHY DON'T WE NOW GO
THERE ARE NO OPPOSITION
WITNESSES LET'S GO NOW TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT WISH
TO STATE THEIR OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT OF A MEASURE SAID
THERE'S ONE PERSON HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM PLEASE ONLY
PERSON THAT MARKS DIVERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU LET'S GO
NOW TO THE REMOTE STATIONS.
ANYONE NOW LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINES TO THE OPERATOR IF
YOU COULD PLEASE ALLOW ANYONE
THAT WISHES TO SPEAK AND
SUPPORT AGAIN TO JUST STATE
YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND
THE FACT THAT YOU SUPPORT.
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TOUCH TONE PHONE AT THIS TIME.
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH
TONE PHONE IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT. AND IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS
TOPIC PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME. OKAY
IS THERE ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
REGISTER OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. THERE'S BEEN A MOTION
THERE'S BEEN A SECOND. I DID TO
THE OPERATOR ANY MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC WHICH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. I
BELIEVE WE ARE SHOWING THIS
ABSENT PEOPLE IN SUPPORT I ONE
MOMENT PLEASE THANK YOU. OKAY
AGAIN WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE
SUPPORT SO WE ARE SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO WE
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT TWELVE IN
THE QUEUE- WILL GO AHEAD AND
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE FIFTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT JERRY
MEMBERS DOESN'T MATTER NOT LIKE
HOW PUBLIC AFFAIRS CALLING ON
BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIA THE FAMILY FISCAL
PLANNING AND URBAN RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION THE COMPUTER
COALITION CMG PARTNERS AND THE
COUNCIL OF INTEL BUILDERS ALL
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SIX OF THE NUMBER FOUR SEVENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON TRACY RYAN ON BEHALF
OF THE WORLD COUNTY REPRESENTED
CALIFORNIA'S URBAN COUNTY TO
CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA IF
THE PATIENT COUNTIES AND IN
RECOMMENDING ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER- WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL WE'VE
BEEN WORKING DILIGENTLY WITH
THE AUTHOR'S. AND I WILL BE TO
WORK WITH THEM TO ADDRESS
STAKEHOLDER CONCERNS THANK YOU.
NOW THE NUMBER TWO EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO GOOD
EVENING I'M ADAM BOOKBINDER
STEVE CAMPBELL DISTRICT TWENTY
EIGHT HAPPY TO SUPPORT AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO THANK YOU.
NEXT IS GONNA BE NUMBER THREE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
CARE IN THAT MEMBERS- TACKLING
WITH ALAMEDA FOR EVERYONE OUR
CITY WOULD BE DIRECTLY AFFECTED
BY THIS BILL- WE AREN'T VERY
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. TO
NUMBER ONE NINETY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. EILEEN BROKEN COALITION
FOR SAN FRANCISCO NEIGHBORHOODS
SPEAKING ON MY OWN BEHALF IN
STRONG OPPOSITION I BELIEVE YOU
DID CALL OPPOSITION. NOW GOING
TO NUMBER FOUR ELEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS BRIAN AGHAST ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION-
AND PUBLIC INTEREST LAW PROJECT
I AM SORT OF IN BETWEEN-
CATEGORY BUT I WANT TO MISS MY
CHANCE HERE WE'VE SUBMITTED A
LETTER OF CONCERNS THE AUTHOR
OF WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THEM TO ENSURE THAT THE
PROCESS IS NARROW. AND THAT IT
HAS TO DO PROCESS. ELEMENTS
THAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE TARGETING THE RIGHT LAND
USE POLICIES AND NOT
INVALIDATING THOSE THAT
PROTECT. HOUSING BUBBLE PEOPLE.
NEXT TO BE NUMBER FOUR TWENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO IT'S
MONDAY WITH CALIFORNIAN BE THE
PARKING. NEXT TO BE LINED TWO
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ZAKOPANE GALLERY CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER IN SUPPORT. NEXUS NUMBER
FOUR SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FONG ORANGE COUNTY M. B. AND
PEOPLE ARE HOUSING ORANGE
COUNTY AND COMPORT THANK YOU.
SAYS ONE FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ADAM JANICEK
WITH THE HOUSING ACTION
COALITION IN SUPPORT. I GOT A
LINE FOR EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'VE GOT A FOUR EIGHTY
FOUR BUT OUTSIDE JENNIFER HERE
IN DAVIS- MEMBER OF PRESIDENT'S
UNITED NETWORK AND I WANT THE
QUARTER I URGE YOU TO. THE BILL
THANK YOU. NEXT IN LINE WE HAVE
NUMBER FOUR EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ASSEMBLY DONE I'LL BE
HAPPY CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION WHICH
STOCKS FOR THE BILL. AND NEXT
WE HAVE NUMBER FOUR NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
INTERNET CRIMES ON BEHALF OF AN
AND SO YOUNG DEMOCRATS IN
STRONG SUPPORT. CURRENTLY OF NO
OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE- PLEASE
CONTINUE. OKAY BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS. HIS
RENT MS WORKS. I JUST WANNA
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THE BILL FOR ALWAYS SUPPORTING
AND STAYING BELOW TO BE ADDED
AS A CO AUTHOR. ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU. ANY FINAL ANY OTHER
COMMENTS. I JUST ALSO WANT
APPRECIATE TO MYSTERY THIS
MOVING THIS FOR I KNOW THIS WAS
ORIGINALLY A BILL BY ARE NOW
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND- I THINK
INVOLVES A VERY IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION PARTICULARLY WHEN
YOU HAVE SITUATIONS WHERE THERE
ARE VOTER APPROVED MEASURES
THAT ARE IN CONFLICT WITH STATE
LAW. ALSO APPRECIATE TO. SHE
MISSED RIVAS ACCEPTING. THE
INTENT- AMENDMENT TO WORK OUT-
THE SCOPE OF THIS BILL- BECAUSE
I DON'T THINK ANYONE INTENDS
FOR IT TO BE USED TO UNDERCUT-
A NUMBER OF POLICIES THAT DO
NOT HAVE TO DO WITH WHAT I
THINK IT'S A HEART OF THE
BILL'S APPRECIATE THAT.
CONSIDERATION HAPPY TO SUPPORT
IT. ANALYSTS ARE THE FINAL.
COMMENTS IS OUR MOTION OF THE
BILL FOR. THIS PROMOTION SECOND
MISTER RIVAS ANY FINAL COMMENTS
RESPECT LAST NIGHT OF CHAD
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY.
MOTION NEED TO PASS THIS
AMENDED- CHIU HI CHIU FIVE THEY
ARE DON'T KNOW THEY ARE THE NO
GABRIELLE. GABRIEL I KALRA.
KALRA KILEY. KILEY NO WORK. FOR
IT I COOK SILVA. THANKS TO BYE
WEEKS WEEKS BY SIXTY TWO D.
BILLS OUT OF LET'S GO TO. FIVE
MISTER SANTIAGO'S HERE LAST
AUTHOR. SORRY. FILE ITEM.
TWENTY ONE A. B. THIRTEEN
SIXTY. I THINK YOU MISTER IF IT
PLEASES THE COMMITTEE I WOULD
BE BRIEF. THANKS FIRST I'D LIKE
TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE MINUTES
AND THINK YOU'RE STOP WORKING
HARD HARD ON THIS BILL- AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY WOULD ENSURE-
THE PEOPLE HOUSED UNDER THE
PROJECT ROOM KEEP CANNOT
RETURN- TO HOMELESSNESS LOCALS
WOULD HAVE TO DEVELOP A PLAN
OUTLINING HOW THEY WOULD MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE CONTINUE TO BE
HOUSED. AND I HAVE ONE WITNESS
WILL ALSO BE BRIEF CHAT DAHLE
FROM A SKID ROW HOUSING TRUST-
THANK YOU MISTER CHIP LONG AS A
PERCENT. LET'S NOT GO. TO YOUR
WITNESS MISTER JOY.
CHARGER
WHAT IS ONLINE I BELIEVE THEY
WERE BUT THE COMMITTEE SHOULD
CHOOSE TO MOVE FORWARD OKAY
WANNA WE MOVE FORWARD LET US
NOW GO TO THE OPPOSITION OF MR
GALLAGHER FROM C. SACK. JOSH
DUGGAR REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES I'LL BE COVERING
COMMENTS FOR MY CALL JEAN HURST
AS WELL. AND STATE TIME
INCORPORATING THE COMMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUES AT THE URBAN
TOWNS CALIFORNIA THE WILL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION.
OUR OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
THIRTEEN SIXTY IS MORE ROOTED
IN FISCALAND PRACTICAL
CONCERNS IN GENERAL POLICY.
BURKE COUNTY THE AGREE WITH
VALUE AND SHARING THE GOAL OF
CONTINUING HOUSE OR SHELTER
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS THAT
HAVE ACCESS EMERGENCY PROJECT
BRINGS YOU SITE. BOB READING
THE SITE. AND ACTUALLY ENSURING
THAT NO ONE RETURNS THE
HOMELESSNESS COMES WITH
CONSIDERABLE CHALLENGES AND
PRACTICAL IMPEDIMENTS. AT THE
EARLY STAGES OF THE PANDEMIC
CHINESE WILLINGLY RESPONDED TO
THE CALL FOR ACTION TO
ESTABLISH PROJECT WHEN HE SITES
ON AN EMERGENCY BASIS. WE DID
WE DID THAT DESPITE A POLITICAL
OUTLOOK OVERWHELMING COMPUTED
PROPERTIES AND SIGNIFICANT
COMMUNITY HURDLE THAT TRACK.
LAKE COUNTY DID IT BECAUSE IT
MADE SNSE TO OVERCOME THOSE
OBSTACLES TO BRING HOMELESS
CALIFORNIANS INDOORS TO PROTECT
THEM AGAINST THE SPREAD OF
COMPANY NINETEEN. HOWEVER ALL
THESE PROJECTS ARE FINANCED
WITH ONE TIME OR LIMITED FUND
SOURCES. THROUGHOUT THE PROJECT
COUNTY HAVE LOOKED TO IT
HAPPENS MERGING PIECE UP
LIMINAL STATE FUNDS AND
DECLINING LOCAL FUND SOURCES.
AND WHILE THIS IS TAKING A
REIMBURSABLE PROGRAM THAT
PROCESS IS GOING TO BE KIND
LIMITED AND ONLY COVERS
ELIGIBLE **** AND POPULATIONS
WHICH IS NOT THE ENTIRETY OF
LOCAL COSTS BEING INCURRED TO
CONTINUE THESE PROJECTS. SO WE
SHARE THE AUTHORS GOAL OF
ENSURING. THATINVESTMENTS IN
PROJECT ROOM HE HAD A
MEANINGFUL LASTING IMPACT ON
CALIFORNIA'S HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS HOWEVER WE MUST
ACKNOWLEDGE ONGOING INVESTMENT
OF RESOURCES THAT WILL BE
REQUIRED TO MAKE THAT GOAL A
REALITY. IN THE PRACTICAL
IMPEDIMENTS TO ENSURING AN
INDIVIDUAL AN INDIVIDUAL DOES
NOT RETURN HOMELESSNESS UPON
LEAVING THE SITE. AS A RESULT
WE MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE.
EIGHTY THIRTEEN SIXTY THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE ONE OTHER. AND
OPPOSITION. JEAN HURST- YES WE
COULD SPEAK OF A BOTH OF THEM-
OTHERS WITNESSES ALSO OF TO
PLEASE THE CHAIR OKAY WHEN WE
GO TO THE FIRST SUPPORT WITNESS.
FOR EITHER SPORT WITNESS. HI MY
NAME IS KEPT AWAY AND I'M THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF ADVANCEMENT
WITH SKID ROW HOUSING TRUST AND
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
AND FOR ENTERTAINING AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY. AND WE
ABSOLUTELY SHARED AT THE
AUTHORS BELIEVE THAT- IT WOULD
BE A TRAVESTY AND FOR THE FOLKS
WHO WERE IDENTIFIED AS- THE
OLDEST MOST VULNERABLE MOST
LIKELY TO DIE ON THE STREETS
AND HAVE BEEN HOUSE TO PROJECT
ROOM KEY. AND TO FIND
THEMSELVES WITH NO EXIT AT THE
TERMINATION OF THE AS A FEMALE
FUNDING. AND BELIEVE THAT IT IS
INCUMBENT UPON LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES TO PURSUE. EVERY
AVENUE AVAILABLE TO THEM TO
ENSURE THAT THIS POPULATION IN
PARTICULAR REMAIN HOUSED AND-
AFTER HAVING CHEST HAS. AND
OPERATED PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING FOR FOLKS EXPERIENCE
CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS FOR THE
LAST THIRTY TWO YEARS. WE
OPERATE TWENTY NINE BUILDINGS
AND SERVE OVER TWO THOUSAND
RESIDENTS. AND WE KNOW FIRST
HAND HOW DIFFICULT AND COMPLEX
ARRANGING THESE FUNDING STREAMS
AND SYSTEMS CAN BE WE ALSO KNOW
HOW CRITICAL IT IS. ONE OF OUR
WIDELY KNOWN. DEVELOPMENTS AD
THAT WAS GROUNDBREAKING AT THE
TIME IS THE CHARLES COBB
APARTMENT. AND AT THE POINT IT
WAS DEVELOPED. THE COUNTY YOU
HAD FIRST BECOME INTERESTED IN
IDENTIFYING THE FIFTY PEOPLE
MOST LIKELY TO DIE ON THE
STREETS OF SKID ROW. AND
HELPING THEM AND YOU KNOW WE-
DELIVERED THE CHILD POP UP TO
ANSWER THAT CALL. AND WHO ARE
STRIVING IN HOUSING AND WE
UNDERSTAND DIFFICULTIES AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
AS- IDENTIFYING FUNDING
SOLUTIONS AND OVERCOMING THE
OPPOSITION AND TO BUILD FULL
CONSENSUS WILL REQUIRE THAT THE
URGENCY OF THIS MATTER CANNOT
BE OVERSTATED. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE OUR
POSITION IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY GREAT THANK YOU
LET'S NOW GO TO MEMBERS. OF THE
PUBLIC IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION TO THE. BILL. ZERO
AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT OF
AB. THIRTEEN SIXTY. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE ONE IN OUR QUEUE
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF FOUR NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS RANDY MARTIN
ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION AND
HEALTHY HOUSING FOUNDATION
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CURRENTLY NO OTHERS IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE. IS THERE
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
TO THE OPERATOR. LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION.
THERE'S ONE IN THE QUEUE.
BORDERLINE FOR THIRTY SEVEN OR
THIRTY SEVEN DO YOU HAVE THAT.
GOOD EVENING CHAIR NUMBERS
EVERYBODY WITH THE COUNTY BEING
EVER HAUL TRACTOR THE
TECHNICIAN AND OPPOSITION
ONLINE YOU WITH THE COMMENTS
FROM FEEDBACK THANK YOU. THANK
YOU LET'S BRING BACK TO
COMMITTEE MOTION MOVE FORWARD.
THEIR SECOND RIGHT- S. THE
AUTHORITY FOR THE COMETS. I
WILL BE BRIEF IN THE
COMMITTEE'S INTEREST I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU YOU'VE ACCEPTED THE
MINUTES- YES IF I DIDN'T
ALREADY SAY THAT EXCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS AND THANK YOU FOR
HELPING US GET THERE GREAT
MADAM SECRETARY. MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS TRUE FIVE TWO
FIVE THEY ARE DON'T KNOW. YOU
KNOW GABRIELLE. I KALRA. KALRA
AYE KILEY. NO HEY NO WARD. WARD
I QUICKSILVER COOK SILVA I
WEEKS. ONE TWO THREE FOUR FIVE
TWO TWO. THAT'S OUT LET'S GO
NOW I THINK AT THIS MOMENT WE
JUST HAVE BILLS THAT DIFFER
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE WILL
BE PRESENTING LET'S NOW FINALLY
GO TO OUR COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE
COUNTY. FILE ITEM. FOR EIGHTY
THREE SIXTY TWO. THE BILL.
CFAST YOU CAN DO IT. LIGHTS TO
CATCH. ALL RIGHT WELL WE'RE AT
THE SEVENTH INNING STRETCH
SPEAK YOU KNOW SPORTS METAPHORS.
AND WHAT IS THE STUFF ABOUT
AARON RODGERS NOT LIKE IN THE
PACKAGE- SORRY HERE OUT OKAY.
ALL RIGHT. SO I AM PLEASED TO
BE HERE TO NIGHT TO PRESENT AB
THREE SIXTY TWO AND I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR HARD WORK AND WE WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. THIS BILL WILL
ENSURE MINIMUM HEALTH AND
SAFETY STANDARDS THAT ARE
FOLLOWED BY SHELTER OPERATORS
AND TO KEEP IT SHORT AND SIMPLE
FRIENDS WE KNOW THAT LIVING IN
A SHELTER IS NOT A HOME. AND WE
KNOW THAT THESE EMERGENCY
SHELTERS HAVE BEEN UP PUT UP BY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND COUNTIES.
BECAUSE OF THE NEED BUT BECAUSE
SOMEONE IS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS DOES NOT MEAN THAT
THEY SHOULD BE LIVING IN
CONDITIONS THAT CAN PUT THEM AT
RISK OF NOT ONLY FOR HEALTH
RISKS- BUT OTHER UNSANITARY
CONDITIONS. THAT THERE HAVE
BEEN CASES OF. INCLUDING BAD
BUG INVADES INFESTATIONS.
EXTREME TEMPERATURES. SHOULD BE
SHOWERS AND TOILETS NOT WORKING.
SO SIMPLY THIS WOULD OFFER SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY AND I WILL LEAVE
IT AT THAT AS I BELIEVE WE HAVE
A WITNESS ON THE PHONE. REALLY
WE HAVE A GUERO- WITH THE
SENIOR HOMELESSNESS POLICY WITH
THE ACLU. LET'S GO NOW TO
WITNESS. THANK YOU. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. I AM EVE GARROW
A POLICY ANALYST AND ADVOCATE
FOR THE ACLU OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IT DONG BUT IF THAT
FAILS. TO END THE HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS WE KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA
MUST EXPAND ACCESS TO PERMANENT
SUBSIDIZED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
TO ALL WHO NEED IT INTEL
CALIFORNIA CAN MEET THIS GOAL
HOWEVER WE MUST ENSURE THAT
HOMELESS SHELTERS WHICH ARE
OFTEN THE ONLY ALTERNATIVE FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE DISPLACED FROM
THEIR HOUSE B. R. STATE PLACES
TO LIVE. MY YEAR LONG
INVESTIGATION OF SEVERAL
HOMELESS SHELTERS IN ORANGE
COUNTY FOUNDED SHELTERS INSTEAD
OFTEN EXPOSE RESIDENTS TO
CONDITIONS IN FLAGRANT
DISREGARD OF THEIR HELP AND
WEALTHY ONE SHELTER I
INVESTIGATED WHAT IN AN OPEN
AIR CONVERTED BOTH TERMINAL
PEOPLE ARE SOMETIMES EXPOSED TO
WIND AND RAIN THERE WAS NO
TEMPERATURE CONTROL AND
RESIDENTS SUFFERED FROM
EXPOSURE. TO EXTREME HEAT.
SHOWERS ARE RANK. LEAD BLOCK Y.
AND WE'RE SOMETIME BROKEN WEEKS.
TOILETS WERE OFTEN BROKEN AND
OVERFLOWING WITH HUMAN WASTE.
IT'S A STATION WAGON BERMAN IN
IN FACT WERE COMMON I
INVESTIGATED SHELTERS IN PLACES
LIKE CONVERTED WAREHOUSES. THAT
WERE ALSO IN THE STATE SUCH
CONDITIONS TURN SHELTERS INTO A
BREEDING GROUND FOR THE
TRANSMISSION OF DISEASE AND PUT
ALREADY VULNERABLE RESIDENTS AT
IMMINENT RISK OF HARM MY
INVESTIGATION ALONG WITH OTHER
EXPOSES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
INDICATE THAT UNSAFE AND
UNSANITARY SHELTER CONDITIONS
CAN HAPPEN ANYWHERE. AB THREE
SIXTY TWO WOULD FOR THE FIRST
TIME ADDRESSED THIS PROBLEM BY
ESTABLISHING UNIFORM AND
ENFORCEABLE HEALTH AND SAFETY
STANDARDS FOR HOMELESS SHELTERS
IN CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA'S
MOST ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
RESIDENTS MANY OF WHOM ARE
OLDER ADULTS PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND OTHER
VULNERABLE PEOPLE DESERVES TO
BE TREATED WTH DIGNITY THESE
PROTECTIONS ARE ESSENTIAL TO
ENSURING THEIR HEALTH AND
SAFETY AND THEY ARE LONGER FOR
DEAL WITH THAT I ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT AB. THREE
SIXTY TWO THANK YOU. THERE ARE
NO OTHER WITNESSES- TO TESTIFY
SO NOW LET'S GO TO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC I DON'T SEE ANYONE
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM. C.
KNOWN IN THE REMOTE STATION TO
THE OPERATOR COULD YOU PLEASE
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
SUPPORTERS OF AB THREE SIXTY
TWO IF YOU COULD JUST AGAIN
INDICATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
THE FACT THE SUPPORT.
ABSOLUTELY AND IF YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE SIXTY TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT. WE DO A FOR INNER Q.
WE'LL START WITH NUMBER FOUR
NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS YOUR MEMBERS RANDY
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION THAT'S
HEALTHY HOUSING FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. SIX WILL GO
TO NUMBER THREE EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHE STRAPPED
ON HER SMALL THE HAPPENED
HOUSING CALIFORNIANS SUPPORTED
A. B. C. SIXTY TWO THANK YOU.
NEXT WE NUMBER TWO FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
EXCEPT THAT WE HAVE SEPARATE
BUT I THANK YOU. FOR THANKS IS
NUMBER FOUR NINETY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
CALLIE RATHER I'M WITH STRONGER
WOMEN UNITED ORANGE COUNTY I AM
STRONGLY IN FAVOR OF AB THREE
SIX TWO THANK YOU. CURRENTLY NO
OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE FOR SUPPORT
PLEASE CONTINUE LET'S NOT GO TO
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO REGISTER
OPPOSITION PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINE. INOCULATE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AB THREE SIXTY TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. CAN ONE
ZERO FOR OPPOSITION AB. THREE
SIXTY TWO. WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYBODY IN OUR QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE TO BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS. OUR
MOTION TO MOVE FORWARD AS A
MOTION A SECOND. TO THE AUTHOR
ANY FINAL COMMENTS. AND AGAIN I
DO APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT ON
THIS I WOULD JUST ADD THAT IN
NO WAY AM I TRYING TO. MAKE A
FIRE EMERGENCY SHELTERS UP
PLACE- THAT SOME COULD CALL A
HOTEL EXPERIENCE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT BASIC DIGNITY AND BASIC
SANITARY CONDITIONS THAT- IF WE
ARE OPERATING THE SHELTERS WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO EXPECT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE MADAM SECRETARY. MOTION
NEED TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS CHIU HI CHIU I
SEE OUR JOB NOW YOU KNOW
GABRIELLE GABBY ALLY KALRA
KALRA AYE KILEY. KILEY NO WARD.
WART I COOK SILVA. HI KIRK
SILVA I WICKS WICKS I SIXTY TWO
YOUR BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM FIVE
AB TEN NINETY ENJOYS A- TO PASS
WORK ON BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE.
AND I WILL KEEP IT AS SIMPLE
THIS IS AB TEN NINETY WHICH
WOULD. WHICH WOULD CREATE- THE
A TASK FORCE THAT WOULD FOCUS
ON A CALIFORNIA MASTER PLAN OF
HOME. BUT SOME OF US WHO ARE A
LITTLE BIT OLDER HERE- WOULD
KNOW THAT HOMEOWNERSHIP HAS
JUST GONE DOWN FOR NOT ONLY MY
CHILDREN MY AGE OR YOUNG ADULTS
BUT CONTINUES TO GO DOWN AND
THIS WOULD BE AN EFFORT. TO
WORK WITH PARTNERS INCLUDING
THE BUILDING TRADES- TO SEEK A
PLAN SO THAT WE CAN
CONSISTENTLY IMPROVE THOSE
KNOWN NUMBERS OF HOME OWNERSHIP.
LET'S GO TO YOUR MAIN WITNESS
SILVIA AT WE ARE WITH THE. TWO
HUNDRED. AGAIN WE'D APPRECIATE
A SHORT PRESIDENT. YES HI GOOD
EVENING- CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS SYLVIA AGUILAR AND I
AM THE MANAGING DIRECTOR OF THE
TWO HUNDRED- I FEEL RIGHT I
THINK YOU CAN COALITION FOCUSED
ON INCREASING HOMEOWNERSHIP AS
A MEANS OF CLOSING THE RACIAL
WEALTH GAP FOR MINORITIES
MILLENNIALS AND GENERATION Z.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO ADDRESS YOU AND TO EXPRESS
OUR COALITION SUPPORT FOR A BI.
TEN NINETY AND COMMAND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CORP SILVA FOR AUTHORING
THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION THAT
WILL CREATE A HOMEOWNERSHIP
TASK FORCE CONSISTING OF
MEMBERS FROM DIVERSE
BACKGROUNDS AND INTERESTS FROM
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
HOMEOWNERSHIP IS THE PRIMARY
WAY FOR FAMILIES TO BUILD
WEALTH IN THIS COUNTRY AND
HELPED BUILD THE GREAT MIDDLE
CLASS THAT EMERGED IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE TWENTIETH
CENTURY. AND ALKALI TRANSLATION
STATE HOMEOWNERSHIP IS THE
GATEWAY TO ECONOMIC SECURITY
AND INTERGENERATIONAL WEALTH.
IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A SEVERE
HOUSING CRISIS AND THE VICTIMS
OF THE HOUSING CRISIS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY MEMBERS OF
BLACK. NOT NEXT NATIVE AMERICAN
AND ASIAN AMERICAN COMMUNITIES
AS WELL AS MILLENNIALS AND
YOUNGER CALIFORNIANS OF ALL
RACES. THESE GROUPS FACE
SIMILAR EXCLUSION AND OBSTACLES
TO HOMEOWNERSHIP AND THEY ARE
THE FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY AND WE BELIEVE GIVING
THEM PATHWAYS TO HOMEOWNERSHIP
IT'S CRITICAL FOR A VIBRANT AND
EQUITABLE STATE. CALIFORNIA HAS
THE LOWEST HOMEOWNERSHIP RATE
IN THE COUNTRY SO CLOSING THIS
HOMEOWNERSHIP GAP IS ESSENTIAL
TO CLOSING THE GENERATIONAL AND
RACIAL WEALTH GAP IN OUR STATE
AND THAT IS WHY THE CREATION OF
THE TASK FORCE WILL BE
COMMITTED TO ADDRESSING
BARRIERS AND DISPARITIES TO
MAKE EQUITY AND HOUSING AND
ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE HOMES A
REALITY FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
WE RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR A BI. TEN NINETY
THANK YOU THANK YOU THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION WITNESS LET'S GO O
PUBLIC COMMENT N ONE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM NO ONE IN THE
REMOTE STATIONS TO THE OPERATOR
IF YOU COULD PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR ANY MEMBER THE
PUBLIC. THEIR WISHES TO
REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT.
HANDMAIDEN JIM IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN
NINETY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR
SUPPORT AB TEN NINETY. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE FOUR IN OUR
QUEUE. WILL BEGIN WITH NUMBER
FOUR NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I MEDICARE THIS IS HOLLY FOR
MANY DECADES THIS IS LIKE A
PUBLIC AFFAIR CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL ON BEHALF
OF THE SAN FRANCISCO PLANNING
AND URBAN RESEARCH INSTITUTE
ALSO KNOWN AS BURKE AS WELL AS
HABITAT. FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIA. XV NUMBERFOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING THIS IS MANY YEARS
REPRESENTING THE- CALIFORNIA
HISPANIC CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
I'M VERY PROUD CO SPONSOR IN
VERY MUCH THE SUPPORT. NEXUS
NUMBER FIVE OH TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS SPEAKERS INCREASE
CHARGES ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
FLORIDA ACTION FUND IN SUPPORT
OF AB TEN NINETY THANK YOU. AND
WILL CUT IN LINE FIVE OH THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD- GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS-
MICHAEL GUNNING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT- BABY
TEN NINETY AND WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR. AND AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE LET ME ASK IF
THERE ARE ANY MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC THE WISH TO. REGISTER
OPPOSITION PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES. FOUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO A. B. TEN NINETY
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO.
AND WE HAVE NO COMMENTS COMING
THROUGH AT THE TIME. BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND ANY
COMMENTS MISTER KILEY. I'M FOR
DOING HAVE TO OPPOSE THIS- YOU
KNOW I CAN TELL YOU RIGHT NOW
BEFORE WE HAVE THE RESULTS OF
THE STUDY SORT OF WHAT THE MAIN
FINDING SHOULD BE WHICH THE WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH HOUSES. AND
YOU KNOW THE CAUSES OF THAT ARE
ARE PRETTY WELL UNDERSTOOD AN
ABUNDANCE OF STUDIES DONE. ON
THAT SO I THINK THAT YOU KNOW
WHAT'S BEEN MISSING IS THE
POLITICAL WILL TO ACTUALLY
BUILD MORE HOUSES AND I JUST
DON'T SEE HOW. OUT ORDERING UP
ANOTHER STUDY IS GOING TO
SUPPLY DOT. ANY OTHER COMMENTS
TO THE AUTHOR. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE MADAM
SECRETARY. MOTION IS TO PASS
THROUGH- ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS TRUE HI CHIU I
SAY ARE TOO HIGH C. R. I.
GABRIEL GABRIEL I KALRA KALRA
AYE KILEY KILEY NO WORD FOR
DIET COKE SILVA HI FOLKS SILVA
I WEEKS. WEEKS I. SEVENTY ONE
HERE ITEMS OUT TO INTERNET OKAY
UP COLLEAGUES BEFORE WE HEAR
FROM MISTER WARD. IF WE COULD
GO THROUGH AND I'LL ASK MADAM
SECRETARY GO THROUGH THE ROLE
MR GABRIEL FORTUNE HAS TO GO TO
THE AIRPORT I WANNA MAKE SURE
HE CAN ADD ON TO THE ITEMS THAT
WE HAVE ALREADY- REGISTERED
MOTIONS FOR. SO IF YOU WANT TO
JUST START FROM THE TOP. AND I
CAN I CAN GO THROUGH THE
FOLLOWER BUT MAYBE START WITH
THE CONSENT HAVE YOU VOTE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. LET'S
JUST LET'S LET'S LET'S GO
THROUGH WHAT WE HAVE ARE GOING
ON SO WITH THE CONSENT COUNTER.
FOR REAL. TIME. FOR FOUR ZERO
FIVE FOUR FIVE EIGHT FIVE.
EIGHT ZERO OKAY- FILE ITEM ONE.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. FILE
ITEM TO. RIGHT THAT WAS AB
SEVENTY ONE A. B. OKAY FILE
ITEM TO AB TEN FORTY THREE. YOU
YEAH. WE ARE CALLING THANK YOU.
THIS IS THIS IS YOUR MY OFFICE
HOURS A SEPARATE GABRIELLE-
THAT NIGHT AND WAKES I KNOW
WILL BE SIXTY TWO FOLLOWING
THREE AB. TWELVE TWENTY. A
MEMBER GABRIELLE. CAMBRIA I
WICKS WICKS I EIGHT TWO ZERO I
THINK WE'VE DONE MOST OF THESE
BUT FILE ITEM FOR EIGHTY THREE
SIXTY TWO AND A HALF SO MEMBERS
TO- NUMBER FIVE SEVEN TWO ONE
THAT'S TAKEN CARE OF WOULD HAVE
BEEN- THE- OUR THIS IS ITEM
NUMBER NINE OKAY LET'S GO TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE EIGHTY
FIVE- TO CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS SAID NEVER GABRIEL
GABRIEL I. SENT HER KALRA.
COLOR I WICKS WICKS I WILL BE
EIGHT TWO ZERO FILE ITEM ELEVEN
AB SIX OH TWO GRAYSON. I HAVE
THIRTIES BUT- SEVEN TWO ZERO
ZERO ONE AND VOTING SO IT'S-
DONE OKAY FILE ITEM TWELVE AB
SEVEN FIFTY THREE GREAT SIXTY
TWO IT'S- I WOULD- SURE. WE
HAVE NOT WITH MICHAEL FALLON
TENURE I'M GOING THROUGH THE
ITEMS THAT WE'VE ALREADY
ENTERTAINED MOTIONS FOR. HAVE.
OKAY FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AB
ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE GRAYSON I
KNOW WANT TO ADD THAT IS OUT
EIGHT TWO ZERO FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN AB ELEVEN A. ONE FOR
ONE- Q. I. Q. I- GABRIEL
GABRIEL I WEEKS WEEKS I. IT'S
GOT A SEVENTY SEVEN TWO ZERO
LET'S GO TO FILE ITEM NINETEEN
AB. THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO. ARE
THERE IS OUT THERE SIXTY TWO.
NO AS A MEMBER OF SIXTY TWO
FILE ITEM TWENTY THIRTEEN
TWENTY NINE AS YOU'RE IN YES-
FORTY ONE- SAID MEMBER SAY ARCO
NOW THEY ARE TO KNOW. OF KALRA.
YES THERE IS. KALRA I WICKS
WICKS I WOULD BE- SIX TWO TWO
FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE A. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY. SEPTEMBER WEEKS.
MY WEEKS I SIX TWO TWO FILE
ITEM TWENTY TWO EIGHTY FOURTEEN
A ONE SEVEN MEMBER GABRIEL
GABRIEL I SEVERAL WEEKS I AND
SEVEN TWO ONE FILE ITEM TWENTY
FOUR AB FOURTEEN NINETY TWO-
SONORA KILEY. KILEY NO FOSTER
MEDICALLY ACCEPT QUICK SILVA
RIGHT HI I WILL BE SIXTY TWO
RIGHT I THINK THAT CATCHES UP
TO WHERE WE ARE AND WITHOUT
WATER WE NOW GO TO MR WORDS
ITEMS- YOUR PLEASURE WHICH ITEM
YOU LIKE TO TAKE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BEGIN WITH A
NUMBER. SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED.
THANK YOU I'M FOR THE MOVE IN
THE SECOND SO BRIEFLY I EIGHTY
USE IN SUPPORT OF HOUSING CAN
PROVIDE SOLUTIONS TO HELP THE
CURRENT HOUSING CRISIS FOR
MIDDLE AND LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. YET THERE UNDER
UTILIZING THE COASTAL ZONE IN
PART DUE TO THE TIME INTENSIVE
COASTAL DEVELOPMENT PERMIT
RECEIPT IF YOU PROCESS. THE
LEGISLATURE AND THIS COMMITTEE
HAS IN RECENT YEARS
SUCCESSFULLY PASS LAWS TO
STREAMLINE THE DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS THESE FOR EIGHTY YEARS
IN SUPPORT OF HOUSING. HOWEVER
WHILE THE HOOK DOES HELP CITIES
THEY DID NOT EXTEND TO SEE PEAS
WHICH ARE A STATE PROCESS THIS
BILL ADDRESSES THAT. THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL COMMISSION
HAS TAKEN STEPS TO CLARIFY THE
REGULATORY PROCESS FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO ADOPT HOWEVER
IT IS NOT EXPRESSLY WITHIN THE
COMMISSION SCOPE TO PROMOTE
SOLUTIONS. IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
ONE FORTY YEARS AGO WITH THE
OPPOSITION FROM THE COMMISSION
THE LEGISLATURE AMENDED THE
COASTAL ACT TO REMOVE LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME HOUSING
POLICIES FROM ITS JURISDICTION.
THIS BILL REINSTATE THOSE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING POLICIES
REPEALED TO GIVE THE COMMISSION
THE AUTHORITY TO PROTECT
EXISTING AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
ENSURE THAT NEW AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IS CONSISTENT WITH
COASTAL ACT POLICIES. THIS WILL
PROVIDE NEW HOUSING SOLUTIONS
AND ENSURE THAT NOT JUST
VISITORS SERVING ACCOMMODATIONS
BUT ALSO RESIDENTIAL ACCESS TO
THE COAST IS BETTER AFFORDED TO
ALL CALIFORNIANS. LIKE TO
PRESENT MY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL SARAH CHRISTIE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA COASTAL
COMMISSION AND BILL PRINCE
LOOKING FROM THE PEOPLE
ORGANIZED FOR WESTSIDE RENEWAL
OR POWER. TO THE OPERATOR IF
YOU COULD PLEASE. ALLOW SIR
CHRISTY FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION SPEAK. AS
WELL AS BILL. I WILL NOT TRY TO
PRONOUNCE THAT BRIDGES LOOKING.
FROM PEOPLE ORGANIZED. TO THE
OPERATOR. DIRECTOR I'M HERE
TODAY REPRESENTING THE
COMMISSION'S UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
OF AB FIVE HUNDRED. IT WOULD
RESTORE THE CALL SELECT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING POLICIES AND
REPEAL THE PROHIBITION ON LCVPS
WOULD ALSO ALLOW THE COMMISSION
TO PROVIDE FOR GREATER
RESIDENTIAL DENSITY IN AREAS
WITH ADEQUATE TRANSIT THAT ARE
NOT SUBJECT TO CIVIL RIGHTS.
FINALLY IT WOULD REQUIRE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO UPDATE L. C.
PIECE TO REFLECT RECENT CHANGES
TO AID YOU IN SUPPORT OF
HOUSING LAWS SOMETHING THE
COMMISSION HAS BEEN
RECOMMENDING SINCE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. MEMBERS THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO UNDO THE
MISTAKES OF THE PAST AND
RESTORE THE COSTA LACKS
ORIGINAL INTENT OF THE
COASTLINE THAT'S NOT ONLY
ACCESSIBLE BUT ALSO LIVABLE FOR
ALL I'VE TRUNCATED MY TESTIMONY
BUT I'M AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU TO
THE NEXT WITNESS. HELLO THE
BILL GROWTH LIKELY FROM PEOPLE
ORGANIZED FOR WESTSIDE RENEWAL.
I'M GETTING AN ECHO ON MY BUT
ARE YOU HEARING THAT WE HEAR
YOU. OKAY BASED OVERLOOKED. OUR
WORK IN THE ORGANIZING GROUP
THAT HAS WORKED IN THE COASTAL
TOWN IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE
GIVE OUT BUT THANKS BYE BYE
MORE FROM THE SENATE SANTA
MONICA IT OPERATES VERY. WE
REPRESENT LOW MODERATE INCOME
FAMILIES WHO HAVE BEEN FIGHTING
TO CREATE AND PRESERVE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SINCE OUR
ORGANIZATION'S FOUNDING. WE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO CREATE OVER A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS WORTH
OF NEW LOW INCOME HOUSING. IN
THE COASTAL ZONE. AS WELL AS
FIGHTING TO PRESERVE THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT WE HAVE
NOW. INCLUDING A TWO HUNDRED
AND FORTY SIX UNIT. OBJECT
BASED SECTION EIGHT.
DEVELOPMENT INDEPENDENCE ALL
WITHIN ONE MILE OF THE BEACH AT
THE ANCHOR OF RACIAL AND
ECONOMIC DIVERSITY IN BETTER
AND BETTER. YOUR CRITICAL THAT
THE BECAUSE THE COMMISSION
REGAINED THE ABILITY TO
ACTIVELY PROMOTE. A PORTABLE
HOUSING IN THE COASTAL ZONE OUR
MEMBERS TESTIFY REGULARLY AT
THE COASTAL COMMISSION WE KNOW
THAT THE COUNCIL COMMISSIONERS
SUPPORT FOR OUR MEMBERS
PARTICIPATION AND SUPPORT BUT
BASIC CONCEPT. ALONE MODERATING
PEOPLE HAVE TO ACT THAT CAN
BOTH VISIT AND LIVE ON THE
COAST. HOWEVER IT IS EXTREMELY
CHALLENGING BECAUSE THE COULD
NOT GET THE COMMISSIONER. KNOW
OUR MEMBERS CAN EXPLICITLY TALK
ABOUT HOUSING AFFORDABILITY.
EVEN THOUGH THAT IS THE MAIN
REASON OUR MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING COASTAL
COMMISSION HERE. PLEASE PASSED
SB FIVE HUNDRED- I AM AVAILABLE
FOR QUESTIONS. THANK YOU AT
THIS POINT THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION WITNESS LET'S GO TO.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THEY WISH
TO REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION SEEN KNOWN IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM KNOWING THE
REMOTE STATIONS TO THE OPERATOR
IF YOU COULD PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR ANY SUPPORTERS OF
THIS BILL. FOUR COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE HUNDRED
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE SEVEN
ZERO. THE END OF THE LINE FOUR
HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE YEAR MIKE
IS OPEN. LINE FOUR HUNDRED
SEVENTY NINE YEAR MIKE IS OPEN.
LINE FIVE HUNDRED FOR YOUR MY
COULD OPEN. ANYTHING CHAIR
NUMBERS I THINK ANY GIRL ON
BEHALF OF WITH THE WALL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LIVE FIVE
HUNDRED FIVE YEAR MIKE IS OPEN.
I'M ROBIN RUSSO I AM AN ELECTED
CITY OF LOS ANGELES
NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCIL OFFICIAL
AND OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
I'VE CHAIRED BOTH THE BENEFITS
AND THE SAN PEDRO LANDED
COMMITTEES AND THAT'S EXTENSIVE
ON THE GROUND EXPERIENCE WITH
CULTURE PROJECTS AND IT'S
MAKING TODAY ON BEHALF OF
CITIZENS PRESERVING VENICE. IN
LOS ANGELES. PLEASE SUPPORT
EIGHTY FIVE HUNDRED AS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS
DESIGNATED BY STATE LAW AT THE
COASTAL RESORTS IN THE COASTAL
COMMISSION MUST BE ABLE TO DO
THEIR JOB AND PROTECT IT JUST
LIKE ANY OTHER CALLS. THE
REPORT THANK YOU. AN OUTLINE.
FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND FOUR
HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. IN. FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHTY FIVE. TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE YEAR MIKE
IS OPEN. AND. FIVE HUNDRED
SEVEN. HELLO THIS IS SUPERVISOR
MIKE WILSON FROM HUMBOLDT
COUNTY I'M ALSO ON THE NUMBER
OF THE CALLS COMMISSION I JUST
WANT TO SAY I'M IN FULL SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL ARE WE REALLY NEED
THIS- I HELPED TO BRING
PORTABLE HOUSING AND ACTUALLY
PROTECT HOUSING THAT WE ALREADY
HAVE IN THE CULTISM THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THE WIND OF.
FIVE HUNDRED SIX. HELLO MY NAME
IS MARYANN DAR I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
BOLINAS COMMUNITY LAND TRUST IN
BOLINAS CALIFORNIA WERE IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ORGANIZATION
AND SUPPORT AB FIVE HUNDRED- WE
REALLY NEED THAT ARE TO GET
PERMITTED TO DO ANYTHING OUT
HERE IS IMPOSSIBLE AND THIS
BILL IS ESSENTIAL FOR OUR
ENTIRE COMMUNITY IS WITHIN THE
COASTAL ZONE. AND IN ORDER TO
HAVE AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE HAVE
TO HAVE THIS BILL PASSED THANK
YOU SO MUCH. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THE TIME.
LET'S NOW GO TO ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC THE WISH TO REGISTER
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. FOUR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO IT AB
FIVE HUNDRED PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE ZERO. AND LIFE FOUR
HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE YOUR MIKE
IS UP. HI GOOD AFTERNOON SHOULD
BE BORROWED WHILE COUNTY
REPRESENTS THE CALIFORNIA ALSO
REPRESENT THE VIEWS OF HEALTHY
CITIES I WANT TO PROJECT A
POINT FOR OUR LATE LETTER OF
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL WE DO
HAVE SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS- BUT
STILL DISREGARD THE HOUSING
ELEMENT PROCESS AND THEN SAID
ADDING ADDITIONAL BUREAUCRATIC
AGENCY TO ALREADY COMPLEX
PROCESS. INVOLVING ATVS CITIES
AND COUNTIES HOUSING IS RIGHT
RIGHT NEED NOT WITHIN THE
PURVIEW OF THE COASTAL
COMMISSION AND THAT THE FORTY
LIVES WITHIN LOOK FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AB FIVE HUNDRED
CREATE DUPLICATIVE INCONSISTENT
OVERLAPPING AUTHORITY WITH
ANOTHER REGULATORY AGENCY AND
FOR THESE REASONS WE.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND ABOUT
THANK YOU. AND THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THE TIME.
THANK YOU LET'S BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. MS CLARK SILVA.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR I
THINK THIS IS AN EXCELLENT BILL
AND IT REALLY STICKS WITH THE
THEME OF LOOKING AT EXISTING
LAND THAT WE HAVE AND- NOT ONLY
INNOVATION OF JUNIOR EIGHTY USE
EIGHTY USE BUT- THE OTHER
COMMENT I'D LIKE TO BE A JOINT
AUTHORS THANK YOU- BUT I ALSO
DO WANT TO NOTE IS WE HAVE A
BEAUTIFUL CALIFORNIA COAST WITH
WHICH WE KNOW. THE MARKET-
KEEPS MANY MANY PEOPLE FROM
EVER HAVING A DREAM OF
ATTAINING A HOUSE ON THE COAST
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT. BECAUSE
MANY OF OUR WORKERS FROM
HOSPITALITY TO TOURISM WORK IN
THESE AREAS WHETHER IT'S
RESTAURANTS WHETHER IT'S HOTELS
AND MANY OF THEM ARE TRAVELING
SOMETIMES AN HOUR OR EVEN
LONGER THE FRONT LINE WORKERS
THEY DON'T GET TO READ ABOUT
WORK REMOTELY IN THIS IS US. A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION FOR
OPPORTUNITIES TO HOUSE A SOME
OF THE- PEOPLE WHO- COULD ONLY
DREAM OF LIVING IN THE COASTAL
AREA TO ACTUALLY ATTAIN A SMALL
EIGHTY YOU. THANK YOU. BECAUSE
OF. WAS THAT A MOTION TO BEFORE.
OKAY THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND
SECOND ANY FINAL COMMENTS. TO
THE AUTHOR AND PUBLICLY
RESEARCHER EITHER MADAM
SECRETARY. MOTIONS TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS TO HI CHIU I SAY
OUR TOTAL HERE TO KNOW
GABRIELLE RELY KALRA KALRA AYE
KILEY KILEY NO. WORK HIGH COURT
AYE QUICK SILVA HI RICK SILVA I
WICKS I SIXTY TWO BILLS OUT.
FILE ITEM EIGHT EIGHTY NINE
FIFTY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS IN TWENTY NINETEEN
GOVERNOR NEWSOM ORDERED DEPART
DGS AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING CAN YOU DEVELOPMENT TO
IDENTIFY AND PRIORITIZE ACCESS
STATE OWNED PROPERTY AND
AGGRESSIVELY PURSUE SUSTAINABLE
INNOVATIVE AND COST EFFECTIVE
HOUSING PROJECTS HOWEVER
EXISTING LAW REQUIRES THAT WHEN
A CITY OR COUNTY EXPRESSES AN
INTEREST IN PURCHASING THESE
PARCELS AGENCIES LIKE CALTRANS
MUST SELL THE PROPERTY AT
TODAY'S OF FAIR MARKET VALUE
WHICH ADDS ENORMOUS COSTS FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
POSSIBLY MAKING THE FINANCIAL
LIABILITY IMPRACTICAL EIGHTY
NINE FIFTY WOULD AUTHORIZE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
TRANSPORTATION TO SELL EXCESS
PROPERTY TO CITIES AND COUNTIES
FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF LONG
TERM AFFORDABLE HOUSING
EMERGENCY SHELTERS WERE FEEDING
PROGRAMS AT THE PROPERTY'S
ORIGINAL ACQUISITION VALUE TO
SPEAK A LITTLE MORE ABOUT THE
HELP AB FIFTY WOULD PROVIDE I
HAVE DOWNEY YET DANCING
DANIELLE IS FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF TRANSPORTATION AND
CHRISTOPHER LEE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES. LET'S GO TO YOUR MAIN
WITNESSES. MR YOST. HI GOOD
EVENING CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME
IS DANNY YES THE SYSTEM DEPUTY
DIRECTOR LEGISLATION A CALTRANS.
THE BILL THIS YEAR- THE
DEPARTMENT RECENTLY RELEASED A
NEW STRATEGIC PLAN WITH THE
GOAL OF ADVANCING EQUITY
AVAILABILITY AND ALL
COMMUNITIES AS WE WORK TOWARD A
VISION OF ACHIEVING A BRIGHTER
FUTURE FOR ALL AND IT IS
THROUGH THE PLAN THE CALTRANS
RECOGNIZES AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE CITIES AND COUNTIES.
FLEXIBILITY TO ACQUIRE THE LAND
AND PUT IT TO BETTER USE
HELPING OUR COMMUNITY ADDRESS
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS.
IT WILL ALSO ALLOW THE LAND TO
BE USED FOR EMERGENCY SHELTER
THE NAVIGATION CENTERS
PROVIDING SERVICES TO PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. THIS
BILL WILL ENSURE LONG TERM USE
OF THESE PROPERTY FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BY PLACING
FIFTY FIVE YEAR COVENANT ON THE
PROPERTY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND I'M AVAILABLE. TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU LET'S GET OUT
OF LEE FOR C. SACK. GOOD
EVENING CRITICALLY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES ALSO IN
SUPPORT I WOULD THINK THIS IS A
GREAT MEASURE THAT A HELP
EXPEDITE THE ACQUISITION OF
PROPERTY FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
EMERGENCY SHELTERS OR THE
SUPPORT SERVICES THAT ARE
CALLED OUT IN THE BILL- I'LL BE
VERY BRIEF OF MY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS BUT I REALLY THINK-
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY HERE TO.
GET DEVELOPMENT IN AREAS THAT.
DEVELOPERS MIGHT NOT CURRENTLY
BE ACTIVELY INTERESTED IN FOR
INSTANCE IN RURAL COUNTIES IN
UNINCORPORATED AREAS WE'VE SEEN
EVIDENCE THAT SOME OF THE BEST
WAY TO GET INTEREST IT'S FOR
THE COUNTY TO ACQUIRE THE
PROPERTY TO BE ABLE TO BRING
THE RESOURCES THAT THEY HAVE
THEIR DISPOSAL AND THEN WORK
TOGETHER TO ATTRACT DEVELOPER
INTEREST. TO GET THE PROPERTY
DEVELOPED FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SO APPRECIATE THE
CREATIVE APPROACH AND THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE DEPARTMENT
I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THERE
IS NO OPPOSITION LET'S GO TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO STATE SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM.
WILL ACKNOWLEDGE THE FOR
SPEAKER. MARKS DIVERSE THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP-
WE SUPPORT IF AMENDED TO FOCUS
THE BILL ON A LOW INCOME
HOUSING AS OPPOSED TO MODERATE
INCOME HOUSING AND ARE WORKING
WITH THE AUTHORED AND
SPONSORED. ON THAT AND SOME
OTHER TECHNICAL ISSUES THANK
YOU. LET'S NOW GO TO THE REMOTE
STATION. CINEMASCOPE TO THE
PHONE LINES TO THE OPERATOR
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
WISH TO REGISTER SUPPORT. NAME
ORGANIZATION AND THE FACT TO
SUPPORT. FOUR COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINE FIFTY PLEASE
PRESS ONE THE EURO. THE
COMMANDER CAN ONE OF THEM ZERO.
AND WE HAVE NO COMMENTS COMING
THROUGH AT THE TIME. AND ANY
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC THE WISH TO
REGISTER OPPOSITION. FOUR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION. TO
EIGHTY NINE FIFTY PLEASE PRESS
ONE THIRTY ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE ZERO. AND WE DO HAVE
ONE COMMENT COMING THROUGH ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEM WITH THEIR LIVES. IN THAT
LINE TWO HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN
YOU MAKE IT UP. YES HI MY NAME
IS MARCY AGAIN I'M CALLING ON
OPPOSITION TO AB ELEVEN OR ONE
AB ELEVEN OH ONE PLEASE VOTE NO
ON THANK YOU THAT IS RELEVANT
ALL ONE. THEN MEDICARE THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THE
TIME THANK YOU BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND ANY
DISCUSSION. JUST ONE APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR FOR MOVING THIS
FORWARD AND- CALTRANS
WILLINGNESS TO. ENGAGE IN THIS
I KNOW THERE ARE STILL SOME
DETAILS TO BE WORKED OUT BUT-
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
SO THAT YOU CAN HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HOPEFULLY
RESOLVE THEM IN THE NEAR
FUTURE. AND WITHOUT ANY FINAL
COMMENTS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS RESPECTIVELY- PROGRESS
IN EITHER. MADAM SECRETARY.
MOTION TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMEDIAN APPROPRIATIONS TRUE HI
CHIU IC ARE STILL NOT GOING.
FORTY GABRIELLE GABRIEL I KALRA
KALRA AYE KILEY KILEY AYE WARD
AYE WARD AYE COOK SILVA HI
FOLKS SILVA I WEEKS WEEKS I'D.
SEVEN TWO ZERO ONE MEMBER NINE
FORTY. LET'S NOT GO BACK TO
FILE ITEM SIX WHICH IS AB FOUR
NINETY ONE IT'S LORETTA
<c.cyan>ONZALEZ BEING PRESENTED BY OUR</c>
COLLEAGUE MISTER WARD THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY WOMAN GONZALEZ I
WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY THANKING
THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR HELP
AND WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND OUT IT
IS A JOINT AUTHORS. AS THE
STATE CONTINUES TO ENCOURAGE
MORE MIXED INCOME HOUSING
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA WE NEED
TO BE EXPLICITLY CLEAR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING RESIDENTS
ARE NOT TO BE TREATED AS SECOND
CLASS CITIZENS AB FOUR NINE ONE
EXPLICITLY CLARIFIES THAT
RESIDENTS OF AFFORDABLE UNITS
IN A MIXED INCOME MULTI FAMILY
DEVELOPMENT MUST HAVE THE SAME
ACCESS TO COMMON ENTRANCES
AREAS AND AMENITIES AS THE
OCCUPANTS A MARKET RATE UNITS
IN SHORT WE'RE NOT GOING TO
HAVE SOMEBODY GO IN THIS STORE
AND OTHER PEOPLE GO AND DOCTOR
EVERYONE THAT HAS ACCESS TO THE
SAME SPACES ANY COMMON
DEVELOPMENT. WE HAVE A WITNESS-
CREAM DRESSY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS WILL SPEAK IN FAVOR OF
THIS MEASURE THANK YOU AND I'LL
JUST MENTION THAT THIS BILL
ENJOYS AN AYE AYE RECORD FROM
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE. TO OUR
WITNESS MISTER GREASY. YES GOOD
EVENING- MISTER SHARON MEMBERS
KAREEM THREE C. ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS- C. A. R. T. PROUD
SPONSOR OF EIGHTY FOUR NINETY
ONE AND WISHES TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS BILL- HERE TO HELP ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE BEEN RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION LET'S ASK
IF THEY'RE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THE WISH TO STATE.
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION HERE IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM THERE IS NO
ONE AND THE REMOTE STATION
THERE'S NO ONE. ON THE PHONE
LINES OPERATOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WISH TO REGISTER
SUPPORT. FOR COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOUR NINETY ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THE END OF
THE ROW. THAT COMMAND AGAIN.
ONE SEVEN ZERO. THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS COMING THROUGH AT THIS
TIME AND- IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION. OUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO AB OR NINETY ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONCE AGAIN ONE OF THEM ZERO. I
DON'T KNOW COMMENTS COMING
THROUGH AT THIS TIME. BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. THERE'S
BEEN A MOTION AND A SECOND ANY
FINAL COMMENTS RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST- I THOUGHT MADAM
SECRETARY MOTION TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMEDIAN APPROPRIATIONS TRUE HI
TRUE I SAY ARE TOO GREAT BILL
HI C. R. I. GABRIELLE KALRA.
COLOR I'D KILEY. KILEY I WORK I
WORK I WORK SILVA AYE
QUICKSILVER AYE WICKS WICKS I.
SEVEN TWO ZERO GREAT ALL THESE
ARE GETTING CLOSE FIVE MORE
ITEMS FILE ITEM TEN AB FIVE
SIXTY ONE TEAM WILL BE
PRESENTED BY MISS CLARK SILVA.
THEIR SECOND. YOUR SECOND
MISTER KALRA. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES I
AM PRESENTING AB FIVE SIXTY ONE
ON BEHALF OF MY COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM AS AMENDED
AB FIVE SIXTY ONE AUTHORIZES
THE TREASURER'S OFFICE TO
DESIGN AN EIGHTY YOU FINANCING
PROGRAM THAT HAS THE POTENTIAL
TO CREATE FIFTY THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL HOMES OVER FIVE
YEARS BY PROVIDING BRIDGE LOANS
TO HOMEOWNERS WHO DON'T QUALIFY
FOR TRADITIONAL. FINANCING I'LL
JUST TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF
MEMBERS PRIVILEGE HERE OUT WE
ARE DOING EXCELLENT WORK ON A
D. USE AND CREATING MORE ACCESS
BY BUT FINANCING IS VERY
ELUSIVE SO I WILL KEEP IT SHORT
AND ASK FOR THE COMMITTEE
SUPPORT. IF WE CAN NOW GO TO
OUR MAIN WITNESS. MISS KELLY
FALLON FROM THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS KELLY
FALLON AND I AM A SENIOR POLICY
MANAGER AT THE BURY COUNCIL
WHICH IS A PUBLIC POLICY
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTING MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED BURIED PENSIONS BETTER
WE'RE GONNA SOLVE OUR REGION'S
MOST CHALLENGING ISSUES. WE ARE
PROUD SPONSOR OF EIGHTY FIVE
SIXTY ONE WHICH SEEKS TO
ADDRESS ARRIERS THAT REMAIN
FOR HOMEOWNERS TO FINANCE
EIGHTY. PER YEAR COUNCIL
SPONSORED THE FIRST THE
LEGISLATION TO EASE THE
PROFITABLE EIGHTIES IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN SB TEN SIXTY NINE BY
SARAH CASKEY REDUCED PARKING
REQUIREMENTS DISCRETIONARY
PERMITTING AN ONEROUS UTILITY
CONNECTION FEES AND WE DON'T
EIGHTY UNION PEACEFUL FOR MANY
HOMEOWNERS. JUST AS SHE SAID
TEN SIX NINE BECAME LAW WHICH
HE HAS PASSED NUMEROUS LAWS
EASE THE PROCESS TO DON'T USE A
TWENTY TWENTY REPORT BY THE UC
BERKELEY TURNS CENTER FOUND
THAT EIGHTY YOU PERMITS
INCREASE FROM SIX THOUSAND AND
201-821-8000 TWENTY NINETEEN IN
THE SAME PERIOD A NEW
COMPLETIONS INCREASED ROCK
POSSIBLY TWO THOUSAND TO SEVEN
THOUSAND. IS NOTABLE THAT THIS
IS THE ONLY TYPE OF HOUSING
THAT IS CURRENTLY EXPERIENCING
AN INCREASE IN COMMITTEE IN THE
STATE WELL EIGHTY PER MANY
INCOMPLETIONS HAVE EXPANDED
SIGNIFICANTLY A MAJOR BARRIER
RANGE FOR HOMEOWNERS WITH LOWER
INCOME OR FEWER ASSETS THAT ARE
UNABLE TO FINANCE EITHER. TODAY
HOMEOWNERS TYPICALLY FINANCER
EIGHTIES USING EXISTING CASH
SAVINGS HOME EQUITY LOAN OR
REFINANCING THESE OPTIONS ARE
PRIMARILY AVAILABLE TO
HOMEOWNERS OF HIGH INCOME OR
HIGH OWN EQUITY LEAVING LOWER
INCOME HOMEOWNERS WITHOUT
PRINTING OPTIONS WITHOUT MAYBE.
THIS MAKES IT EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT FOR MANY LOW INCOME
HOMEOWNERS AND HOMEOWNERS OF
COLOR TO USE A RECENT UC
BERKELEY CENTER FOR COMMUNITY
INNOVATION STUDY FOUND THAT
EIGHTY OWNERS TEND TO BE MUCH
MORE PLAN ARE LESS LIKELY
IDENTIFIES A PERSON OF COLOR
COMPARED TO THE TYPICAL
CONCRETE HOMEOWNER. AB FIVE
FIFTY ONE ADDRESSES THIS GAP BY
ALLOWING THE TREASURE TO WORK
WITH A BROAD GROUP OF
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING PRIVATE
MORTGAGE LENDERS SIGNIFIES EACH
TV AND HIGH TECH BATES
ESTABLISH AND MINISTER IN
EIGHTY FINANCING PROGRAM. WE'VE
SEEN GREAT POTENTIAL FOR EIGHTY
YEARS TO PROVIDE AFFORDABLE
RENTAL OPTIONS TO CALIFORNIA'S
INTENT CALIFORNIANS AND
GENERATE INCOME FOR HOMEOWNERS.
TO CONTINUE THE SUCCESS ENSURE
THAT ALL HOMEOWNERS ARE ABLE TO
ACCESS IS OPPORTUNITY ARE.
STRICTLY AFTER AYE VOTE THANK
YOU. THERE IS. NO OPPOSITION TO
THE SPELL NOW GO TO PUBLIC.
THERE'S NO ONE COMMITTEE ROOM
THERE'S ONE AFTER MONTHS. TO
THE OP IF YOU PLEASE. ALLOW
INDIVIDUALS AT WHICH TO EXPRESS.
FOR BILL. REGISTER THE SUPPORT.
FOUR COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIVE SIXTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN
ONE ZERO. AND LINES FOUR
HUNDRED NINETY SIX OF MY COULD
OPEN. MISTER CARROLL THE POLY
FOR MEANING I THINK IF THE FLAG
HAVE PUBLIC AFFAIR CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL ON BEHALF
OF THE SAN FRANCISCO PLANNING
AND URBAN RESEARCH ASSOCIATION
ALSO KNOWN AS FOR. THE COUNCIL
OF INFILL BUILDERS CAPITA
COALITION AND HERE YOU PARTNERS
ON SUPPORT. BLINDS. FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY ONE. HI MISTER
MISTER CHER MEMBERS LEWIS BONTA
ON BEHALF CALIFORNIAN BIG ON
SPORTS. THANKS. FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTEEN. GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL GUNNING
WITH THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
LINE. FIVE HUNDRED FOURTEEN.
GOOD EVENING OUT OF CHEN TOOK
WITH THE HOUSING ACTION
COALITION IN SUPPORT. AND LINE.
FIVE HUNDRED TEN. GOOD EVENING
THIS IS BOB NAYLOR FORD DEALS
SEVEN COMPANY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU LET'S SEE IF THEY'RE
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC THEY WISH TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL. SORT COMMENTS
IN OPPOSITION TO IT AB FIVE
SIXTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO. ONCE AGAIN. ONE NINE
ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION
AT THE TIME BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE AS THEIR
PROMOTION. YES THIS MOTION AND
A SECOND. AND WITHOUT BACK TO
THE AUTHOR. JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE MADAM
SECRETARY MOTION TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS TWO FIVE TWO
FIVE THEY ARE JOB GABRIELLE
CHOLERA KALRA AYE KILEY. I'M
LOOKING. WARD BY WARD HI FOLKS
SILVA HI KIRK SILVA I WEEKS
WEEKS BY CITY FOUR FIVE TWO
ZERO SIR. THE MEASURES OUT
LET'S NOT GO TO FILE ITEM
SEVENTEEN A. B. ELEVEN EIGHTY
SIX THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
WANT TO THANK YOU AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR KEEPING THE
STREAK ALIVE- FOR MY RENTAL
REGISTRY BILL- AND THANK YOU
MEMBERS FOR HEARING ME OUT ON
THIS BILL I WANT TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ENSURING
THE PRIVACY OF INDIVIDUALS AND
HOUSEHOLDS IS PROTECTED
INCLUDING THAT PERSONALLY
IDENTIFIABLE INFORMATION. UNDER
EIGHTY ELEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT AND
I ALSO SEE THE AMENDMENT
AMENDMENTS WILL REMOVE
OPPOSITION FROM THE REALTORS
AND THE APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
SO THEY I BELIEVE OR NOT YEAH
NEUTRAL THERE'S BEEN A MOTION
AND A SECOND IN RESPONSE TO
COVER NINETEEN CALIFORNIA NEXT
TO STATEWIDE EVICTION MORE
TRAIN THROUGH AB THIRTY EIGHTY
EIGHT FOR NON PAYMENT OF RENT
YOU TO COVER NINETEEN FINANCIAL
HARDSHIPS LATER ESTABLISHING
THE STATE RENTAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. SB NINETY ONE
ALLOCATING CALIFORNIA SURE
FEDERAL RENTAL ASSISTANCE FUNDS
TO LOCALITIES TO ACCOMMODATE AN
AFFECTION MORE TRAM EXTENSION
THE CREATION OF THE STATE'S
RENTAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY TO
COMPEL NEWLY SUBMITTED RENTAL
DATA FROM ACROSS CALIFORNIA
WITH EXISTING CITY UNTIL
REGISTRY DATA TO START FILLING
IN THE STATE'S HOUSING DATA GAP
AB ELEVEN EIGHTY WILL REQUIRE
H. CD TO SAVE ALL DATA
COLLECTED BY THE STATE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. AND LOCALLY
RUN RENTAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS
THAT RECEIVE FEDERAL SUBSIDIES
FOR A PERIOD OF AT LEAST TEN
YEARS AB ELEVEN ABLE POSITION
ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS TO
COLLABORATE WITH A ON DATA
ANALYSIS AND FUTURE RESEARCH
USING THE DATA PRESERVATION. OF
PRESERVED WITHIN THIS BILL
SAFEGUARDING THIS CRITICAL
INFORMATION WILL ENCOURAGE
HOUSING POLICY THAT ACTUALLY
SERVES OUR RESIDENTS WITH ME TO
TESTIFY VERY BRIEFLY IS HANNAH
HOLLOWAY WITH TECH EQUITY.
LET'S GO TO YOUR MAINTENANCE.
TO THE OPERATOR. AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'M HANNAH HOLLOWAY
WITH EQUITY CONFIDENCE IN
RECOGNITION OF TODAY'S HEARING
AGENDA ALL TO SAY THAT EQUITY
IS A PROUD SPONSOR OF THIS BILL
WHICH WILL COMPILE HOUSING
INFORMATION JURISDICCIONES
ACROSS THE STATE START BUILDING
A DATA DRIVEN UNDERSTANDING OF
THE RENTAL MARKET. AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THE COMMITTEE MIGHT HAVE. THANK
YOU THERE IS NO OPPOSITION
WITNESS LET'S NOW GO TO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC THERE IS ONE
WITNESS IN THE CHAMBER OR ONE
NUMBER THE PUBLIC WISHES TO
REGISTER YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON
THIS BILL. MARKS DIVERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU MISTER
STARBURSTS LET'S GO TO THE
REMOTE STATION THERE'S NO THERE
ARE LET'S NOW GO TO THE PHONE
LINES. OPERATOR PLEASE ALLOW
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THEY WISH
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT TO TESTIFY.
OUR COMMENTED SUPPORT OF AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN ONE. THEN ZERO.
AND LINE FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY
ONE YOUR MY KIDS UP. GOOD
EVENING THIS MONTH THEY WOULD
CALIFORNIANS DETERRENCE BURKE
THANK. AN LINE OF. FIVE HUNDRED
THIRTY. HOP ON BEHALF OF BILLS
AFFORDABLE FACTOR CALIFORNIA
PRACTICE OF TOP GOLDEN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROVIDER IN
SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. THE LINE FIVE
HUNDRED SEVENTEEN. HI BOB LOPEZ
ON BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
DEMOCRATIC CENTRAL COMMITTEE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE. HELLO ADAM
BOOKBINDER CAMPBELL SPORT. AND
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THIS. WE ASK OF THEIR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC THAT WISH TO
REGISTER OPPOSITION. FOUR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE OF THEM ZERO. AND
ONCE AGAIN THAT IS. ONE ZERO.
AND WE HAVE A COUPLE COMMENTS
COMING THROUGH ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE THEM
WITH LINE NUMBERS. LINE FOUR
HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR YEAR MIKE
IS UP. IF YOU'RE A MEMBER
SKINNER FEEL ON THE HOUSE THE
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION CALORIE CHIEF
PRIEST YOU TO FACT THAT THE
BUILDING NO LONGER MANDATED
RENTAL REGISTRY BILL HOWEVER WE
STILL HAVE CONCERNS.
DISARMAMENT TO ENSURE THAT
INFORMATION SPECIFIC TO PRIVATE
FINANCIAL INFORMATION NOT BE
USED AS THE BASIS FOR ANY OTHER
PURPOSE CLAIMS AGAINST HAVE YOU
PROVIDERS IS WARRANTED PLEASE
READ AND CALORIE KIDS OPPOSED
TO AB ELEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT.
CASES CELL TELLING MISTER CHAIR
GO NINERS AT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OTHERS IN I AM LINE FOR
FORTY SEVEN. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS
CHRIS FOR SAKE WITH WESTERN
MANUFACTURED HOUSING
COMMUNITIES ASSOCIATION I WON'T
REHASH HER LETTER AND IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME BUT WE STILL
REMAIN RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO
IT AT ELEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT- WE
JUST DON'T BELIEVE THAT.
NECESSARY TO CREATE A FRAMEWORK
FOR A STATEWIDE RENTAL REGISTRY
WHEN H. CDS ALREADY
UNDERSTAFFED AND OVERWORKED SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR OPPORTUNITY
AND- I APPRECIATE YOUR
LISTENING. AND MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THIS TIME GREAT BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE I BELIEVE
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION TO MOVE
IT FORWARD. AND THE SECOND. ANY
COMMENTS. I JUST WANNA SAY THE
AUTHOR I KNOW THIS THIS IS BEEN
A- LABOR OF LOVE FOR YOU AND
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
DILIGENCE IN YOUR ENGAGEMENT-
AND YOUR CREATIVITY. WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AND SUPPORTERS AND
OPPONENTS AND WITH THAT HAPPY
TO SUPPORT ANY FINAL WORDS.
RESPECTFUL FOR NAY VOTE MADAM
SECRETARY. MOTION TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMEDIAN APPROPRIATIONS CHU HI
CHIU I SEE ARE TWO CABRIO.
KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY. KILEY
KNOW WARD. WARD I KIRK SILVA HI
FOLKS SILVA AYE WEEKS FIVE
WEEKS I. FIVE TWO ONE. TWO
ITEMS LEFT WILL CALL FILE ITEM
EIGHTEEN AB TWELVE NINETY SEVEN
HOLDEN BY KALRA. THANK YOU
MISTER SHERMAN MEMBERS AB TWO
MOVIES ARE SECOND. SECOND THE
TWILIGHT SEVERAL CLARIFIED THAT
I BANK MAY FINANCE HOUSING AS
PART OF AN OTHERWISE ELIGIBLE
PROJECT ONLY WHEN THE HOUSING
ELEMENT IS REQUIRED FOR THE
OPERATION OF THE PROJECT
ADDITIONALLY NO PART OF THE
HOUSING ELEMENT CAN BE
FINANCED. WITH TAX EXEMPT BONDS
TO ENSURE THERE'S NO CONFLICT
WITH OTHER STATE HOUSING
FINANCE PROGRAMS UNDER CURRENT
LAW FIVE BANK IS AUTHORIZED TO
FINANCE A WIDE VARIETY OF
PUBLIC AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS BUT EXPRESSLY EXCLUDES
HOUSING WITHOUT DEFINING THE
SCOPE OF THAT RESTRICTION OR A
CLEAR INDICATION OF WHAT. THE
ABSOLUTE PROHIBITION ON HOUSING
IN THE AYE BANK ACT CREATES A
FINANCING GAP BY EXCLUDING ALL
PROJECTS THAT CONTAIN ANY
ELEMENTS HOUSING. FOR EXAMPLE
PROJECTS THAT HAVE PROPERTY
HOUSING FOR SCHOOLS
GROUNDSKEEPERS ARE OPERATED
FACILITIES SUMMER AND YOUTH
CAMPS AND TREATMENT RELATED
HOUSING FOR SOCIAL SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS CANNOT BE
FINANCED BY BANK UNDER AB
TWELVE NINETY SEVEN THESE
PROJECTS WOULD BE ELIGIBLE. AS
A FINANCIAL LAST RESORT FOR
MANY PROJECTS THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW AYE BANKS TO ADD AN
IMPORTANT TOOL IN THE STATE'S
TOOL BELT TO INCREASE MORE
TARGETED. AND CREATIVE
APPROACHES TO HOUSING. AT WE
HAVE AMBER MADISON FROM THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION. TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. OF CALLING IN. THANK
YOU RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU LET'S GO TO YOUR MAIN
WITNESS AMBER MADISON. NUMBER
MADISON. AMERICAN HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF. FIFTY BUT I
THINK THAT PROVIDE THE CRUCIAL
FINANCING MECHANISM FOR PUBLIC
ABOUT THE FACILITY THAT
SOMETIMES INCLUDE AN ELEMENT OF
HOW. IT SEEMS THAT. WE CAN
MOSTLY HEAR YOU THINK IT'S OKAY.
OKAY THANK YOU WHAT IS YOUR
SUPPORT AB TWELVE NINETY SEVEN
BECAUSE IT WOULD VERIFY THE
AUTHORITY OF THE I. BANK.
RECOUP FINANCING PROJECTS WITH
HOUSING ELEMENT WHEN THOSE
ELEMENTS ARE NECESSARY FOR THE
OPERATION OF THE PLANT BUDGET.
IT'S CLARIFICATION WILL HAVE
THE EFFECT OF MOVING PROJECTS
ALONG THAT WOULD OTHERWISE HAVE
BEEN PROHIBITED. SINCE EIGHTEEN
NINETY SEVEN BIG CLEAR THAT-
PART HOUSING ELEMENT AND
REFINANCE WITH TAX EXEMPT BONDS.
THIS BILL EXPANDS HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES THE STATE ONE
DURING THOSE TOUGH CONFLICT
WITH OTHER HOUSING FINANCE
PROGRAM. THEREFORE AB FIVE
NINETY SEVEN WILL BE PART OF A
LOOSE MARC HOUSING ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT CALIPHS. FOR THESE
REASONS OKAY I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR EYEBALLS. THERE IS
NO OPPOSITION WITNESS LET'S GO
TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THE
WISH O SPEAK UP OR WISH TO
REGISTER THEIR POSITION ON THIS
ISSUE THERE'S NO ONE HERE IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM LET'S GO TO
THE REMOTE STATION NO ONE AT
THE REMOTE STATION. TO THE
OPERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR MEMBERS
OF PUBLIC THAT WISH TO REGISTER
SUPPORT. FOUR COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF AB. TWELVE NINETY
SEVEN. WE HAVE NO COMMENTS
COMING THROUGH AT THIS TIME.
AND IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
OPPOSITION SIDE. FOUR COMMENTS
IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWELVE
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO RECOMMEND AGAIN. OE
ZERO. WE HAVE NO COMMENT AT
THIS TIME BECAUSE- BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE MR MOTION.
CORRECT THIS MOTION AND A
SECOND HEY FOR COMMENTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
FOR AYE BANK. NICE MADAM
SECRETARY MOTION DO PASSED TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS CHU NóI MET HI.
HI CHU HI THEY ARE JOKES
GABRIELLE KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY
KILEY NO WARD CORPUS SILVA. HI
KIRK SILVA I WICKS WEEKS I WANT.
TO THREE FOUR- YOU DON'T HAVE
TO CONSCIOUS. HE I RECOGNIZE.
THERE WHERE FOR TWO ONE- WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WERE TO ADD UP
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WERE TO ADD ON
THERE IS THAT OKAY GREAT- I
WILL BE PRESENTING MY FINAL
ITEM FILE ITEM TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTEEN I'M ASKING
MR KILEY TO PRESIDE. SECOND.
TWO MINUTES. CALLER EXISTENCE
AB EIGHT SIXTEEN WOULD ADDRESS
THE INCREDIBLE NEED TO NOT
ONLY- CONFRONTS ARE HOMELESS
CRISIS BUT ENSURE REAL
ACCOUNTABILITY- WE KNOW THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE COME
UNDER INTENSE PRESSURE TO
ADDRESS THIS WITH UNFORTUNATELY
THE LATEST PRESSURE POINT FROM
THE COURT'S THERE BEEN LAWSUITS
BROUGHT AGAINST GOVERNMENTS ALL
OVER THE STATE IN MANY
INSTANCES SUCCESSFUL INCLUDING
SOME VERY WIDELY PUBLICIZED
EXAMPLES IN ORANGE COUNTY AND
LOS ANGELES AB EIGHT SIXTEEN
WOULD CREATE A DIFFERENT
PROCESS FOR ENSURING
ACCOUNTABILITY BY REQUIRING THE
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
COMPLETE A CAPS A NEEDS
ANALYSIS TO DETERMINE WHAT
RESOURCES ARE NEEDED. TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS REQUIRING
ALL JURISDICTIONS CITIES AND
COUNTIES AND STATE AGENCIES TO
CREATE ACTIONABLE PLANS TO
REDUCE HOMELESSNESS BY 90% OVER
THE NEXT TEN YEARS AND
ESTABLISHING A HOMELESS
INSPECTOR GENERAL TO ASSURE
ACCOUNTABILITY WITH REGARDS TO
THESE PLANS IN THESE ANALYSES
RATHER THAN WAITING FOR
EXPENSIVE TIME CONSUMING
LAWSUITS TO FORCE THE QUESTION
OF HOW WE ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS
AB EIGHT SIXTEEN WOULD
PROACTIVELY ESTABLISH PLANS
METRICS ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ENFORCEMENT OF PROGRESS TOWARD
THESE PLANS AND WITH THAT. I'D
LIKE TO TURN IT OVER TO A
WITNESS. OUR FIRST WITNESSED ME
PROCEED. THIS IS JULIE SNYDER
GOOD EVENING MISTER TERRY
MEMBERS. GOOD EVENING MISTER
KAREN MEMBERS THIS IS JULIE
SNYDER WITH THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE WE ARE AN INDEPENDENT
NONPROFIT ADVOCATING FOR SOUND
PUBLIC POLICY ON BRAIN HEALTH
ISSUES WE ARE PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR THIS BILL WITH HOUSING
CALIFORNIA CORPORATION FOR
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND
SACRAMENTO MAYOR DARRELL
STEINBERG- AB EIGHT ONE SIX
BOLD APPROACH IS BUILT ON THE
SAME PREMISE AS OTHER AUDACIOUS
GOAL STEP BY POLICY MAKERS.
LIKE GENERATING A 100%
RENEWABLE ENERGY ELIMINATING
GAS POWERED CARS AND MANY MORE.
I MISSED THAT VISIONARY LOCAL
AND STATE LEADERS EXPERIENCED
NONPROFIT AND PRIVATE SECTOR
INNOVATORS CAN. AND WILL RISE
TO MEET AN AMBITIOUS GOAL IF
YOU SAT AT. EIGHTY EIGHT ONE
SIX WILL INSPIRE OUR COMMUNITY
IS IN THE STATE TO USE EVERY
ZONING TOOL EVERY FUNDING
OPPORTUNITY EVERY OUNCE OF
CREATIVITY TO HELP OUR
NEIGHBORS WHO LIVE OUTSIDE. THE
WHOLE ORDER CALIFORNIANS
INGENUITY HAS TACKLED FAR
GREATER CHALLENGES. AN
ASTONISHING 85% OF YOUR
CONSTITUENTS IDENTIFY
HOMELESSNESS AS THE TOP
CHALLENGE FOR GOVERNMENT TO
ADDRESS. AB EIGHT ONE SIX IS
THE EQUITABLE AMBITIOUS GOAL
DRIVEN APPROACH THEY DEMAND AND
THEY DESERVE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU SECOND. GOOD EVENING
MISTER TURN ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ADAM LANE ON THE VICE
PRESIDENT PROGRAMS FOR THE LA
BUSINESS COUNCIL I'M PROUD TO
BE TESTIFYING TODAY IN SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHT SIXTEEN THE L. A.
B. C. OF THE PROGRESSIVE
BUSINESS ADVOCACY AND RESEARCH
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING OVER
FIVE HUNDRED MEMBERS ACROSS
GREATER LOS ANGELES WE HAVE
DEDICATED THE BETTER PART OF
THE PAST TWO DECADES ADVOCATING
FOR SOLUTIONS TO THE WIDENING
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY GAP THAT
HAVE CONTRIBUTED SO GREATLY. TO
THE HOMELESSNESS CRISIS WE
CURRENTLY FACE IN THE MONTHS
BEFORE COMING NINETEEN GRIPPED
OUR NATION WE WORK IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE L. A.
TIMES ON A COMPREHENSIVE PUBLIC
OPINION ON LA I FOUND THAT 95%
OF LA VOTERS IDENTIFIED
HOMELESSNESS AT THE TOP ISSUE
FACING SEVEN CALIFORNIA 66%
CALLED IT AN EMERGENCY
SITUATION AND 75% THE FULL STOP
WISHING A LEGAL RIGHT TO
SHELTER. THAT LAST STATISTIC IS
CRUCIAL HOUSING IS ONE OF THE
FEW PUBLIC GOOD THAT WE TREAT
AS A COMMODITY WITHOUT AN
ENFORCEABLE MANDATE WE LACK A
COMMON GOAL TO WORK TOWARDS AND
INSTEAD WE HAVE A PATCHWORK OF
SOLUTIONS THAT DON'T MEET THE
MAGNITUDE OF OUR CRISIS. BY
MANDATING A STATEWIDE GAP
ANALYSIS AB EIGHT SIXTEEN WILL
FINALLY PAYING A FULL PICTURE
OF THE HOUSING AND RESOURCES
NEEDED FOR HOMELESS POPULATION
AND ALLOW FOR THE DEVELOPMENT
OF A COMPREHENSIVE PLAN BASED
ON DATA. THE BILL ALSO REQUIRED
THAT FOLLOW COUNTIES ACROSS THE
STATE TO THEIR FAIR SHARE LOCAL
LEVEL PLANS ALLOW THE STATE TO
BETTER TARGET LOCALITIES WITH
THE RESOURCES NECESSARY TO MEET
THEIR TARGETS AND REGION BUT
ACROSS OUR TABLE TO ADEQUATE TO
TAKE ADEQUATE MEASURES WILL
FINALLY BEGIN TO PROVIDE
PROPORTIONAL RESOURCES AFRAID
OF CONSEQUENCES FROM THE NEWLY
ESTABLISHED HOMELESSNESS
INSPECTOR GENERAL. AND FINALLY
BY SENDING A CLEAR MANDATE
TIMELINE AB EIGHT SIXTEEN WILL
SPUR INVESTMENT INNOVATION AND
PARTNERSHIPS THAT WILL HELP US
LOWER THE COST OF HOUSING GREAT
JOB HERE IN CALIFORNIA THERE
WAS A SILVER LINING FROM THIS
PANDEMIC IT WAS PROGRAMS LIKE
HOME HE THAT BROUGHT TOGETHER
CROSS SECTORAL STAKEHOLDERS TO
HOUSE PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS QUICKLY AFFORDABLY
AND WITH WRAPAROUND SERVICES.
ALMOST THIS WAS AN EMERGENCY
BEFORE CUT THE NINETEEN AND
WILL CONTINUE TO BE. ONE LONG
AFTER WE NEED TO CREATE MORE
SALUTE GEN WHAT THIS LEVEL
URGENCY. AND CREATIVITY AS WE
HAVE OVER THE YEAR. AB EIGHT
SIX ONE ABOUT. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR AND WE- REQUEST YOUR-
TRADE BEATRIZ. THANK YOU WE
ALSO HAVE ONE WITNESS
TESTIFYING BY PHONE IN
OPPOSITION. YES JOSH DUGGAR
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION AND COUNTY
THE AND ON BEHALF OF MY
COLLEAGUES WITH URBAN COUNTY
CALIFORNIA AND RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA.
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB EIGHT
SIXTEEN BUT HAVE SUGGESTED A
SERIES OF AMENDMENTS AUTHORED
ANY CONSIDERATION WE SHARE THE
GOAL OF IMPROVING THE STATE'S
RESPONSE TO HOMELESSNESS AND
AGREED THAT PLAYING IN THE
MAJOR PART OF THE CHANGE
ACHIEVING MEASURABLE AND
SUSTAINABLE PROGRESS. FOR THAT
REASON WE WORKED
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE AUTHOR
SPONSORED AND STAFF LAST YEAR
ON SIMILAR BILL EIGHTY THIRTY
TO SIXTY NINE. AFTER MANY
VALUABLE CONVERSATIONS WE
REMOVED OPPOSITION TO LAST
YEAR'S BILL WITH THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENT THAT WOULD HAVE TAKEN
UNFORTUNATELY IT DID NOT
CONTINUE IN THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS BUT WE STAND READY TO
FULLY ENGAGE IN A MEANINGFUL
DIALOGUE THIS YEAR. IN THE
HOPES OF REACHING SIMILAR
COMMON GROUND GENERALLY OUR
CONCERNS OF AB EIGHT SIXTEEN IS
THAT IT ALL STARTED BEING A
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS. COUNTY
DEGREE THAT A COMPREHENSIVE
STRATEGY SHOULD INCLUDE ALL THE
ELEMENTS OF CLEARLY ARTICULATED
GOALS DEFINED ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR EACH LEVEL
OF GOVERNMENT COMMENSURATE
ONGOING FUNDING TO FULFILL THE
RESPONSIBILITY YOU CAN ACHIEVE
THE GOALS AND. TRANSPARENT
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES. EIGHTY
EIGHT. INCLUDING A MAY FOR
COUNTY PARTY GOAL BACK BACK.
AND A PLANNING PROCESS
REDUCTION TARGETS. IT ALSO
INCLUDES ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES THROUGH ESTABLISHING A
HOUSING AND HOMELESS AND
INSPECTOR GENERAL ANY COURT
INTERVENTION PROCESS. BUT THE
MEASURE DOES NOT DEFINE ROLES
AND RESPONSIBILITIES FOR EACH
LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT NOR DID
THEY INCLUDE COMMENSURATE
FUNDING TO ACHIEVE GOALS OR TO
MEET THE TRAINING REQUIREMENTS.
AFTER A COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH
WILL HAVE SUBMITTED A SERIES OF
AMENDMENTS TO SUGGEST A MORE
MEASURED APPROACH. INCLUDING
FUNDING THE LOCAL PLANNING
PROCESS. ANALYZED THE LOCAL
PLANT BEFORE SETTING BENCHMARKS
AND COMPELLING ACTION AND
MAKING THE TIMELINE MORE
WORKABLE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF OUR POSITION
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
MEANINGFUL ENGAGEMENT WITH THE
OFFICE STAFF. AND SPONSORS THAT
WE ENJOYED LAST YEAR. THANK YOU
I DON'T SEE ANYONE HERE- IN THE
COULD COMMITTEE ROOM SO
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE PHONE LINES FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
TIME AB. EIGHT SIXTEEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO. NET COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE ZERO. LINE FOUR
HUNDRED NINETY FIVE YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN VERSUS IS ROSS BARKLEY
ON BEHALF OF THE OFFICE OF
SACRAMENTO MAYOR DARRELL
STEINBERG IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHT POINT SIX THANK YOU. LINE.
FOUR HUNDRED FORTY SIX. GOOD
EVENING THIS IS SHERIN REPORT
WITH THE CORPORATION FOR
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING WE ARE CO
SPONSORS OF EIGHTY EIGHT ONE
SIX AND APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHOOSE LEADERSHIP ON
THIS IMPORTANT BATTLE. NINE
THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE.
ANYTHING THAT INTERESTS ON
BEHALF OF HEALTH IN CALIFORNIA
IF TRUMP SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
EIGHT ONE SIX THANK YOU. WINE.
TWO HUNDRED NINETY SEVEN. HI
GOOD TO TREAT THE CONTACT WITH
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS ON BEHALF OF OUR
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. AND THE LINE. FIVE
HUNDRED THIRTEEN YOU'RE MY
COULD OPEN. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR
ME. YES WE CAN HEAR YOU- HOP ON
BEHALF OF BUILD AFFORDABLE
FACTOR CALIFORNIA PART OF THE
POPULAR AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROVIDER IN SUPPORT OF EATING
MARKET AT EIGHTY WILL. AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. YES FOUR THANK YOU I
JUST WANNA THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
DOING THIS- DATA IS EVERYTHING
AND I COULD GO ON AND ON ABOUT
HOW IMPORTANT THIS IS GOING TO
BE FOR OUR PLANNING EFFORTS BUT%
I'LL JUST PARAPHRASE YOGI
BERRA- IF YOU DON'T KNOW WHERE
YOU'RE GOING YOU'RE GOING TO
END UP SOMEPLACE ELSE WE NEED
THIS IT'S GOING TO BE
INCREDIBLY HELPFUL AND IF
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY COME ON
BOARD AS A CO AUTHOR AT SOME
POINT I'D- I'D BE UNDERGOING.
RAPID IDEA. MR SHOOT BECAUSE- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER ABOUT.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THANK YOU TO PASS AS
AMENDED DECLARATIONS DO PASSED
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CARDINAL THANK YOU- TO ISSUE HI.
C. A. R. TO APRIL KALRA COLOR
HI KILEY KILEY NO WORK WHAT I
COOK SILVA THE PROPOSAL BY
WEEKS WEEKS I'D- FIVE TWO ONE.
MEASURE PASSES COLLEAGUES THANK
YOU FOR WE'VE GOT ONE MORE TO
ADD ON TO THAT FILE ITEM.
EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN TWELVE NINETY
SEVEN SEVEN MEMBER BOARD. HI
AND WITH THAT I THINK EVERYONE
HAS ADDED ON TO EVERYTHING THAT
PASSES FIVE ONE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR DILIGENCE AND WORK AND
WITH THAT THIS MEETING IS NOW
ADJOURNED. OR YOU KNOW.